COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
SEEING THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY PRESENT GRAY PRESIDENT
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA.
GROW.
GROW HERE COOLEY.
COOLEY HERE COOPER.
UBER HERE DAILY.
DALY HERE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER HERE GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW HERE MATHIS.
MATHIS HERE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ HERE QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE SALAS.
SALAS YEAR.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED MEMBERS WE'VE GOT TO
PARTS OF YOUR AGENDA TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN.
THE FIRST PART OF THE AGENDA AND
SIGN IN ORDER -- FOLLOWED BY A
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS WITH
THREE ITEMS.
STARS WHO DO WE HAVE I SEE
SENATOR JACKSON.
SENATOR WELCOME COME ON UP.
SO MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA BEGIN
WITH ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP ONE
SIXTY NINE CENTER JACKSON CENTER
WELCOME AND BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
A CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND I'M SO
GLAD THIS ROOM IS WARMED UP IT'S
NOT THE NORMAL MEATPACKING
FEELING THAT YOU GET HERE SO.
FIRST I WANT THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THIS IS SB ONE SIXTY NINE THIS
IS SAY.
THIS IS TRULY A BILL THE CHILL
SIMPLY CLOSES A LOOPHOLE.
THAT HAS EXISTED SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN AFTER THE SANTA BARBARA
OIL SPILL WHEN THE PIPELINE --
BLEW UP AND A CREATED TO A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM ALONG R.
COSTA A PIPELINE THAT HAD DONE.
NOT BEEN PROPERLY.
MAINTAINED WE DID A LEGISLATION
THERE WERE TWO BILLS THAT WERE
DONE TO TRY TO CREATE BETTER
OVERSIGHT AND BETTER FREQUENCY
IN THE MAINTENANCE AND TESTING
BY THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
AND THAT BILL HAS BEEN IN EFFECT
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN BUT THERE'S
BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A LEAK IF
YOU WILL IN THAT LEGISLATION IN
THAT.
THE INDUSTRY HAS AVOIDED THE
RESPONSIBILITIES IMPOSED BY THAT
MEASURE BY.
RUNNING ITS PIPELINES AT SUCH
AND NOT ALL OF THEM MIND YOU BUT
SOME OF THEM RUNNING THE
PIPELINE TO LISTEN 20% OF
CAPACITY AND THUS NOT HAVING TO
MEET.
THE REQUIREMENTS SO THIS BILL.
LOS IS THIS EXEMPTION FROM THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN LAWS FOR
PIPELINES THAT OPERATE AT VERY
LOW PRESSURE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE DOING TO
AVOID HAVING.
TO MEET THE ANNUAL INSPECTIONS
AND KEEPING RECORDS JUST SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT THESE ARE
FUNCTIONING APPROPRIATELY SO
THAT WE DON'T SEE THESE OIL
SPILLS HAPPENING -- ON A REGULAR
BASIS -- BEFORE I GO ANY FURTHER
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE APPRECIATE
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AND THANK THE CHAIR VERY MUCH
FOR HIS WORK IN THE WORK OF THE
STAFF. TO HELP US CRAFT
AMENDMENTS ON THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF RECORDS WHICH
WAS THE A CONCERN EXPRESSED BY
THE INDUSTRY -- IT IS A OF A
MEASURE THAT SIMPLY MAIL.
OF THEY HAVE HAD SENATOR.
THAT CREATES THAT BALANCE SO
THAT THE INDUSTRY WILL HAVE THAT
CONFIDENTIALITY WHILE THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL WILL HAVE THE
INFORMATION HE NEEDSTO DO ITS
JOB -- WITHOUT -- THE THE BILL
DIRECTS OPERATORS TO SPECIFY
RECORDS FOR THE INSPECTION BY
THE OFFICE OF STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
FAIRLY BASIC -- I DON'T THINK
THIRTY CURVEBALLS HERE WHICH IS
CLIENT TRYING TO CLOSE AN
EXEMPTION MAINTAIN THE
CONFIDENTIALITY THAT THE
INDUSTRY SIX AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR HELP IN IN ACHIEVING THAT
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE WE DID HAVE.
A WITNESS HERE TODAY'S OUT ILL
SO -- IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SIR WERE HERE -- FROM
YOUR WITNESS -- THIS JUST STAFF
TO ASSIST IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
WE WILL HEAR FROM ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON LOUIS CENTERS WITH THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION -- WE'RE
ALL ABOUT PIPELINE SAFETY --
DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT --
READING THE ANALYSIS WERE WERE
WERE VERY HAPPY TO SEE THE THE
THE THE BALANCE -- TO PROTECTING --
CRITICAL INFORMATION -- FROM
SECURITY CONCERN PURPOSES AND
THAT WE LOOK FOR TO SEEN THOSE
AMENDMENTS IMPRINT OF THE BILL
DOES GET OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY --
AND WE DO APPRECIATE YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR WORKING
ON THIS THANK YOU.
OKAY REALLY DIVISIONAL
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN PEONY
THOMAS RIPS IN THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT DRAMAS SOCIAL ASIAN
AND AND FOR THE BREVITY OF TIME
ALLOW ME TO ECHO.
THE COMMENTS OF MY COUNTERPART
AT WESTERN STATES -- BUT ALSO
CHAIRED MIXTURE OF PLEASE LET ME --
ALLOW MY THINGS TO GO OUT TO
YOUR STAFF -- BEEN AN
OUTSTANDING JOB AND IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU AS
WELL AS YOUR STAFF ON THIS BILL.
A WE WERE MOVE OPPOSITION
PROVIDED THAT THE COULD
COMMITMENTS IN COMMITTEE COME ON
PRATT.
AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU INITIAL -- PUBLIC
INPUT OR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER COOLEY A SECOND FROM
MISTER COOPER -- THIS IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MISTER CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR JUST BRIEFLY.
IF WE COULD -- CLARIFY THE
STATUS OF THE AMENDMENTS ARE
THEY GONNA BE TAKEN AT THE NEXT
STOP AND APPROPRIATIONS OR
WHAT'S THE STATUS.
YES WE WILL TAKE WE'VE AGREED TO
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THAT WERE
PROPOSED AND THEY WILL BE TAKEN --
I ASSUME IF IT'S GOING TO A
PROBES -- BUT DOUBLE TAKE BEFORE
THE MATTER SHIRT ON THE FLOOR
BETWEEN OUT NOW AND APPROACH SO
WOULD ARRIVE IN APPROACH WHICH
DALY AND WOULD BE AMENDED THANK
YOU.
APPRECIATE CLARIFICATION THE
RIGHT HERE.
OKAY SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT HI GRAY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONDS UP [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
THROW NO.
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE COOPER
[inaudible]
DALY.
DALY I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MELINDA.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO NOT VOTING SALAS -- FILE
AND ON FIRST OF ALL I QUIRK
SILVA ADDING ON I OKAY WE'VE GOT
INTO FIVE VOTES.
IT WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS CHAIR
MEMBERS.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE -- TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION MOST OF THE
SECOND.
SEARCH A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT HI GRAY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
ON TOP.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER.
COOPER I DAILY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS HI MELINDA.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RIVAS
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AT THIS POINT MEMBERS REMOVED
ITEM ONE ON YOUR AGENDA ACR ONE
OR TWO LAST MISTER BIGELOW. TO
PRESENT -- THE RESOLUTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
MATHIS.
THE SECOND FOR MISTER GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON.
ARE YOU HAVING A PLEASANT DAY
JUST WANT TO CHECK THIS OUT AND
GET THE FEEL OF THE ROOM FIRST.
HAVE A GREAT DAY MISTER PRESSURE.-THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WELL I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ACR ONE OR TWO
WHICH ARE JUST THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO ADOPTTHE
RULES FOR THE USE OF MASS TIMBER
PRODUCTS. FOR RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDING CONSTRUCTION.
CALIFORNIA HAS A SEVERE
MORTALITY CRISIS DUE TO THE
DROUGHT AND TO THE WESTERN BARK
BEETLE WHICH IS CAUSING MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
TREES.
PER YEAR ANNUALLY TO DIE.
YES I SAID DIE AND IF YOU GO TO
THE SEARS YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT IT ISN'T MUCH FOR YOU.
TO HARD FOR YOU TO SEE THE DEATH
AND DEVASTATION THAT'S OCCURRING.
THE DEAD -- TREE BUILD UP IN OUR
FORCE FUELS IS INCREASING AND
THE THREAT OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES SUCH AS WE'VE SEEN --
IN THIS LAST COUPLE OF YEARS IS
JUST HORRIFIC.
THE PARADISE FIRE AS AN EXAMPLE
COVERED OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES DESTROYING NEARLY
NINETEEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND HOMES WERE
LOST.
AND SADLY EIGHTY SIX LIVES IN
NOT FIRE WERE LOST.
OVERGROWN FORESTS ARE
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO THE TREE
MORTALITY CRISIS THE SEER
WATERSHED SUPPLY AND MUCH OF THE
STATE WATER FOR FARMS IN URBAN
AREAS [inaudible]
ARE OVERGROWN.
THAT WATER IS BEING ABSORBED BY
TREES INSTEAD OF GOING TO THE
MUCH NEEDED AREAS THAT ARE
REFERRED.
TO ACR ONE OUT TO ASK THE OFFICE
OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
SIMPLY ADOPT RULES FOR THE USE
OF MASS TIMBER PRODUCTS.
BY DOING SO CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
ABLE TO EXPAND ITS MARKET FOR
THE IN STATE WOOD PRODUCTS AND
WOULD HELP.
PROVIDE LESS FUELS FOR WILDFIRES
AND REDUCE THE CARBON EMISSIONS.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS KRISTIN
CALL PAKI WITH A CALIFORNIA
FOREST ASSOCIATION AND SHE'S
HERE TO ASSISTING ALSO GIVE
ADDED TESTIMONY.
MISTER CHAIR WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE I'D LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
MASS TIMBER IS A CATEGORY OF
FRAMING USING PREFABRICATED
SOLID ENGINEERED WOOD PANELS
THAT ARE LIGHT WEIGHT YET VERY
STRONG WITH HIGH ACOUSTIC FIRE
SEISMIC AND THERMAL PERFORMANCE.
IT'S FAST AND EASY TO INSTALL
MASS TIMBER OFFERS DESIGN
FLEXIBILITY AS WELL AS LOW
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
CROSS LAMINATED TIMBER IS
PROBABLY THE MOST COMMONLY USED
FORM OF MASS TIMBER.
THE BENEFITSA MASKED MEMBER
INCLUDE REDUCED ENERGY
CONSUMPTION TIMBERS THE BUILDING
MATERIAL WITH THE LOWEST ENERGY
CONSUMPTION.
IT'S FIRE RESISTANT MASS TIMBER
PRODUCTS RESIST THE EFFECTS OF
FIRE THROUGH THE CHARRING OF THE
OUTER LAYER BUT INSULATING THE
UNBURNED WOULD AT THE CORE THAT
MAINTAINS THE STRENGTH OF THE
PRODUCT.
REDUCE CO TWO EMISSIONS CROSS
LAMINATED TIMBER HAS A LIGHTER
CARBON FOOTPRINT SINCE WOOD
PRODUCTS CONTINUE TO STORE
CARBON ABSORBED BY THE TREES
WHILE THEY WERE GROWING.
AND WHAT IS THE ONLY MAJOR
BUILDING MATERIAL THAT GROWS
NATURALLY AND IS RENEWABLE.
ACR IS CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
ACTIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE INTERNATIONAL CODE COUNCIL.
WITH PASSED SB EIGHT FIFTY NINE
WHICH ESTABLISHED THE WOOD
PRODUCTS WORKING GROUP.
GOVERNOR BROWN'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
BE FIFTY TWO EIGHTEEN DIRECTED
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO REVIEW
THE APPROVED TALL WOULD BUILDING
PROPOSAL.
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN APPROPRIATE MONEY TO
IMPLEMENT A MASKED MEMBER
BUILDING COMPETITION IN
CALIFORNIA CONSISTENT WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORCE CARBON PLAN.
AND FINALLY IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ICC RELEASE
VOTING RESULTS ON CO CHANGES
COULD CHANGE PROPOSALS AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH INCLUDED
THE PASSAGE OF OF PACKAGE OF
FOURTEEN TALL MAST TIMBER
BUILDING CODE CHANGE PROPOSALS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
TREES THE COCA BEHALF OF A
COMPANY CALLED COULD TERRA THEY
ARE A BUILDER OF RESIDENTIAL
INDUSTRIAL COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES
AND HAVE BEEN USING A LOT OF CLT
ENTER BIG FAN OF THE TECHNOLOGY
SO THANK YOU AND WE DO.
ENCOURAGE YOUR YES ABOUT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROBERT SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THEN KERN CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
OF CARPENTERS MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
PLEASE PORTIS BILL NOBODY IN
THIS LEGISLATURE NEEDS AN
EDUCATION ON THE CRISIS IN THE
IN THE FARCE.
WHAT'S ALSO NOT BEING DEALT WITH
IS THE LOSS OF MIDDLE CLASS
WE'VE GONE DOWN FROM A HUNDRED
FORTY MILLS TWO TWENTY SEVEN IN
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS AND IT WAS
ALREADY ON DECLINE WE CAN
REBUILD THE MIDDLE CLASS IN
THESE RURAL AREAS.
AND START TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS IN THE IN THE FOREST
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE CARLSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SO SHOULD
CALIFORNIA LOGGERS PEOPLE DO THE
WORK LOGGING LOG TRACKING LOG
ROAD BUILDING. FOR THE REASONS
ARTICULATED PARTICULAR BY THE
WITNESS AHEAD OF ME THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON INJURED BECAUSE
IT ARE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT NURTURE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
A DIGITAL SPORT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION.
CHARLIE RAY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION DUSTER MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION A TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR ACCURATE READY MIX CONCRETE.
AND DETRIMENTAL PRODUCERS -- WE
RESPECTIVELY A POST AND
RECOGNIZING THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A LOT OF BENEFIT FOR THE
REAL ECONOMY SOUTH HEALTHY
FORESTCLIMATE.
IS CERTAINLY REPRESENTS A AREA
OF INNOVATION OUR CONCERN IS
MAINLY WITH PROCESS JUST THAT
YOU KNOW THE INTERNATIONAL C¡
COMMISSION IS.
ADOPTED -- CODE IN THAT PROCESS
IS USUALLY THAT THE CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES AND TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
LOOK AT WHAT PIECES ARE PARTS
ARE OUR OUR POST APPROPRIATE --
AND AND SPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THIS IS FOR TALL WITH BUILDINGS
UPDATED STORIES WE THINK THAT'S
GET.
CAREFUL REVIEW -- THAT PROCESS
IS ALREADY UNDER WAY AT THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE --
SARCOS ARE JUST WE JUST DON'T
WANT TO TRY TO PREJUDGE THE
OUTCOME ON WHAT THEY WOULD
RECOMMEND.
THANK YOU A DIGITAL TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NUMBER BRING IT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
MEMBERS [inaudible]
WHICH COOLEY.
I JUST WANT.
TO NOTE THAT OVER THE YEARS --
WE AND THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
ADDRESSED MANY BILLS -- ON
BUILDING CODE ISSUES EVEN WHEN
THEY'RE AND FERMENT.
DEALING WITH EARTHQUAKE SAFETY.
A MOMENT WELL PROBLEM SINCE AND
TALL BUILDINGS AFTER THE
NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE ALL MANNER
VERY SOON WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
WILL.
CHOOSE TO ENTER THE CONVERSATION
ON BEHALF OF ISSUES IT WAS ALSO
TRUE IN THE BROWN ERA ON GREEN
BUILDINGS AND IT.
I CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THERE IS A
MINISTRY OF PROCESS.
BUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
OFTEN APPROVED MEASURES US BEST
FIND OUR INTEREST IN THE SUBJECT.
WITH ADDITIONAL ARE QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
GRAY.
I GRAY I'D BIGELOW HI BIGELOW
AYE AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA UP.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELINDA.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
THAT'S FOURTEEN VOTES.
IT IS OUT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
HAVE A STRETCH LONG ENOUGH TO WE
HAVE A SENATOR YEAH MR BIGELOW
DO A GOOD JOB OF STRETCHING.
THIS TIME MEMBERS WE ARE
AWAITING THE ARRIVAL OF OUR
FRIENDS FROM THE RED CARPET THE
STATE SENATORS.
AND WE'RE GONNA GIVE THEM --
FIVE MINUTES WE'RE GONNA TALK
AMONGST OURSELVES AND THEN IF
THEY'RE NOT HERE AT THE END OF
FIVE MINUTES THEN MAYBE THEY CAN
WAIT TILL NEXT YEAR FOR WHATEVER
THEIR BILLS ARE
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE HAVE FOUND AT
LEAST ONE CENTER THAT CARES
ABOUT HIS BILLS -- SENATOR
PLEASE SIR APPROACH WE'RE GONNA
BRING THE COMMITTEE BACK TO
ORDER AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE
MEMBERS TO ITEM -- LEFT ON YOUR
AGENDA SB.
SEVEN SEVENTEEN ADVERTISING
SENATOR PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES CURRENT LAW
OFFERS A TIGHT HOUSE EXEMPTION
TO ALCOHOL MANUFACTURES.
ALLOWS THEM TO BUY ADVERTISING
SPACE AT STADIUMS AND SPORTS
ARENAS.
SB SEVEN SEVENTEEN CODIFIES
EXISTING PRACTICE BY EXPLICITLY
INCLUDING CRAFT DISTILLERS IN
THIS EXEMPTION.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE CHRIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ARTISANAL -- DISTILLERS GUILD.
MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SIR WOULD YOU LIKE. TO EIGHT
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
YES -- THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK -- THAT'S
GONE INTO THIS BILL IN
APPRECIATE THE CENTERS HELP AND
WE JUST WANTED TO GET A BILL AND
TO CLARIFY AND HELP SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT GO ALONG WITH.
CRAFT DISTILLERS NOT BEING
INCLUDED -- IN SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE FOR ABC.
THANK YOU ANY -- ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING THAT ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
WELL CENTER YOU DON'T HAVE AN
ENEMY AIRCRAFT.
I'M SORRY.
I SAID YOU DON'T HAVE A LIVELY
CROWD NO I GUESS NOT.
OKAY -- WILL BRING BACK THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER HIGH DAILY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER HI JOAN SO YOU'RE
AYE LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS I THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN
VOTES -- AND IS OUT.
THANK YOU CENTER JONES -- IT
LOOKS LIKE THE SENATOR HAS
STARTED A AVALANCHE OF SENATOR
SHOWING UP [inaudible]
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM TEN
MEMBERS ON YOUR AGENDA THIS IS
SB SIX AVENUE AWHILE CONCERN
REQUIRE TO PRESENT MOVE HIS BILL.
YOU HAVE A MOTION.
AND THE SECOND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I'M NOT
REPEAT THE CUSTOMER THAT CENTER
WIENER -- JUST SAID TO ME SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MISTER
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING US TO BE HERE
LONG STORY SHORT SB SIX SEVENTY
WOULD REQUIRE PROVIDED TO TELL
COMMITTEE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES IN NOTIFY CALLAWAY S.
WHENEVER THERE IS A NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE OUTAGE.
OR ANY OUTAGE AFFECTING
EMERGENCY WARNING CAPABILITIES
HITTING THE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES CREATING THRESHOLD
WITHIN SIXTY MINUTES OF THE
OUTAGE.
CALORIE S. WITHIN BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR NOTIFYING THE AFFECTED LOCAL
COUNTY -- YES THIS WOULD ENSURE
ALL THE NECESSARY EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS.
AGAIN INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
KEEP RESIDENTS SAFE MEMBERS I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
CENTER NIELSEN WHO IS -- OUR
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ON THIS AT
TODAY MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE THE
SYSTEM CHAIR OF MISTER JIM NAGEL --
FROM THE COUNTY CINEMA THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE YOU SIR AND
THEN WE HAVE MISS HANLEY OF
FIREMAN SEE COMMUNICATIONS
MANAGER FOR KERN COUNTY HERE
TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
OKAY TO HAVE ADDITIONAL --
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
WE DON'T GOOD AFTERNOON YEAH MY
NAME IS JIM NOVEL AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT -- SHERIFF
MARQUESSATE WISHED YOU COULD BE
HERE TODAY THAT. TO SPEAK BUT
I'M FORTY HE COULDN'T MAKE IT --
SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
COME AND EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT OF
SB.
SIX SEVENTY AND JUST WANT TO
SPEAK AS YOU KNOW IT'S NO SECRET
ARE STATES BEEN JUST DEVASTATED
BY WILDFIRES OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND ESPECIALLY
OUR COUNTY IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WAS.
WAS HIT REALLY HARD AND ONE OF
THE THINGS I LEARNED WHEN I WAS
DEALING WITH THE FIRES WAS THAT
COMMUNICATIONS WAS CRITICAL AND
AND INFORMATION COMING GOING WAS
CRITICAL AND FOR US YOU KNOW ME
PARTICULARLY MY JOB WAS -- TO
COORDINATE OVER -- FOUR HUNDRED
INCOMING UNITS.
IN MUTUAL AID AND WHAT WE
LEARNED IS AS TOWERS WENT DOWN
WE DIDN'T GET THE INFORMATION
QUICKLY AS LINES ARE BURNED WE
CAN GET THE INFORMATION SO WE
COULDN'T ADJUST OUR RESOURCES
ACCORDINGLY.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS IS ALL OF
OUR ALERT AND WARNING SYSTEMS GO
OUT OVER TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
SO IF THERE WERE AREAS THAT WERE
AFFECTED THEN WE NEED TO MOVE
UNITS AT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SO JUST FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND
STUFF TO GET THEM OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
ON THE PRESIDENT OF THEIR
COMMUNICATION SECTION AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AS A COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER FOR
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT ONE THAT
RECENTLY EXPERIENCED A VERY
LARGE EARTHQUAKE IN OUR COUNTY.
WE DID LOSE NINE ONE ONE FOR A
BRIEF PERIOD OF TIME IN
RIDGECREST.
AND FOR OUR CITIZENS WHEN THEY
HAVE AN EMERGENCY THEY EXPECT TO
PICK UP THE PHONE AND REACH US
RIGHT AWAY.
SECOND SEEM LIKE MINUTES MINUTES
LIKE OURS.
BEING ABLE TO KNOW AHEAD OF TIME
OR AS SOON AS POSSIBLE WHAT'S
HAPPENING BEING ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION OUT TO OUR CITIZENS
ON WHAT TO DO IF THEY HAVE AN
EMERGENCY.
IT'S CRITICAL TO THE WAY WE
OPERATE WEIRD YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHECK YOUR
ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA AND THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL BEERS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
ANTHONY GOOD SALAS REPRESENTING
THE CITY AT THOUSAND OAKS AND WE
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD WE SUPPORT IT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF COURSE ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT -- GOOD
AFTERNOON RUSSELL NOVAK ON ON
BEHALF OF THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON PENSION PALMER ON
BEHALF OF MARIN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY DOWN
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS BERNIE
ROSS WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT IF AMENDED SO
I WANT TO BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT AN
AMENDMENT -- INANIMATE DEALS
WITH THE EPA REGULATIONS SO WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF YES ADOPTING A
P. REGULATION SOMETHING WE HAD
ASKED MR REQUIRE.
FOR AND HE HAS DONE AND SO WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT --
PROCESS WISE SO IN IN DECEPTION
THOSE -- A P. REGULATIONS
THERE'S A DATE CERTAIN BY WHEN
THOSE REGULATIONS NEED TO BE IN
PLACE LAST JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY OUR OUR CONCERN IS
INITIATING THAT PROCESS RIGHT
NOW YOU WILL BE GETTING A BILL
FROM THE SENATE AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR WHICH TALKS ABOUT EMERGENCY
REGULAR TO TALK ABOUT
REGULATIONS FOR WILDFIRES.
IN THAT RATE IN THAT PROPOSAL
THERE'S L<c.cyan>G SAYS SAYS WITHIN</c>
FOURTEEN DAYS OF THAT BILL
BECOMING OPERATIVE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE CAN THE
OFFICE WILL START ESTABLISHING
THIS APA PROCESS WE LIKE THAT
DATE CERTAINTY SO WE WILL LIKELY
SEE SOMETHING SIMILAR HERE AND
THIS PROPOSAL THAT WILL DIRECT
CAL -- YES TO BEGIN THAT EPA
PROCESS WITH IN A TIMELY FASHION --
EITHER FOURTEEN DAYS OR BEFORE
THE END OF JANUARY -- THE OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT'S IN THE BILL
CURRENTLY THERE'S AN EXCEPTION
EXEMPTION TO THE APA PROCESS IN
SUBSECTION BE.
IN SUBSECTION BE OF THE APA
PROCESS SAYS THAT EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS NEED TO BE ADOPTED
IF YOU CAN JUSTIFY A CERTAIN --
ELEMENT THAT NEEDS TO BE INDEED
THE URGENCY AND AND HOW YOU PLAN
TO RESPOND TO THAT ARTS AND
ISSUE -- AND WE LIKE THAT WE
THINK THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
GOVERNMENT'S PIECE OF THE APA
PROCESS MORE IMPORTANTLY IN THAT
SUBSECTION BE THOUGH IS THAT
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS ARE ONLY
GOOD FOR CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS.
THEN AFTER THAT YOU MUST RE
JUSTIFY WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
WHY HAVEN'T YOU MAY PROGRESS IN
YOUR OTHER -- REGULAR RULE
MAKING PROCESS THIS.
YES IF YOU WOULD MIND COMING UP
TO THE FRONT.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS POTENTIALLY I KNOW
BOTH COX'S HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION OKAY SO THE
MAYBE SOME FALSE IF YOU COME UP
HERE.
AND BE AVAILABLE. TO ARTICULATE
FURTHER.
YOU CAN FINISH YOUR COMMENT YEAH
AND THAT THAT ESSENTIALLY WAS
THE END OF MY COMMENT TO CUT IT
UP THE COMMENT WAS THAT -- THERE
ARE SOME GOOD GOVERNANCE
PROVISIONS IN THE APA PROESS
AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE GOOD
GOVERNANCE PROVISIONS.
PREVAIL SO BY PROVIDING AN
EXEMPTION IN THE PROCESS --
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS COULD GO
ON FOREVER SO WHAT ARE NOT
TOTALLY FOR BUT YOU CAN KEEP
EXTENDING THE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS SO.
THERE ARE SOME PROTECTIONS IN
THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
IS BEING ADOPTED IS BEING
ADOPTED CONSISTENT WITH WHATEVER
THE EMERGENCY IS SO THAT WAS THE
END OF OUR REQUESTS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON PROCEED TIER THE
WIRELESS ASSOCIATION WE ARE WE
TO OUR SUPPORT OF AMENDED WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING.
EXTENSIVELY WITH THAT SENTIMENT
WIRE AND HIS STAFF AND THE AND
JUST OF A COUPLE LITTLE THINGS
THAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE WE
APPRECIATE THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS.
THAT REMOVES -- A AS A THRESHOLD
THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS SOME
PLACES IT WITH THE APPROXIMATE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA WE THINK THAT
MAKES THE BILL MUCH MORE
WORKABLE WE ARE THERE'S ANOTHER
PROVISION IN THE BILL WHAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE THAT CHANGE TO MAKE
IT MORE CONSISTENT -- THERE'S
ANOTHER A PROVISION IN TERMS OF
THE CONTACT PERSON THE BILL NOW
SAYS A SPECIFIC PERSON WE THINK
THAT THAT SHOULD BE DONE IN A
MORE GENERAL WAY MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY TO CALL.
AND THAT THEY'RE ALWAYS
AVAILABLE -- AND THAT WITH THAT
I THINK THAT WILL WILL BE FINE
WITH THE BILL -- AGAIN WE
RESPECT AND AND HAVE BUT MOST OF
STEEP FOR FIRST RESPONDERS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS.
THAT THIS WORKS.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR -- ARE YOU CLEAR ON WHAT
I KNOW WE HAVE SUPPORT FROM IN A
POSITION FROM THE COMMITTEE --
CONSISTENT WITH SOME TESTIMONY
WHICH IS GIVEN THEIR THAT
RELATES.
TO ONLY MAKE SURE I GET THAT
RIGHT WHAT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE THE REALLY THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS THE THE REGULAR
RULEMAKING PROCESS -- ALONG WITH
A LOAD I NOTICED A LITTLE
TRICKERY FIRST AND THEN OF
COURSE ALLOWING CALLOW YESTER
DOCTORS REGULATIONS IF THEY
CAN'T MEET THE TORCH WENT DEAD
LIKE CONSISTENT WITH YOUR GOALS
I BELIEVE.
THAT SOUND FAMILIAR TO YOU.
SO IF IT'S OKAY MATURED LIKE TO
BE A COMMENT ON THAT.
ABSOLUTELY OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO LOOK.
I'LL TALK ABOUT THE THE CUSTOMER
SECTION THE CUSTOMER SECTION IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH I SPECIFICALLY
IN SO -- WHERE -- MISTER
CROSSING WAS DISCUSSING RATHER
THAN THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS
THAT ARE IMPACTED WE'RE GOING TO
TALK CITIES.
COUNTY SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO ADD THAT WE'VE
ALREADY CLEANED UP THERE'S ONE
ADDITIONAL SECTION AND WE NEED
TO BE A CLEAN THAT UP.
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO FIGURE
THAT OUT ON THE ISSUE OF IN
INDIVIDUAL TO CALL I WANT TO
SPEAK FOR THE INDUSTRY BUT
THEY'RE VERY WORRIED THAT IT'S
GONNA BE. ONE INDIVIDUAL AND
WANTING TO BE ABLE TO BE
SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
THAT'S ANOTHER CLEAN UP THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH.
ON THE ISSUES AMER EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS I WENT TAKE A MOMENT
TO SPEAK ON THAT.
SO HERE'S WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO
RIGHT NOW.
SO IT WOULD REQUIRE A WE ASKED
TO COMPLETE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS BY JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY BY THE WAY THE
RECENT EMERGENCY ALERT BILL THAT
WE PASSED LAST YEAR.
WENT THROUGH THE SAME EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS.
AND WE ARE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH.
I'D LIKE TO TALK TO YOU BUT WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS REQUIRED WHEN
IT COMES TO EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS.
THE LEGISLATURE IT'S IMPLEMENTED
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS FOR FAR
LESS THAN THE CRISIS WE ARE HERE
TODAY.
LAST YEAR ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE
DIED. ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE DIED.
FROM WILD AND FIRES.
MAJORITY OF THEM DID NOT GET THE
ALERT.
IN FACT WHAT WE KNOW IS WHEN YOU
ARE DOING AN OPT IN SYSTEM
THIRTY MAYBE 40% ARE RECEIVING
AN ALERT.
THIS THE LEGISLATURE IS ADOPTED
MERCY REGULATIONS ON BINGO.
WE'VE ADOPTED EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS ON PRIVATE OUTDOOR
CAMPING PROGRAMS.
WE'VE ADOPTED EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS ON WATER EFFICIENCY.
IF THERE WAS EVER A TIME.
AND I WILL SPEAK PERSON TO THIS
AND I DO NOT NEED TO GET
EMOTIONAL BUT IF THERE WAS EVER
A TIME TO BE ABLE TO ADOPT
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS THE TIME
IS NOW WHEN IT COMES. TO NINE
ONE ONE OUTAGES AND EMERGENCY
ALERTS.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WE SEEN
THE TWO LARGEST FIRES IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY IN FACT LAST
YEAR.
SENATOR GALLAGHER CENTER NIELSEN
SAW THE LARGEST FIRE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY MOST DESTRUCTIVE IN THE
MOST DEADLY.
AND OVER A HUNDRED FOLKS DIED.
ROOM WHENEVER MERCY REGULATIONS
ARE DONE THERE IS AN EXISTING
PUBLIC COMMENT WINDOW AND I'LL
JUST BE CANDID THE REASON WHY
THERE ARE SOME THAT DON'T LIKE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS IS BECAUSE
THE COMMENT WINDOW IS FIVE DAYS.
THAT'S THE REAL REASON IT'S FIVE
DAYS.
FURTHER IN ORDER TO MAKE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS PERMITTED
THE OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD ON A
PARALLEL EFFORT AND WE'VE
ALREADY CHECKED THIS WITH -- YES.
BUT THROUGH THE REGULAR
RULEMAKING PROCESS WITH A FORTY
FIVE DAY PUBLIC COMMENT WINDOW
THIS IS BECAUSE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS ONLY LASTS FOR ONE
YEAR.
SB SIX SEVENTY DOES NOT EXEMPT --
YES FROM ANY OF THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS REQUIRED ON THE
EMERGENCY RULE MAKING PROCESS NO
ONE INJURED RIGHT HERE RESPOND
TO THIS ISSUE AND AGAIN I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN WORKING.
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THAT WE
WORKING TOGETHER.
DURING THE CAMP FIRE THAT BEGAN
AROUND SIX THIRTY THREE AM.
THE STATE RECEIVED THE FIRST
NOTICE IT NINE ONE ONE WAS OUT.
FIVE HOURS AFTER THE FIRE
STARTED.
PARADISE WAS ALREADY LOST.
WE DID NOT KNOW THAT NINE ONE
ONE OR BIRDS THERE'S FOR HIDDEN
FOLKS.
WHEN IT CAME TO THE TUBS FIRE IN
MY OWN BACKYARD?
IT BEGAN AT NINE FORTY THREE PM
ON OCTOBER EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE FCC
NOTIFIED THE STATE SIX HOURS SIX
HOURS AFTER THE FIRE STARTED.
PEOPLE DO NOT KNOW THEY COULDN'T
CALL 911- THEY WERE NOT
RECEIVING EMERGENCY ALERTS.
IF THERE WAS EVER A TIME TO BE
ABLE TO ADOPT EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS WITH THE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES IT'S AFTER
ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE DIED ON THE
WORST WILDLAND FIRE IN OUR STATE
HISTORY.
SO WE ARE WORKING WITH INDUSTRY
I GIVE YOU MY WORD AND WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY YOU HAVE MY PROMISE
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL THIS
IS COMMON SENSE OF WHAT I WOULD
ASK.
A IN THE DOES INTO THE CHAIR TO
BE ABLE TO LEAVE THIS BILL
INTACT BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO
MEAN CANDIDLY LIVES SAVED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA NINE I NEGLECTED TO
MENTION MISTER CHAIR -- SIMILAR
GALLAGHER WHO HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL I
APOLOGIZE IN THEIR GALLAGHER FOR
YOUR ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL --
AND I WOULD -- ASK THE CHAIR TO
BE A TO KEEP THIS BILL INTACT AS
IS ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
IT'S CRITICAL. TO GET ADOPTED
PRIOR TO NEXT FIRE SEASON
[inaudible]
SIR -- BEFORE WE GO TO QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS LET'S TAKE LET'S
FINISH OUR TESTIMONY I WE HAVE
BEEN OF A SIDE BAR THAT WE HAVE
ANY -- TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AND WE HAVE SUPPORT
OF AMENDED WE HAVE SOME SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN AT THIS TIME IT'S GREAT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS. FOR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
COMMENTS CONCERNS [inaudible]
MR GALLAGHER -- YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I I JUST WANT OF
FACTLY AGREE WITH WHAT WAS
STATED.
BY THE SENATOR HERE -- YOU KNOW
WE SAW THIS FIRST HAND THAT --
YOU KNOW PEOPLE DID NOT GET
ALERTS -- THAT ARE EMERGENCY
[inaudible]
NOTIFICATION -- HAS GAPS IN IT
HAS SOME SERIOUS GAPS IN IT --
AND SO THIS BILL I THINK IS A
VERY REASONABLE WAY OF TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
TOO YOUR WORK THROUGH HELLO YES
HAVE THE INDUSTRY WORK TO CALLOW
YES TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW --
WHEN THERE ARE OUTAGES -- THAT
AFFECT -- NINE ONE ONE YOU KNOW.
HERE ONE OF THE BEST THINGS WE
CAN DO IS GIVE PEOPLE ALL THE
TOOLS AND THE KNOWLEDGE THAT HE
AT LEAST GIVE THEM THE KNOWLEDGE
OF OF OF WHAT LIMITATIONS ARE.
WHILE WE'RE ALSO WORKING TO
IMPROVE.
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION AND MAKE
THAT MUCH STRONGER AND MAKE SURE
THAT ALL MEDIA THIS -- ARE
WORKING TO TO HELP PEOPLE GET
THEM THE LATEST AND BEST
INFORMATION IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY -- SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT I WOULD ASK -- THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY WITH IN A LOT OF WORK --
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY ON THIS AS
WELL -- SO AGAIN I THINK IT'S AS
HE SAID VERY WELL.
IF NOT OW I DON'T KNOW WHEN
BECAUSE WE WE WE CLEARLY NEED TO
TO ACT ON THIS QUICKLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
THIS REGULAR.
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
MAYBE YOU COULD HELP US.
AS YOU WERE ARTICULATING THEIR
YOU WERE SHARING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THE PARADISE FIRE.
WHICH YOU KNOW I JUST SPOKE A
FEW MINUTES AGO TALKING ABOUT
THE THE FOLKS AND AND AND I ACR
THAT I'M CARRYING -- AND THE
IMPACTS OF WITH THAT.
HAPPENED THERE THE GIVEN THAT
SAID EVEN WITH YOUR OWN TUBS
FIRE BOTH OF AND THE COMMON
LINKAGE.
NO REVERSE NINE ONE ONE NO NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM.
IN THOSE CASES WOULD HAVE WORKED.
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM WENT DOWN
[inaudible]
RAPIDLY.
THEREFORE THOSE PEOPLE WOULD
HAVE NEVER GOTTEN THEIR NOTICES
EVEN UNDER THIS BILLS --
SYNOPSIS -- AND THE NINETY
MINUTE NOTICE FOR YOU.
TO HAVE FROM THE TELCOS TO GET
BACK TO YOU.
IS IS ALMOST UNDOABLE -- JUST.
A LITTLE HISTORY THERE ARE
BECAUSE IT TAKES AWHILE TO
ACTUALLY VERIFY [inaudible]
THAT'S THAT'S ONE JUST KIND OF
STATEMENT -- THE OTHER ISSUE IS
I THINK THE QUALIFICATION OF
WHAT IS A COMMUNITY MEAN OR WHAT
IS THAT I CENTRIC AREA MEAN IS
THAT.
ONE USER FOR USERS.
IS IT MORE THAN THAT.
THAT'S THAT'S A QUESTION.
AND THE AND THE IF I COULD ALL
ALL AT A SECOND QUESTION ON THIS
IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT
SO I DON'T COMPOUND.
NO GO AHEAD IF THE ONE ON TO
THAT AND THEN I'LL ASK MYSELF.
THANK YOU SO LET'S TALK ABOUT ON
THE ISSUE OF DISCOVERY SO.
IN THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL IT SIXTY MINUTES.
UPON DISCOVERY.
NOTIFICATION.
SO -- AND THE REASON WHY THAT IS
SO IMPORTANT -- IS THAT ALLOWS
INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
pAND THEN AFTER THE OUTAGE HAS
BEEN DISCOVERED A CUT CABLE FOR
EXAMPLE.
A BURNED FIBER LINE.
WITHIN ONE HOUR THAT DISCOVERY.
THEY WOULD THEN CALL INTO THE
CALIFORNIA WARNING CENTER WITH
THE OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
TWO CURRENTLY ASTHE BILL AS
DRAFTED IT WOULD BE ANY. NINE
ONE ONE OUT EACH.
ANY OUTAGE IMPACTING AN
EMERGENCY ALERT LINE.
WE ON THE ISSUE OF PARADISE --
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
AND I WILL ALSO SPEAK FOR THE
TUBS FIRE AS WELL [inaudible]
IS THAT.
PARADISE WE HAD THE BUTTE COUNTY
SHERIFF HE HE WISHES HE COULD BE
HERE TESTIFIED PREVIOUSLY --
THEY DID NOT KNOW THAT THOSE
ALERTS FOR NOT HITTING
[inaudible]
RESIDENTS.
A NO IS DOWN.
WE DIDN'T KNOW IS DOWN BECAUSE
THE FCC GETS THE FIRST NOTICE OF
AN OUTAGE.
YES YOU SEE THEN BECAUSE THE P.
YOU SEE.
PC SHOULD HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
DEALING WITH FIRST RESPONDERS.
THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE THAT.
WITHIN SIXTY MINUTES OF AN
OUTAGE.
AND I'M MAKING THIS UP AT THE
MOMENT EIGHTEEN T. VERIZON
WHOEVER THAT CARRIER MAY BE.
WOULD NOTIFY THE WARNING CENTER
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THE WARNING CENTER WOULD THEN
CALL.
THE EMERGENCY MANAGER.
IN WHATEVER COUNTY.
THERE'S BEEN IMPACTED BY THE
INCIDENT.
SO I THINK IT'S COMMONSENSE IT
CUTS THAT MIDDLEMAN WHICH WE
SIMPLY DO NOT NEED -- AND BUT IT
WOULD BE SIX IN HIS POND
DISCOVERY.
OKAY SO THAT GETS SENT TO PART
OF MY SECOND QUESTION BT IT TO
ME -- BACK UP AND HAVE A FIRST
QUESTION A PART A PLEASE -- IN
THE IN THE PARADISE AND AND TUBS --
SCENARIOS.
HOW WOULD THAT TELL BECAUSE OF
NO?
HOW WOULD THEY HAVE KNOWN RIGHT
AWAY AND VERIFIED THAT THEY DID
HAVE AN OUTAGE THEIR FIBER WAS
BURNED?
THAT'S THAT'S REAL GOOD HOW
WOULD THEY KNOW WITHOUT
VERIFYING.
AND WHEN THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
GO IN BECAUSE IT'S A DISASTER
ZONE IT'S AN IMPACTS ON HOW
WOULD THEY BE ABLE TO SEND A
CREW OUT TO VERIFY AND HOW LONG
WOULD THAT TAKE SO THEY WERE
ABLE TO ERIFY ENOUGH TO THE FCC
THAT THE FIRST.
AND THIS IS ACCORDING THE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES STATE RECORDS --
I DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC
CARRIER BUT THE FIRST
NOTIFICATION -- IT CAME INTO THE
FCC -- WITH THE CAMPFIRE. FIVE
HOURS LATER.
AFTER THE START.
IT CAME IN FIVE HOURS EARLIER TO
THE FCC -- THE TUBS FIRE.
IT WAS I HAVE THEY KNEW AT
APPROXIMATELY NINE FORTY FIVE
TENNIS PM THE TUBS FIRE THAT
THEIR OUTAGES -- IN THE STATE
DIDN'T FIND OUT ABOUT THAT
OUTAGE UNTIL FOUR TWELVE AM IN
THE NEXT MORNING.
SO IT TOOK AWHILE.
MORE NO EIGHT SO THAT NOTED THAT
NOTICE WHEN TO THE FCC WHAT TOOK
A WHILE IS FOR THE FCC TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE STATE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
CUTS THE MIDDLE PERSON OUT.
IN THERE SHOULD BE NO REASON AT
THE SEC'S INVOLVED IN THIS AND
SO RIGHT NOW THIS RIDICULOUS
CHAIN AND EVENTS AND I DON'T
MEAN TO I'M.
NOT PLACE TIME AND I APOLOGIZE.
IT'S QUITE ALRIGHT I THINK THIS
IS WHAT THIS WHOLE PROCESS IS
ABOUT NEWS IT'S GOOD FOR US
BECAUSE TYPICALLY OF LATE WE WE
HAVEN'T HAD THIS DETAILED
DISCUSSION.
ON IN COMMITTEES AND I THINK
THIS WEEK IN PARTICULAR WOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
DETAILED DISCUSSION YEAH TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND SO WE HAVE THE
BEST PRODUCT GOING FORWARD. FOR
ALL PEOPLE I MEAN I'M ON YOUR
PAGER YEAH I'M TRYING TO GET.
GET THERE SO SO TRY TO WORK IT
THROUGH.
I UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN THAT
FIBER WIN OUT THERE'S ALMOST AN
INSTANTANEOUS -- A SPARK THAT
OCCURS INSIDE A COMPLETE
COMPUTER AND THEN IT SENDS UP
INTO A RING LOOP WHICH AT THAT
MOMENT IN THE BLINK OF YOUR AYE
THAT YOU JUST POINT THREE TIMES
FOUR TIMES SIX TIMES DOWN.
IT SHOT.
A SIGNAL AND REVERSE THAT COURSE
AND MAY HAVE SENATE A HUNDRED
MILES AROUND BUT THIS CONTINUITY
DIDN'T BREAK.
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED NINE ONE
ONE DID GO DOWN NO NO NO?
IT DID.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO MORE.
I ABILITY FOR TO CONNECT.
AND WHEN IT DIDN'T CONNECT IT
WAS COMPLETELY LOST BUT NOBODY
COULD TELL YOU WHY ARE IF IT WAS
A SIMPLE FIX WITHIN A GLITCH OF
A COMPUTER AND THEY NEEDED TO
VERIFY THAT BUT THEY DIDN'T THEY
DIDN'T KNOW THAT IT.
WAS GOING DOWN BUT IT TOOK A
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH.
THE WITHIN THE INTERNAL SYSTEM
AS WELL.
SO THE CHALLENGE THAT -- MINOR
SEEN THE CHALLENGE AND I CAN LET
DECISION CHAIR OF NO I MEAN
THERE WERE OUTAGES FOR EXAMPLE
AND SAY NO MY COUNTY.
AND FOLKS WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
CALLING NOW 911- READ COM WAS
RECEIVING NINE ONE ONE CALLS
FROM AROUND OTHER AREAS OF THE
COUNTY BUT DID NOT REALIZE THAT
THEIR OUTAGES IN SPECIFIC AREAS
THAT WERE BEING IMPACTED BY THE
TUBS FIRE.
THIS BILL SOLVES THAT SO LET'S
JUST SAY YOU KNOW USE THE TUBS
FIRE EXIT FOR EXAMPLE IF WE HAVE
AN OUTAGE UPON MARK WHY SPRINGS
ROAD.
BECAUSE THE FIRES BURNED.
I'M I'M USING THIS IMAGE EXAMPLE
EIGHTEEN TI WOULD THEN CALL THE
WARNING CENTER THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
WHAT HAPPENS NOW IS IF A FIBERS
BURN A FIBER IS BURNED?
INDUSTRY WILL CALL THE SEC
THEY'RE FEDERALLY REGULATED
UTILITY.
SEC THEN DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
BECAUSE THE PC.
UNDERSTAND THEIR COUNTERPART.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE BECAUSE PC
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH FLIPPING
DISASTERS.
SO THIS LITTLE IT CUTS THE
MIDDLE PERSON WILL BE ABLE -- TO
GET THIS IN -- ESSENTIALLY REAL
TIME BUT AGAIN WE PROVIDE FOR
SIXTY MINUTES UPON DISCOVERING
THIS BILL SO THIS IS A GOOD
EXCHANGE FOR ROOM BECAUSE YOU'RE
HEARING A LOT OF GOOD
INFORMATION.
AND AGAIN I'M GOING TO REITERATE
I'M ON YOUR PAYCHECK -- ON THIS
SO -- A JUST ON THEIR CLOTHES I
HAVE TWO CLARIFICATION TIER ONE
WHAT WHAT WHAT WOULD BE THE
NUMBER WOULD BE JUST ONE PHONE
THAT'S OUT.
CURRENTLY IS THE BILL READS IT
IS ANY OUTAGE YES THAT'S
CURRENTLY HAVE THE BILL READS
OKAY.
SO THE SO THAT CAN BE.
I'M JUST GONNA SAY THIS
EDITORIAL THAT COULD BE
PROBLEMATIC FOR SOME OF THOSE
MORE RURAL COMMUNITIES -- WHERE
THEY THEY HAVE THE ONE OFF
PERSON THAT LIVES SEVERAL MILES
OUT AND?
THAT MAY NOT BE EVEN AN OUTAGE
BECAUSE OF THE TELCO THAT MAY BE
AN OUTAGE BECAUSE THEIR OWN --
PHONIES GONE BAD -- STILL CAN'T
CONNECT IF THE PHONE DOESN'T GET
ENERGIZED BECAUSE IT'S NOT
WORKING.
SO THAT'S JUST A SIMPLE ONE BUT
LET ME COME BACK.
TO REALLY WHAT.
WELL I'M JUST GONNA GO OVER.
I THINK THE CHAIR ASKED A
LEGITIMATE QUESTION AND I'D LIKE
TO TRY TO GET SOME RESOLVED
BECAUSE I THINK MEMBERS HERE
WILL WANT.
WE HAVE SOME I THINK GOOD --
SUPPORTABLE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
BROUGHT FORTH BY THE COMMITTEE
AND I THINK THOSE ARE WORKABLE
AND MAKE IT FAR MORE SUPPORTABLE
AN EASIER TO SUPPORT TODAY -- IS --
WILL YOU BE WILLING TO TAKE
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND AND WORK
WITH THEM FROM HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR LOOK
I AM NOT AT ALL TRYING TO BE
DIFFICULT WHATSOEVER AND I HOPE
IN THE COMING OFFICE IS
RESPECTFUL.
WE'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS ALREADY
THAT WOULD ALLOW -- YES TO BE
ABLE TO CREATE THE THRESHOLD.
SO WHEN IT COMES -- TO NICE YOUR
BIGELOW WHEN HE WAS JUST
REFERRING TO IN REGARDS TO AS
THE BILL CURRENTLY READS.
IF THERE IS ONE PERSON -- THEN
YES IT WOULD BE REPORTABLE.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE IN THE BILL IS
THAT -- YES WILL EVENTUALLY
CREATE THE THRESHOLD SO THEY
WILL CREATE THE THRESHOLD OF HOW
MANY CUSTOMERS RIGHT SO THAT
WILL ACTUALLY THERE'S LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW THAT
ALLOWS A WE ASKED. TO BE TO
CREATE THE THRESHOLD -- AND
WE'VE WORK WITH INDUSTRY ON THAT.
I AM NOT AT ALL BE DIFFICULT BUT
I'M I'M ASKING IF FOR SOME
SUPPORT HERE TODAY TO BE A TO
KEEP THE BILL INTACT.
I'M ASKING YOU FOR THAT -- WE
HAVE WORK THIS WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK THIS IN THE
REASON WHY SO WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS MORE THAN REASONABLE.
AGAIN WE'VE CREATED EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS FOR BINGO IN THE
STATE.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO CREATE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WHEN IT
COMES TO NINE ONE ONE OUTAGES.
AND EMERGENCY ALERTS -- AND AND
BE HAPPY TO IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
A SIDEBAR MISTER CHAIR -- I'D BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT AS WELL --
MOMENTARILY WHATEVER WORKS FOR
YOU BUT I WOULD ASK IF YOU BE
WILLING TO BE ABLE TO KEEP IT.
INTACT -- TO ALLOW THESE BE A TO
GO INTO EFFECT PRIOR TO NEXT
FIRE SEASON.
THIS COOPER.
SURE MISTER LOOK AT MY QUESTION
ABOUT THE FOR TAKING THE MINUTES
OR NOT BUT THE THRESHOLD AS FAR
AS YES.
A LOT TO DO THAT.
HOUSE TO THE ESTABLISH A
THRESHOLD.
IT WOULD BE JULY FIRST.
TO TWENTY TWENTY IF WE ALLOW THE
EMERGENCY -- REGULATIONS TO TAKE
PLACE.
SB SIX MONTHS OKAY SIDE I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS WITH YOU CAN TAKE
MORE NOT SO.
I'LL THROW THAT OUT THERE OKAY
[inaudible]
MR DAILY.
YEAH MY QUESTIONS ARE SIMILAR SO
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY.
YOUR DESIRED DATE FOR THE
EMERGENCY REX TO TAKE PLACE AND
I GUESS THERE'S BEEN SOME TO IT.
IS THAT THE CRUX OF THE
DISAGREEMENT ON AMENDMENTS YES.
YES PLEASE AND MISTER CHAIR
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M.
WRONG I DON'T TOWARD YOUR MOUTH
BUT YES THAT'S WHERE WE'D LIKE
TO BE IN TO KEEP.
SO WHAT WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS AS THE BILL CURRENTLY READS.
A BIRD IS THE REGULATIONS WOULD
BE PUT INTO PLACE.
THOSE REGULATIONS WOULD BE
IDENTIFIED -- AND IMPLEMENTED BY
THE OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
WE DELEGATE MOST OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY IN REGARDS TO THE
REGULATIONS AND THRESHOLDS TO
THE OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES IN
THE WHOLE INTENTION ON WHY WE'RE
ADOPTING EMERGENCY RAGS FOR
DROPPING EMERGENCY RACE TO GET
THESE IN PLACE.
BY NEXT FIRE SEASON.
IF WE DON'T IT WILL MOST LIKELY
GO FOR FOUR YEAR. SEVEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT FIRE SEASON OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND YOU WANT.
THE RAGS IN PLACE BY JULY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY YES SIR IN
HASN'T THERE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT IF THEY
CAN'T.
GET THROUGH THEIR RULE MAKING
PROCESS BY THEN.
THAT THEY CAN ISSUE.
THE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
[inaudible]
IT.
WITH THAT WHAT WOULD THAT
ACCOMPLISH YOUR GOAL -- YES I I
BELIEVE WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS AND GET THEM
IMPLEMENTED BY JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY BUT IF FOR SOME
REASON [inaudible]
THEY CAN'T -- AMID SOMEONE
SUGGESTING THAT THEY HAVE THE
SHOULD HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
ADOPT EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
REGARDLESS OF ANY OTHER
[inaudible]
PROCEDURAL DEADLINES
REQUIREMENTS.
IN THE RULE MAKING PROCESS
[inaudible]
IS THAT.
DOES THAT WORK FOR YOU FOR
PURPOSES OF YOUR BILL.
WHAT WOULD WORK -- AND AGAIN
ULTIMATELY IF THIS MEANS MEANS
WHAT I'M HEARING -- THE CHAIR
SAY PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG MISTER CHAIR -- ULTIMATELY
IF THE DECISION IS IS THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT.
EMERGENCY REYES OR NOT -- LOOK.
WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT THIS HERE
JUST A BIT AGO -- THAT IT --
WANTED BILL TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THIS -- I WILL TELL YOU.
I THINK THAT.
THERE ARE VERY FEW.
ISSUES THAT ARE TRULY LIFE OR
DEATH.
WE NEED TO LEARN FROM OUR STAKE
MISTAKES WE'VE HAD SERIOUS
MISTAKES.
ON EMERGENCY ALERT TO NINE ONE
ONE OUTAGES IN THE STATE.
IF IT IS THE WILL OF THE
COMMITTEE IN IF THIS MEANS THAT
THIS BILL WILL NOT GET OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE OF COURSE I'M
GONNA HAVE TO TAKE THE MEANS.
I WOULD SUGGEST TO ALL OF US
TODAY.
THAT WE KEEP AN INTACT BUT
ULTIMATELY IT'S THE WILL OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I WILL GO WITH THE
CHAIR -- IF THAT MEANS THAT THIS
BILL IS GOING -- TO REMAIN ALIVE
BECAUSE THAT MEANS MORE PEOPLE
ARE GONNA.
STAY ALIVE AS WELL [inaudible]
MR SAUCE.
THANKS TO REQUIRE -- YOU KNOW I
WAS JUST.
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING IN THIS OBVIOUSLY IT'S A
VERY RESPONSIVE. TO TO THE
EMERGENCY IS THAT OF A OCCURRED
IN THE STATE.
BUT YOU KNOW I CENTER THIS BY
COMMITTEE STAFF I WAS LOOKING AT
THE AND YOU PROVIDED SOME
CLARIFICATION BUT JUST HELP ME.
UNDERSTAND THE MOMENT SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT SO ONE
WOULD ALLOW CARILLO YES TO ADOPT
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS OF THE
CAN'T MEET THE JULY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY I KNOW YOU SEE
THE AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
SOME.
MR TERWILLIGER STAFF HAS THE
AMENDMENTS.
WE WE DO NOT HAVE A COPY.
OKAY SO PERHAPS YOU GUYS CAN.
WILL DECIDE ON THE A BANDS --
AYE CRITICALLY DEMANDS FOR THEM
IS JUDGE US BY THE COMMITTEE
MISTER BURN THAT'S THAT THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS BEGIN -- UNDER
THE REGULAR PROCESS.
ISSUE A NOTICE NO LATER THAN
FEBRUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY AND ALLOW CAL --
YES TO ADOPT EMERGENCY RAKES IF
FOR SOME REASON THEY CAN'T MEET
THE JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
DEADLINE SO I THINK THE IMMENSE
AT LEAST IS JUST WHAT COMMITTEE
ARE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT I'VE
HEARD FROM YOU -- TODAY ONE
COMMENT I WOULD MAKE IS IF IN
FACT THERE'S SOME URGENCY TO THE
ISSUE WHICH YOU HAVE STAYED
THERE IS AND I THINK THE
DIALOGUE HAS SUGGESTED IS
CONSISTENT WITH THAT -- WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD PUT EARNERS
BECAUSE OF THE BILL -- NOW WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT HERE
TODAY WE COULD DO IT ON THE
FLOOR -- WITH THE APPROVAL THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND I THINK
THERE'S A RULES COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN WRITER SOMEWHERE.
MAYBE RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME.
AND THAT WOULD BE PERHAPS --
AVENUE TO MOVE THIS EVEN QUICKER --
CONSISTS I THINK WITH YOUR GOAL
BUT ALSO GIVE.
COMFORT I THINK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- WITH THOSE
MANSIONS THAT -- SOUND FAIR TO
YOU IT IS ABOUT THIS CASE GET A
QUICK COPY THE MEANS IS THAT
POSSIBLE DISS HIM ABSOLUTELY.
SURE WHAT WHAT WE WHAT WE
VENTURE FOR SECOND IT CAN I JUST
CLARIFY.
WHAT WE HAVE SUGGESTED IS NOT TO
ELIMINATE THE EMERGENCY OF
REGULATION PROCESS?
IF YOU INCLUDE THE APA PROCESS
IN ANY PROPOSAL.
THE APA PROCESS INCLUDES THE
ABILITY FOR AN AGENCY TO MAKE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS SO WE ARE
NOT OPPOSED TO EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS.
SO MAYBE WAS IT VERY CLEAR WHAT
WE WERE SUGGESTING THAT.
YOU MUST ADOPT YOU MUST INITIATE
DIRECTOR RULE MAKING PROCESS
VERY EARLY ON TO GET THAT GOING
IN THE INTERIM.
AN AGENCY MAY ISSUE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS AND WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THAT WE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THAT.
BUT WHAT THE BILL DOES HERE IF
YOU READ THE THE LANGUAGE HERE
TODAY IT EXEMPTS UNDER
SUBSECTION BE OF THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS SOME DUE PROCESS
ISSUES.
AND ALL WERE SAYING THIS YOU
MUST COMPLY WITH THAT DUE
PROCESS ISSUE THE STRUCTURES.
ARE THE AMENDMENTS AS DESCRIBED.
BY THE CHAIR HERE CONSISTENT
WITH YES WITH THOSE WHICH ARE
ASKING FOR THOSE ARE YEAH THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IS THE THREE ITEMS YES
I ACTUALLY GO TO THOSE HUNGRY.
THOSE ARE PERFECT.
JERRY MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND JUST TAKE
A LOOK AT THIS YEAR FOR THE
FIRST TIME SO -- LOOK I THINK
THE BOTTOM LINE WOULD BE THIS.
THERE WOULD NOT BE A COMMITMENT
IF -- THE EMERGENCY BRAKES
AREN'T EMBEDDED IN THE BILL THAT --
WE ASK CAN GET TO GET TO THIS BY
JULY FIRST AT TWENTY TWENTY NINE
HER DOG YOU TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
WITH.
THE LEGISLATIVE UNIT ON THAT.
IF THERE WOULD BE AN URGENCY
BECAUSE N THAT WE CAN GET
POTENTIAL BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE THAT THEN
TURNS IT INTO A TWO THIRDS VOTE --
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
THEN GIVE -- WOULD GETTING GIFTS
T. -- OFFICE WERE TO SERVICES.
TIME TO BE ABLE TO A LONGER
RUNWAY TO BE TO GET THIS THING
DONE -- PRIOR TO JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY AGAIN NOT AT ALL
TRYING TO BE DIFFICULT MEMBERS --
BUT TRULY TRYING TO MAKE THIS
FUNCTIONAL FOR THE STATE -- IN I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A HUGE GAP
THAT -- WILL COST LIVES.
I SURELY DON'T SEE IT AS A
PARTISAN ISSUE AND IN TALKING
WITH OUR VICE CHAIRMAN -- I
WOULD ASSUME WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT SEEKING AN URGENCY BECAUSE
AND AGAIN THE RULES WHICHEVER
COULD SPEAK TO IT IF I'M IF I'M
ADELINE HEARING CORRECT I THINK
WE COULD PURSUE THAT URGENCY
BECAUSE ON THE FOR THAT WOULD IN
FACT MOVE THIS QUICKER I THINK
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH.
YOUR GOALS AND EACH YEAR SHOULD
BE -- AND ACHIEVABLE OUTCOME I
THINK OKAY.
IN WOULD BE THROUGH THE CHAIR
WOULD THAT BE A POSSIBLE ASK
VICE CHAIR YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
IF THAT'S OKAY -- THROUGH THE
CHURCH STRUCTURE.
AS LONG AS WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT WORK WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE IMMINENCE THAT WE HAD.
AND THAT YOU HAVE A COPY OF THAT
YOU JUST GOT A COPY.
AND AND YOU SAY I'M SORRY YOU
DIDN'T HAVE IT -- PRIOR TO OUR
DISCUSSIONS HERE I MADE THE
ASSUMPTION -- BUT AS LONG AS
WE'VE GOT THAT THE CHAIRS WORKED
OUT THE URGENCY I THINK IT WOULD
MAKE IT -- SUPPORTABLE.
I WILL COMMIT TO THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU I'M GRATEFUL
AND I WILL.
WITH THAT THE TWO THIRDS --
THRESHOLD -- WILL COMMIT TO THE
THE IMMENSE AS THEY'RE LISTED
HERE WITHIN THE WORKSHEET
[inaudible]
THE QUESTION.
MOVE THE BILL.
AS AMENDED OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
A SECOND DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
HEY I'VE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
FIND SOME [inaudible]
PEROT.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS HI MELINDA.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
THAT SIXTEEN CLOSER TO THE TOP
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MEMBER SIGNATURE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CONNECT
COMPLEMENT.
TO EVERYBODY PULLED TOGETHER AND
JUST MADE SOMETHING WORK
INCLUDING THE AUTHOR.
THAT'S A FIRST IN A RARITY.
AROUND APPLIES ABSOLUTELY. FOR
POINTLESS MASSES AT THIS POINT
MEMBERS WERE GOING -- TO MOVE TO
ITEM THREE ON YOUR AGENDA AND
WELCOME SENATOR WIENER TO
PRESENT [inaudible]
HIS BILL
.
WELCOME SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR THE RECORD I DID
NOT USE A CURSE WORD AGAINST US
AND REQUIRED.
FOR THAT'S NOT RELIGIOUS --
ACCUSATION TOLD.
MY MOTHER WOULD BE VERY UPSET IF
I AND I'M JOINED TODAY -- MISS
CHAIRMAN BY -- MY MAIL MULTI
YOUR PARTNER IN THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- SANTIAGO I WE
WORK HAND IN GLOVE ON THIS BILL --
FOR YEARS NOW -- AND I WANT TO
THANK.
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALSO HAVING WORKED WITH US
FOR A FEW YEARS NOW -- ON THIS --
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
COLLABORATION [inaudible]
OUR COLLEAGUES.
SB FIFTY EIGHT IS A LOCAL
CONTROL BILL -- THAT WILL ALLOW.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CITIES TO MAKE
DECISIONS LOCALLY -- ABOUT
WHETHER TO HAVE A TWO AM CLOSING
TIME.
OR TO EXTEND HOURS IF.
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY AND THE
CITY COUNCIL CHOOSES TO DO SO.
FOR THE LAST APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS HAD
A STATEWIDE -- INFLEXIBLE RULE --
THAT ALCOHOL SERVICE MUST.
AND A TWO I AM AT THE LATEST WE
ALREADY HAVE LOCAL CONTROL IN
TERMS CITIES BEING ABLE TO GO
EARLIER THAN TWO I AM -- BUT THE
BOOM DROPS AT TWO AM AND THAT IS
TRUE WHETHER YOU ARE IN DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES OR SAN FRANCICO.
OR WHETHER YOU ARE IN A SMALL
RURAL COMMUNITY THAT -- HAS ONE
BAR OR HAS NO BARS IT'S THE SAME
EVERYWHERE THIS BILL WILL CREATE
A FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM -- FOR
TEN CITIES.
AND THOSE TEN CITIES EACH OF
THEM HAS REQUESTED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
EITHER THE CITY COUNCIL -- WERE
THERE MAYOR -- AND THE BILL DOES
NOT REQUIRE -- ANY CITY TO GO
PAST TWO AM THE BILL SIMPLY
PROVIDES PERMISSION SO THAT THE
CITY'S CAN DECIDE -- LOCALLY --
THE BILL IS IDENTICAL TO THE
BILL -- THAT YOU ARE ESSENTIALLY
IDENTICAL TO THE BILL THAT
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
ALLOWED ON THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
LAST YEAR EXCEPT.
THE CITY OF FRESNO APPROACH US
THIS YEAR -- THE MAYOR AND ASKED
US TO BE INCLUDED ON SO WE
INCLUDED -- FRESNO AFTER
CONSULTING WITH YOU TO THE
FRESNO REPRESENTATIVES -- THE
THE BILL ALSO DOES NOT ALLOW THE-CITY SIMPLY TO ON THE SPUR OF
THE MOMENT THE MOMENT OFTEN.
IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE A CITY
WILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH A LOCAL
PROCESS CAN BE ANY OUR COMMUNITY --
TASK FORCE THAT TASK FORCE MUST
INCLUDE CHP AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT WAS AN
AMENDMENT THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASKED US TO TAKE -- IN A
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE BILL AND
WE ACCEPT THAT -- THAT AMENDMENT --
AFTER GOING THROUGH THAT PROCESS
THIS CITY WILL HAVE TO PRODUCE A
PUBLIC SAFETY PLAN.
AND A TRANSPORTATION PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S DOING ANALYSIS
ABOUT HOW -- TO INSURE SAFETY
AND TRANSPORTATION ACCESS -- AND
THEN IT'S UP TO THE CITY COUNCIL --
TO DEOTE AND THE CITY COUNCIL
IF IT ADOPTS THE PLAN AND
APPROVED THE ORDINANCE IT WILL
GO TO ABC.
WAS ELEVEN SURE THAT EACH OF THE
STEPS HAPPENED -- AND AND THEN
EVEN AFTER THE PLAN GOES INTO
EFFECT.
IT'S NOT ANYWAY AUTOMATIC EACH
INDIVIDUAL EXTENDED HOURS --
APPLICATION WILL BE REVIEWED IN
THE SAME WAY THAT ABC REVIEWS --
LIQUOR PERMITS OR LIQUOR
LICENSES INITIALLY AND WITH
PUBLIC NOTIFICATION THE ABILITY
OF NEIGHBORS TO OBJECT OR HAVE A
HEARING OR SEEK MODIFICATIONS.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE CITIES TO HAVE AN ON
SWITCH OFF SWITCH FOR THEIR
ENTIRE CITY IN FACT I THINK IT'S
UNLIKELY THAT ANY CITY.
WHAT DO THE CITY WIDE I THINK A
LOT OF TIMES TO PUT YOUR THIS
AND THEY ASSUME THAT THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD BAR ON THE CORNER
IS GOING TO GO TO FOUR AM --
CITIES WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DECIDE THIS THIS WILL ONLY
HAPPEN IN ONE NEIGHBORHOOD OR
ONE ENTERTAINMENT ZONE -- WE'RE
IN A LIMITED AREA AND I THINK
MOST CITIES WOULD DO THAT --
CITIES ALSO THE ABILITY TO
DECIDE HOW MANY NIGHTS A WEEK OR
A YEAR A CITY COULD GO -- SEVEN
NIGHTS A WEEK OR ONLY FRIDAY
SATURDAY NIGHTS OR ONLY ON
SPECIAL OCCASIONS A COUPLE OF
NIGHTS A YEAR MAYBE ONLY NEW
YEAR'S EVE.
I CITIES WILL HAVE THE COMPLETE
FLUX HE BASED ON WHAT THE CITY
COUNCIL THINGS BASED ON WHAT THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT CHP THANK
BASED ON WHAT THE LOCAL.
OUR COMMUNITY -- THANKS --
COLORS NIGHT LIFE IS VERY
IMPORTANT -- IN CALIFORNIA AND
PARTICULARLY AND THIS IN CERTAIN
CITIES I'M IS A HUGE ECONOMIC
GENERATOR IN TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT --
THESE -- OVERWHELMINGLY SMALL
BUSINESSES -- THAT ARE OFTEN
STRUGGLING ESPECIALLY IN OUR
HIGHER COST OF CITIES THIS WILL
GIVE THEM MORE FLEXIBILITY AND
GIVE WORKERS -- MORE WAGES --
NAY LIFE IS ALSO VERY IMPORTANT
FOR THE CULTURE -- OF OUR STATE
AND MANY OF OUR CITIES AND HELPS
DEFINE.
WHAT A CITY IS IN TERMS OF THAT
NIGHT LIFE AND PROVIDING CITIES
WITH MORE FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE
WHAT WORKS FOR THEM LOCALLY --
MAKES ALL THE SENSE.
IN THE WORLD -- I WANT -- TO
ALSO JUST -- I THINK IT'S A
POINT ALSO UNDERSTAND THIS IS
NOT SOME CUTTING EDGE.
REVOLUTIONARY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ALMOST HALF OF THE
STATES IN THIS COUNTRY.
ALLOW LATER THAN TWO AM SERVICE
WHETHER IT'S STATE WIDE.
OR WHETHER IT IS.
A CITY BY CITY -- DECISION SOME
STATES IT MIGHT ONLY BE ONE CITY
BUT THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
THAT WOULD BE BRAND NEW.
FRANKLY WE'RE CATCHING UP --
WITH SOME OTHER STATES -- SO --
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US UP
FOR A FEW YEARS NOW -- I WANNA
ASK US SOMETHING NUMBER SANTIAGO --
TO SAY A FEW WORDS -- AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO OUR WITNESSES WHO
WERE BARRED NEW IN THE PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION -- NICOLO DELUCA --
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF OAKLAND
WHICH IS ONE OF THE PILOTS
CITIES.
THINGS JOURNAL BE BRIEF AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PROMOTION FOR
MISTER ROWE SECOND WAS JONES
SAWYER REYES SANTIAGO AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN THE REST OF
THE COMMISSION HELP IN THIS TO
MAKE THIS A BETTER BILL
EVERYTHING HERE BUT HERE'S THE
BOTTOM LINE LIKE IN AREAS LIKE.
OURS IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE OLYMPICS SO
WE HAVE.
WHAT WE HAVE DONE A DESTINATION
POINT AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ATTRACT -- THE THE THE REVENUE
WILL BUILD A CONVENTION CENTER
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE.
WITH OTHER CITIES I'M THEIR
CITIES WHO DO THIS TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY WE CAN'T COMPETE
WITH CITIES TO DO BEFORE -- OR
LATER IN THE MORNING SO THE PART
OF THIS IS REALLY NAY ECONOMIC
ENGINE THE ABILITY TO TO COMPETE
AND LOOK IT.
YOU TAKE A LOOK TO SEE LOS
ANGELES DOESN'T HAVE TO BE DONE
EVERYWHERE YOU CAN CHOOSE WHERE
WE'RE NOT YOU ACTUALLY CAN DO IT
AND IN SOME CASES WHERE YOU HAVE
LIKE A STABLE CENTER.
AND LET'S SAY YOU WATCH A
CONCERT OR SOMETHING AND YOU
COME BACK TO YOUR HOTEL ROOM AND
YOU CAN'T HAVE DINNER AFTER ONE
O'CLOCK IN ORDER A GLASS OF WINE
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
SOMEONE TO GIVE YOU KIND OF A
PRACTICAL POINT OF VIEW AND
THERE'S A LOT OF ARGUMENTS ABOUT
WHAT -- OR FOLKS THINK THAT THIS
IS THE BILL THAT WILL ALLOW
PEOPLE TO DRINK -- ALL NIGHT
LONG THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT THIS%
IS ABOUT IT'S A VERY SIMPLE BILL
THE TALK ABOUT PURE LOCAL
CONTROL WERE LOCAL MUNICIPALITY
COULD DETERMINE WITH VERY STRICT
GUIDELINES AS TO WHEN WHERE AND
IF.
THEY ALLOW A DRINKING TOLL FOR
THE MORNING SOMEBODY CLARIFY
THAT -- NOW AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
THE TIME.
HI BURDEN FROM CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION KNOWN AS CAL TRAVEL
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIFTY EIGHT OUR MEMBERS ARE VERY
PROUD OF THE EXPERIENCES IN THE
SERVICES THAT THEY OFFER --
VISITORS TO CALIFORNIA BUT WE
ARE AT A DISADVANTAGE RIGHT NOW
AGAINST MANY OTHER --
INTERNATIONAL CITIES IN
PARTICULAR BUT ALSO IN THE
UNITED STATES WHEN WE ROLL UP
THE CARPET AT TWO AM.
WE REALLY LIKE THIS BILL -- AS A
PILOT PROGRAM WITH LOCAL CONTROL
TO ALLOW OUR CITIES TO COMPETE
MORE EFFECTIVELY TO ATTRACT
VISITORS -- FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD TO
ENJOY EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE TO
OFFER -- WE ALSO SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EXISTING
BUSINESSES TO GAIN MORE REVENUE
AND PROVIDE MORE SERVICES -- TO
TO VISITORS AND ALSO FOR NEW
BUSINESSES TO PRODUCT SUPPORT IS
FOR EXAMPLE IF WE ARE HAVING A
CONCERT THAT STAYING OPEN LATER
TO ALLOW FOOD INTO ALLOWED DRINK
AFTER IT.
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES -- AND
AND OTHER ACTIVITIES AROUND THE
EXTENDED HOURS WILL HELP THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY.
IT WILL INCREASE TOURISM REVENUE
IT WILL INCREASE JOBS IT WILL
INCREASE TAXES SO WE DEFINITELY
SUPPORT WE ALSO LIKE THAT IT'S A
BALANCED BILL THAT IT IS A PILOT
PROGRAM IN THAT IT DOES HAVE
LOCAL CONTROL.
SO FOR A TRUCE TOURISM'S UNITED
VOICE IN THE STATE WE SUPPORT SB
FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NICOLO TO LIVE HERE WE
HAVE OF THE MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF --
REALLY WANTING TO SENATOR FOR
INCLUDING US AS FOR THE PILOT --
AS A CENTER SAID THERE'S A LOT
OF GUARD RAILS IN THIS BILLS
SPECIFICALLY THE CITY COUNCIL
HAVE TO PASS A RESOLUTION
ALLOWING US TO GO FORWARD -- AND
ALSO THE HIGHLY WITH THE SENATOR
SAID OAKLAND SPECIFICALLY IT'S
BECOME A AN EXPENSIVE TOWN.
THE AREA WHERE THE CITY WOULD
USES FOR AM.
THOR THE WOULD BE AROUND THE FOX
THEATER YES A VERY SUCCESSFUL
MUSIC CALL WAY MOST OF THE
BUSINESSES AROUND OR PARTIAL
RESTAURANTS.
ALL OWNED BY A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER SO THE EXTRA TWO OURS
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO THE
BARTENDERS BAR BACKS WAITERS
WAITRESSES SUPPORT STAFF.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY SPORT MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANTHONY GONZALEZ I
REPRESENT TWENTY NINE PALMS BAND
MISSION INDIANS.
WE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE ABC.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR ON POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS.
TO INCLUDES SOME TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CHAIRMAN WE
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
WILLINGNESS TO TALK TO US ABOUT
IT.
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES WITH A. B.
C. WE HAVE TO GET CLARIFICATION
WITH.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL WE SUPPORT
THE BILL AS IT IS BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR THE
TRYING YET -- TWENTY NINE PALMS
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS INCLUDED.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE FOUND OUT
WITH ABC.
EVEN IF YOU'RE A A CITY THAT'S
IN THE BILL WHICH THERE IS THE
CITY AND THE BILL WHERE A TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT IS WHOLLY WITHIN THE
CITY.
THEY DO NOT QUALIFY UNDER THE
BILL BECAUSE YOU CAN'T BE A
SOVEREIGN NATION.
AND PRETEND YOU'RE PART OF THE
CITY SO THERE'S THERE'S ISSUES I
KNOW WE HAVE TO ADDRESS WITH THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR AND AND
AND THE SENATOR AND BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM
THANK YOU.
A RESPONSE ALSO THERE ARE SOME.
ISSUES UNIQUE TO SOVEREIGNTY
THAT NEED TO BE WORKED OUT THERE
WILL A LOT CERTAINLY.
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS THE BILL
MOVES.
FOR THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN CALLED ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MONEY MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ANGIE MINETTI HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF FRESNO AND I THINK
THE SENATOR FOR INCLUDING THE
CITY AS I'M ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
AS WELL THANK YOU.
YOUR MEMBERS TRUST BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO STEINBERG
IN SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON WE HAVE A
LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS MELANIE
QUITE AS WITH CAN TANA WHAT'S
AND HER MEN ON BEHALF OF THE VA
HUSBAND OF CUMIA INDIANS AND
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM TWENTY
NINE PALMS WERE IN A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED.
POSITION WE ARE ONE OF THE THREE
TRIBES THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE PILOT PROJECT SO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
TIMOTHY BURR ON BEHALF OF LIFT
IN SUPPORT.
UNDER GOVERNOR GOVERNMENT
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF THE MORONGO
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS ECHOING
THE SENTIMENTS OF ANTHONY GUNS
OFFICE ON BEHALF THE TWENTY MIND
POMP AND MISSION INDIANS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO CAVENDER CHECK KERR
PRESIDENT ALKA APCA AMERICAN
PETROLEUM COMMISSIONERS
ASSOCIATION ON THE PRESENT LOCAL
CHAPTER OF THE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS WE SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE TO TEST
MORE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
YEAH.
CHECK MY GRAY.
JERRY GREEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM THAT ON TO GET A LOT OF THE
CULTURE OF THE CALIFORNIA CALL
POLICY ONLINE KAPPA.
KAPPA STABILIZE MADE UP OF FORTY
DIVERSE ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE FOCUS ON
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
I AM BORN AND RAISED IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY I ENJOY AND I DO
ENGAGE IN THE NIGHT LIFE. FOR
OVER TEN YEARS AND I STILL DO.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE AND I LIVE IN
LA SANTA MONICA LONG BEACH AND
MANY MORE CITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I'VE ALSO SEEN EXCESSIVE USE
OF ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION.
PLENTY USES ACTIVITY VIOLENCE.
POOR DECISION MAKING TRAGEDIES
BREAKING APART FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AND LIST GOES ON CAP
OPPOSE THE SENATE BILL. FIFTY
EIGHT TO EXTEND ON SO AUGUST
SERVING HOURS BEYOND TO AGAIN
WOULD BE ONLY TOO STRICT
ENFORCEMENT LIMIT.
LIMITED SEARCH RESOURCES AND
COST STRESS ON FIRST RESPONDERS
WHO ARE BARELY KEEPING PACE.
SHOULD SB FIFTY EIGHT BECOME LAW
EARLY MORNING COMMUTE TRAFFIC
WILL ONLY BE NEGATIVE IMPACTED.
ALONG WITH DO YOU AYE BEING MOST
PREVALENT THIS WILL FURTHER
EXHAUST LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES.
LAST YEAR THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL X. EXPRESSED SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION TO THE GOVERNOR
BROWN.
OVER MISTER WEINER SECOND
ATTEMPT TO DISTRICT THE
PROTECTIONS OF A UNIFORM TWO AM.
LAST CALL.
GOVERNOR VETOED THE BILL THIS
STATEMENT WITHOUT QUESTION.
THESE TWO EXTRA HOURS WILL
RESULT IN MORE DRINKING THE
BUSINESSES AND CITIES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WILL SEE A GOOD
SOURCE OF REVENUE.
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
HOWEVER STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT
THIS WILL INCREASE DRINKING AND
WHICH LEAD TO MORE DRUNK DRIVING.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE AN OF MISCHIEF
AND IT FROM ITS MIDNIGHT TO TWO
AM WITHOUT ADDING TWO MORE
ADDITIONAL MAY HAVE.
THE BOY AND BAR BILL HAS BEEN
PORTRAYED AS A PILOT PROGRAM.
A GOOD PROBABLY BROWN DOES NOT
TURN 76% OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
INTO A TEST SUBJECT.
THE FACT IS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
THE DATA THAT WE NEED THE
SCIENCE IS CLEAR ON THE DANGERS
THAT KEEPING BARS IN CALIFORNIA
OPEN FOR TWO ADDITIONAL HOURS.
ALL HARD TO RELATE TO AKA WILL
INCREASE.
THERE WILL BE MORE CAR WRECKS
MORE VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULTS
THE SCIENCE RESEARCHING.
REACHING THESE CONCLUSIONS IS
THE HIGH STANDARDS COMING FROM A
TEAM IN THE U. S. CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL CDC.
WE NOW HAVE MORE EVIDENCE DAHLE
CALL RESEARCH GROUP AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE.
RELEASED THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS REPORT THAT MAKES.
PROJECTIONS ON HOW MUCH THE
ADDITIONAL HARM WILL COST THE
STATE AFTER THE EXTRA REVENUE OF
EXTENDING THE SALES.
OUR SUBJECT OF SOME KIND OF
SUBJECTED.
IT IS CONFIRMED THAT SB FIFTY
EIGHT MAKES BACK POLICY I LET ME
SAY THIS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT DOES NOT MAKE DOLLARS AND IT
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK PLEASE CONSIDER THE VERY
REAL HUMAN CONSEQUENCES.
OF MAKING ALCOHOL MORE
ACCESSIBLE.
VOTE NO ON SB FIFTY EIGHT NIGHT
LIFE PROFITS FOR ONLY A FEW AND
NOT WORTH THE COST. FOR MANY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RAMON COST ALONG --
SPEAKING FOR ALCOHOL JUSTICE SO
I AM A TO COMMENT ON THE REPORT
WAS RELEASED YESTERDAY BY I'LL
CALL JUSTICE -- ANALYZING THE
COST OF THE BENEFITS OF S. B. --
VERY CONSERVATIVELY ESTIMATING
THE COST OF THE BENEFITS OF SB --
FIFTY EIGHT THIS REPORT WAS PUT
TOGETHER BY UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA TRADE EPIDEMIOLOGIST
AND A UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
DAVIS TRAINED ECONOMIST AND
HERE'S WHAT THEY FOUND.
BASICALLY -- IF YOU TAKE ALL THE
BENEFITS C<c.cyan> RECORD BENEFITS</c>
WHICH IS MAINLY TAX REVENUE THAT
CAN BE -- ESTIMATED -- THE IF
THEY THEY TOOK THE NUMBER OF
BARS THERE ARE THE NUMBER --
THAT WOULD STAY OPEN THE NUMBER
OF DRINKS TO COULD BE SERVE THE
PRICE FOR THOSE DRINKS THE TAXES
WOULD BE CHARGE OF THOSE PRICES.
AND WHAT THEY CAME UP WITH IS AN
ESTIMATE OF THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
THE BENEFITS.
UP THEY DO NOT LOOK AT EXTRA
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF SOMEBODY'S
IN A BAR BUYING A DRINK THAT
MEANS ARE NOT SOMEWHERE ELSE
SPENDING THE MONEY SO IT'S MONEY
THAT'S EITHER GOING TO THE BAR
OWNER SOMEBODY ELSE IN TOWN --
BUT IT'S THE SAME MONEY AND IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY HAVE ANY JOBS
BECAUSE IT JUST TAKES A JOB AWAY
FROM ONE PERSON.
TO YOU KNOW SPEND IT AT THE BAR.
AND I THINK A MORE INTERESTING
POINT IS IT DOESN'T COUNT
TOURISM BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
ESTIMATES THAT I'VE SEEN ON HOW
THIS TOURISM MAGIC WOULD
ACTUALLY WORK HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CITIES THAT
HAVE VERY MATURE TOURISM
INDUSTRIES ALREADY SAN FRANCISCO
LOS ANGELES PALM SPRINGS AND
OTHER CITIES THE FRANKLY IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND HOW.
SACRAMENTO WAR FRESNO ALREADY
BECOME TOURIST MECCA IS JUST
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL -- BUT IN
ANY EVENT THERE'S NO HARD
EVIDENCE THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED
BY ANY OF THE POINT TO THIS BILL
THE TOURISM IS GOING TO BE
BENEFIT.
SO THERE'S NO WAY TO CALCULATE
ANY KIND OF GAME ON THE OTHER
HAND TO CALCULATE THE LOSSES YOU
HAVE THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL ESTIMATE.
ON WHAT IN DOLLAR TERMS THE
HUMAN COSTS ARE THAT IS THE CAR
WRECKS THE VIOLENCE THE CRIME
ALL THE THAT ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH EXTRA PEOPLE DRINKING EXTRA
BLUES.
AND SO -- TAKING THE ESTIMATES
OF THE CDC DOLLAR ESTIMATES OF
THE HUMAN HARM THOUGH BECAUSE BY
THIS BILL VERSUS THE DOLLAR
ESTIMATES OF THE TAX REVENUES
AND ANYTHING ELSE THAT COULD BE.
CALCULATED WE FIND THAT THERE IS
A MAJOR SHORTFALL THE REPORT
GIVES YOU THE SHORTFALL FOR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES -- BUT YOU
CAN PROJECT OUT ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S AT LEAST A
TWO TO ONE RATIO OF LOS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR QUOTA COULD GAIN
THROUGH TAX REVENUES.
YOU HAVE MORE THAN TWO DOLLARS
LOSS TO THE HUMAN TRAGEDIES OF
CAR WRECKS CRIMES AND SO FORTH
THE RELATED TO THE AFTER
DRINKING WE URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRADING
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM RICHARD ZALDIVAR I'M THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE WALL LAST MEMORIALS
PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES.
I'M ALSO CO CHAIR CAPITAL WHICH
IS A CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE.
AND A SPOKESPERSON UP FOR THE
LGBT Q. CAUCUS OF THAT COMMITTEE
AND A BOARD MEMBER OF ALL CALL
JUSTICE.
I ALSO HAVE TO BE TRANSPARENT
I'M VERY PROUD -- VOTER IN
ROGERS REGISTERED VOTER AND OF
THE ASSEMBLYMAN SANTIAGO AND THE
ASSEMBLYMAN DOESN'T MAYES IN
WORK IN THE COMMUNITY.
BUT ON THIS BILL I AM I DISAGREE.
I AM ALSO TALKING AS SOMEONE WHO
IS A RECOVERING ALCOHOLIC THE
THIRTY YEARS.
I DID MY FAIR SHARE PARTY AND SO
MANY PEOPLE DIED TO THE AIDS
CRISIS -- AND THEY CONTRACTED
HIV AND AIDS BECAUSE OF
INCREASED ALCOHOL AND DRUGS IN
THOSE YEARS.
MY COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO GET
BECOME HIV POSITIVE AND IN AND
IN INFECTED WITH SURPLUS THROUGH
HI PARTY AND CRYSTAL METH USE.
IN ALL THOSE CAPACITY IN
CAPACITIES I REPRESENT
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY EIGHT
WELL WE HEAR IT'S AN ECONOMIC
ECONOMIC BOOM TO THIS TO THE
STATE.
TRAVEL INDUSTRY AND TOURISM.
AT WHOSE COST.
IT STRIPS AWAY UNIFORM
PROTECTIONS OF THE STANDARD TO A
LAST CALL.
IT TURNED 78% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION INTO A SPLASH.
SPLASH ZONE LAB.
IT EXTENDS OVER CONSUMPTION LOSS
OF LIFE VIOLENCE INJURY AND
NUISANCE TO EARLY MORNING
COMMUTE HOURS.
AND IT COSTS THE STATE THREE TO
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR TO
ADMINISTER.
COST CITIES AND TOWNS AND SPLASH
ZONES TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS MORE TO MITIGATE THE
HARMS.
IT DISREGARDS FORTY YEARS A PEER
ON THE DANGERS OF EXTENDING LAST
CALL.
AND IT SUBSIDIZES IT REWARDS
NIGHTLIFE ALL CALL SALAS AT
TEXAS TAXPAYERS.
LIKE SPENCE.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC OVER TEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED OFF THE
WHOLE WORK RELATED DEATHS TAKE
PLACE.
IT'S GOING TO COST THIRTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL COSTS
AND FOURTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION
IN STATE COSTS.
AS A PERSON OF COLOR.
WHO'S WORKING CLASS IN MY
COMMUNITY.
AND A LARGE METROPOLITAN AREAS
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDERSERVED ARE
AT RISK [inaudible]
AT RISK.
AKA HOLISM AT RISK OF DRUG.
OVERDOSES AT RISK FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES.
SO WE SHOULD NOT LOOK AT THIS AS
ECONOMIC BOOM TO THE STATE.
BECAUSE THE STATE'S NOT GONNA
PAY FOR THOSE WHO DIE.
OVER THOSE HAVE TO SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES I REALLY WOULD
APPRECIATE ON BEHALF OF OUR
COMMUNITY A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
COULD WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY OPPOSITION.
HI BRUCE LIVINGSTON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A CALL JUSTICE AND
I'M A CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR
WINNER.
AND I JUST WANT TO DO A ME --
TOO FOR YOUTH FOR JUSTICE OF US
AND REFERRAL.
AND ALSO OF THE CENTER FELL
ALCOHOL AND DRUG COALITION WHICH
ARE IN OPPOSITION VERY CONCERNED.
ABOUT YOUTH DRINKING -- AND
TRAVELING LONG DISTANCES LATE AT
NIGHT AND INCURRING TROUBLE AT
THREE OR FOUR IN THE MORNING
INTO THE COMMUTER HOURS THANKS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE REVEREND JAMES BUTLER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
ALCOHOL PROBLEMS REPRESENTING.
MANY FAITHS COMMUNITIES WITHIN
OUR STATE WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KAREN SHOCK RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO CENTRAL CITY WHICH IS
ONE OF THE TEST AREAS WE ARE
ALREADY DROWNING IN THE BAD
BEHAVIOR OF OF DRUNKEN BAR
PATRONS AND WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
ENFORCEMENT.
LAST YEAR IN APRIL I WAS HIT AND
CRITICALLY INJURED BY A DRUNK
DRIVER I'M HERE NOW BECAUSE
AFTER I WAS ABLE TO LEARN TO
WALK AGAIN.
PLEASE DON'T HAVE LATER HOURS DO
THIS TO US.
HELLO MY NAME IS FRANCESCA RE
CANNOT I'M AN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SEVEN KEVIN MCCARTY.
I AM A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE ELMHURST
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION.
I'M ALSO REPRESENTING THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE WIND PARK
HISTORIC DISTRICT ASSOCIATION
AND FRIENDS OF CAPITAL MANSIONS.
THOSE TWO NEIGHBORHOODS WOULD BE
PART OF ANY ENTERTAINMENT
DISTRICT THE CITY WOULD SET UP
AN WOULD BE SEVERELY IMPACTED.
WE URGE YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL WE ARE NOT IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BILL
MONTAGNES SACRAMENTO'S TAHOE
PARK NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL --
JORGE CAST THE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES DRAGON AKEL POLICY
ALLIANCE A GROUP MADE UP OF
ABOUT THIRTY ORGANIZATIONS AND
PREVENTION AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
IN LOS ANGELES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SUNNY
SKY HAWK I AM A NATIVE AMERICAN.
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL SB FIFTY
EIGHT MAY I REMIND YOU THAT.
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES ACROSS
AMERICA JUST WITHIN THE LAST
YEAR. TEN THOUSAND OF THOSE
PEOPLE WERE CALIFORNIANS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JAMIE RICH FROM THE CENTER FOR
HUMAN DEVELOPMENT -- ALWAYS
CONCERNED ABOUT ANYTHING THAT
INCREASE YOUTH ACCESS TO ALCOHOL
SO URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL.
PATTY HOYT ALCOHOL AND DRUG
ABUSE PREVENTION TEAM SAN RAMON
VALLEY AND A LIKELY SPLASH ZONE
IN OPPOSITION.
FRED JONES REPRESENT A MEMBER OF
THE ALCOHOL POLICY ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION.
MIKE SKIP ANOTHER MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA CALL POLICY ALLIANCE
THERE IS NO ECONOMIC INCENTIVE.
FOR THE STATE OR THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE FOR THIS BILL.
IT'S A LOSING PROPOSITION PLEASE
VOTE NOW.
OKAY WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NINE WILL GO AHEAD AND BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
[inaudible]
WHICH LACKEY [inaudible]
YES CERTAINLY.
I DON'T BELIEVE THE AUTHOR THIS
BILL IS INTENDED BUT COUNTLESS
LIVES IN DANGER BUT THAT WILL BE
THE BIGGEST MY PRODUCT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
I FEEL UNIQUELY QUALIFIED AND I
FEEL SOMEWHAT RESPONSIBLE TO
SPEAK. TO THIS ISSUE.
AND TO TRY TO CONTROL MY
EMOTIONS BECAUSE YOU KNOW MY
PERSONAL LIFE FROM MY
EXPERIENCES TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
TWENTY OF THOSE TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS WERE SPENT WORKING ABOUT
THESE HOURS IN QUESTION.
THE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BETWEEN
TWO AND FOUR AM.
LET ME JUST SHARE WITH YOU A
COUPLE.
NUMBERS OF VERIFY WHAT I'M ABOUT
READY TO SHARE WITH YOU.
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION IS SHOWN
THE 54% OF CRASHES.
THAT HAPPEN BECAUSE OF ALCOHOL
IMPAIRMENT ARE AT OR AFTER TWO
AM.
SIMILAR TO IT SIMILARLY THEY
FOUND THAT THE DEADLIEST TIMES
TO DRIVE.
ARE WE TO IN MIDNIGHT AND THREE
AM WHICH RESULT IN NEARLY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DRIVERS BEING
INJURED OR KILLED.
DURING THOSE TIMES.
THERE MAY BE I'M I'M NOT HERE TO
ARGUE THE FISCAL BENEFITS -- BUT
THE HUMAN COST.
I WITNESSED WITH MY OWN EYES.
AND I'VE I'VE WALKED IN THE
HOMES OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES AND HAD TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION THAT.
THEIR LOVED ONES ARE NOT COMING
HOME BECAUSE SOMEONE DROVE
IMPAIR.
AND I COULD TELL YOU YOU HERE'S
ANOTHER THING THAT MANY PEOPLE
MAY NOT REALIZE.
THE BETWEEN TWO AND FOUR AM YOU
HAVE A FATIGUE MULTIPLIER.
AND I'VE I'VE ARRESTED OVER.
THOUSANDS.
AND IMPAIR DRIVERS IN MY IN MY
CAREER.
VERY VERY FEW OF THEM A NOD TO
REALIZE THAT THEY ARE IMPAIRED.
THAT IS OUR BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH
BILLS LIKE THIS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO DRIVE
FOLKS.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE ALL THESE
GREAT PROGRAMS WE HAVE LEFT AND
WE HAVE UBER WE HAVE.
DESIGNATED DRIVER PROGRAMS AND
ALL THOSE THINGS THAT HELP
REDUCE.
FACT REMAINS IF THIS BILL GOES
IN. TO AFFECT THERE WILL BE.
PEOPLE DIE.
BECAUSE DIRECTLY BECAUSE OF THIS
POLICY BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO BE PERMITTED. TO MAKE BAD
CHOICES.
IF YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH
CASTING A VOTE IN FAVOR OF THAT
YOU THINK DIFFERENTLY THAN I DO.
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU STRONGLY
CONSIDER THE REALITY OF WHAT
THIS WILL DO.
AND THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
WHICH COOPER NOT A GOOD TO
RESPECT THE SENATOR HE'S
PROBABLY THE HARDEST WORKING
MEMBER THIS LEGISLATURE THAT
WORKS THE BILLS AND MY ONLY
CONCERNS ARE.
THAT YOUR GRAVEYARD IF YOU DON'T
KNOW FOR GRAVEYARD THAT'S A LOW
STAFFING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
MATTER WHERE YOU WORK SURE OF C.
H. P. R. PD SLOWEST AFRICA'S
MOST PEOPLE IN BED.
SOLDIER LOWEST NUMBERS
INFERENCES IN SACRAMENTO FOR C.
H. P. THE AMERICAN MEMBERS OF
VIOLENT SELF THE RIVER YOU HAVE
TO TWO MEN UNITS AND ONE
SUPERVISOR.
NORTH THE RIVER TWO TWO MENUS
AND WHAT'S PROVIDES WRONG
GRAVEYARD SO IF YOU TO CRASH A
TIED UP IF YOU BOOK SOMEBODY THE
COUNTY JAIL.
YOU'RE TALKING YOU DOWN THERE
FOR A COUPLE HOURS OFF THE
STREETS.
SO AND LET ALONE JUST NORMAL
ACCIDENTS AND THINGS SO IT'S
IT'S REALLY TIME INTENSIVE ON
GRAVEYARD LEVEL SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENING TO BE OFTEN WHILE
SHOOTING.
YOU'RE GONNA PULL WATER UNITS IN.
AND THEN FOR YOUR CITIES I MEAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S INCLUDED BUT
THE CITY GOVERNMENT BOB THIS
FIFTEEN YEARS THE MAYOR AND
COUNCIL MEMBER AND ECONOMIC.
NO DRIVERS TRUMP.
PUBLIC SAFETY THE IN THE DAY
THAT POLICE CHIEF.
WORKS FOR THE CITY MANAGER CITY
COUNCIL SO THAT THERE'S SOME
CONCERNS WITH THAT I'M I'M NOT
TO BE VOTING THE BILL TODAY ON A
WITHHOLD MY VOTING WAY FOR THE
FOR BUT THERE'S SOME REAL THING
TO THINK ABOUT.
AND THINK ABOUT FOR THE MORNING
AUTHORS HAVE REPORTS THEY TO GET
OFF IT SIX OR SEVEN THE MORNING.
TO TRY TO FINISH REPORTS AND
MAYBE.
BLOOD GO TO SHOP SOMEWHERE
COFFEE SHOP OFFICIALS REPORTS --
THEY MAKE A RESCUE ONE OVERTIME
SO THEY'RE ONE OF THE ISSUE I
THINK WE'RE FOR SAN FRANCISCO I
THINK IT'S GREAT BECAUSE SEVEN
HELLO FOLKS.
IT'S A SMALL CITY NOT A BIG CITY
IT'S ALL IT'S COMPACT POLITICAL
TAKE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION THERE
BUT THE AVERAGE UBER RIDE IS
ABOUT SEVEN MILES.
AND CERTAINLY A LOT OF FOLKS
COMMUTE FROM THE SUBURBS GIVE
DOWNTOWN OFFICE LIVE DOWNTOWN
BELOW FOLD COMMUTING FROM THE
SUBURBS NEAR DRIVING ON THE
FREEWAY IS AND WE TALK ABOUT A
NUMBER C. S. P. OFFICERS.
YOU THINK ABOUT IT THERE'S NOT A
LOT OUT THERE.
YES YOU'RE DOWNTOWN SEE IF
YOU'RE SEXUALLY MAY BUST YOU.
THERE CONSTRUED IN IN THE CITY
IN THE MID TOWN AREA BUT ALSO
THAT THEY THEY REALLY AREN'T SO
AWFUL TO DRIVING IN FROM ELK
GROVE RANCHER GLOBAL FULL SINCE
THE TWO SIDES A LOT OF HILLS.
AND LA IS THE SAME THING A LOT
OF FOLKS ARE DRIVING BY DRIVING
INTO THE DOWNTOWN AREA DELAYED A
PARTY.
SO THAT'S THAT THAT IS A REAL
ISSUE WITH THAT HAVING MADE
ARREST SPENT THIRTY YEARS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT SACRAMENTO.
HAVING MADE ARREST FOR DRUNK
DRIVERS IN DEALING WITH THAT.
IN BEING A COMMANDER RECOMMENDED
DIVISION FOR THE SOUTH THERE IN
PATROL.
AND WE STAFF GRAVEYARD THE
THAT'S A LUIS STAFFING DAY SHIFT
A SECOND LOWEST AND FINISH IT
HAS THE MOST BECAUSE WILSHIRE
COMING HOME FROM WORK AND DOING
THINGS SO THAT'S HOUSE STAFFING
WORKS.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY TO STAFFING
CIVIL TOOLS ARE MY CONCERNS I
HAVE A GREAT RESPECT FROM THE
AUTHOR AND IT'S JUST SOMETHING
TO THINK ABOUT IS NOT.
EXCESSIVE CISCO IT WORKS
ABSOLUTELY BUTTONS IN THE
SUBURBS PEOPLE ARE GONNA.
GO OUT AND DRIVE AND IT'S IT'S
IT'S IT'S HARD IT'S HARD.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTION
CONSERVE MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WERE ALSO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR AGAIN
TACKLING THIS ISSUE I KNOW THIS
IS -- BROUGHT IT BACK.
THE SECOND TIME I BELIEVE.
THIRD THIRD TIME -- AND I KNOW
THERE ARE A NUMBER QUESTIONS OF
LISTEN TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO.
ALSO WAS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AS
WELL.
CAN THIS IS -- ONCE ONCE ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL THIS ONE YOU'RE TO
TOUCH BASES ON ABOUT THE LOCAL
CONTROL COMPONENT TO THIS.
FORMING AND HOW LONG I MAY HAVE
MISSED IT.
AND I DON'T SEE ABOUT HOW LONG
IS A PILOT PROGRAM GOING TO LAST --
FOR AND SO MUCH ANSWER THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS THAT I MAY HAVE
ANOTHER.
ONE IN A FOLLOW UP.
YEAH THANK YOU -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
SEES ME -- THANK YOU SOME OF HER --
FOR THOSE QUESTIONS AND I WILL
START BY SAYING YOU KNOW I TO
BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO JUST --
EXPRESSED A LACK OF SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL AYE AYE THE FEELING'S
MUTUAL RESPECT TO BOTH COMMAND
THIS LAND I RESPECT THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE.
IN PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC
SAFETY IS ABSOLUTELY ONE ASPECT.
OF THIS ISSUE AND THIS BILL AND
OUT TO OUR WE WORKED WITH C. H.
P. AND WE WORKED WITH THE POLICE
CHIEF THIS IS. TWO YEARS AGO AND
THEY ASK FOR AMENDMENTS THAT WE
PUT INTO THE BILL IN THOSE
MOMENTS OF NEVER CHANGE IN THE
BILL. TO MANDATE THAT BOTH CHT
AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT BE
INVOLVED IN THE PLANNING PROCESS --
AND THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WHEN
THEY MADE THAT REQUEST TO MADE
ALL THE SENSE IN THE WORLD TO ME
BECAUSE LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE -- OKAY
IT IS ONE ASPECT OF THIS
IMPORTANT ASPECT IT'S NOT THE
ONLY ASPECT.
NIGHT LIFE IS NOT I THINK
SOMETIMES WE TEND TO VIEW NIGHT
LIFE ONLY AND THE NEGATIVE --
AND IT'S NOT JUST AROUND DRIVING
WHEN PEOPLE SAY OH THE PERSON
WAS STUMBLING DOWN THE STREET --
URINATED ON MY FRONT PORCH AND
PEOPLE LOOK AT THE NEGATIVE.
AND THE POSITIVE ABOUT NIGHT
LIFE GETS COMPLETELY LOST -- IT
IN THE SHUFFLE AND THERE ARE AND
WE HAVE TO TRY TO MITIGATE THE
NEGATIVE AND WE DO THAT IN THIS
BILL -- BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
POSITIVE TO NIGHT LIFE IS ONE
THERE'S A REASON WHY SO MANY
PEOPLE [inaudible]
GO OUT.
WHY PEOPLE GO OUT AND ENJOY
THEMSELVES AND WHY PEOPLE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT -- AT A
TIME THAT IS NOT HOW WE DO IT
RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE PEOPLE WHO GET OFF WORK
AT MIDNIGHT.
AND THEY CAN'T GO OUT NOW
THERE'S NO WAY THEY CAN GO BACK
HOME AND CHANGE OR GO OUT BY.
TWO NOT EVERYONE WORKS IN NINE
TO FIVE JOB WORKS WHAT WE'RE
CONSIDERED TRADITIONAL SCHEDULE
SO THIS IS SIMPLY PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY AND YES THIS IS
GOING TO BE A LOCAL DECISION FOR
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY FOR THE
LOCAL.
I. CITY COUNCIL IT IS A FIVE
YEAR PILOT PROGRAM THAT WAS AND
THEN WE TOOK IN THIS COMMITTEE.
TWO YEARS AGO INITIALLY IT WAS
PERMANENT IT WAS STATE WIDE.
AND PERMANENT.
AND WE WENT DOWN TO A FIVE YEAR
PILOT IN THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
NEXT YEAR WILL REINTRODUCE THE
BILL WOULD LIMIT IT.
ONLY TO CITIES WHO HAVE TOLD US
THAT THEY WANT TO BE AND IN
ADDITION THE FIVE YEARS DOESN'T
START ON JANUARY FIRST AND THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE MAD AT ME.
FOR NOT STARTING AT JANUARY
FIRST WHAT WE AGREED WITH WITH
WITH THIS COMMITTEE TWO YEARS
AGO AND IT'S STILL IN THE BILL.
IS THERE IS A TWO YEAR RAMP UP
PERIOD TO GIVE COMMUNITY SO THE
COMMUNITIES DON'T FEEL RUSHED TO
DO THE PLAN AND WE DON'T WANT IT
TO BE -- WE HAVE FIVE YEARS AND
IF WE TAKE OUR TIME TO DO
PLANNING IS GOING TO EAT AWAY AT
THE FIVE YEARS WE GIVE A TWO
YEAR RAMP UP SO THAT THEY THEY
CAN DO THAT METHODICAL PLANNING
AROUND PUBLIC SAFETY.
AROUND TRANSPORTATION PASSER
ORDINANCE IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO
SO GIVE ABC TIME TO REVIEW THE
ORDINANCE AND SO FORTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT ARE THE
CITY'S -- HOW IS NEW YORK AND
OTHER ONES WHO HAVE THE SIMILAR
PROVISIONS -- TODAY'S HERE
DEMANDED THAT I'M NOT SURE ANY A
SPIKE IN TERMS OF DO YOU EYES OR
ACCIDENTS OR THINGS OF THAT
NATURE WELL -- SO A COUPLE
THINGS -- THERE ARE -- WE HAD --
AND WE DID THIS TWO YEARS AGO WE
GAVE IT TO THE COMMITTEE -- WE
TOOK ALL FIFTY STATES AND LOOKED
AT AND COMPARE CLOSING TIME TO
RATES OF DO YOU Y. COLLISIONS --
AND THERE IS ABSOLUTELY ZERO
CORRELATION THERE WERE SOME OF
THE EARLIEST CLOSING TIME STATES.
THAT HAD HIGH LEVELS OF THE
WIVES AND SOME OF THE LATEST
ONES THAT HAVE LOWER LEVELS --
AND SO I DON'T THINK I I DON'T
THINK IT'S ACCURATE -- TO
SUGGEST THAT THERE'S SOMEHOW
THIS JUST EXACT CORRELATION AND
AND WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE.
ON PORTS AND I SAY THIS AS
SOMEONE WHO AND I'VE SAID THIS
TO THIS COMMITTEE REPORT IS A
HARD THING TALK ABOUT WHEN I WAS
SIX YEARS OLD.
MY AUNT MY FATHER'S ONLY SIBLING
WAS KILLED BY A DRUNK DRIVER --
IT HAS RACKED OUR FAMILY FOR
YEARS IT STILL SOME AS WITH US
TODAY THIS IS AN ISSUE I TAKE
VERY VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND SHE WAS KILLED -- IN THE
EARLY EVENING -- THAT WE KNOW
THAT.
THE BAR IS A NIGHT CLUBS ARE NOT
THE ONLY SOURCES OF ALCOHOL
LATIMES WE'RE GOING TO LIQUOR
STORES LIQUOR STORES ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL THEY WERE
EXCLUDED.
FROM THIS BILL -- AND SO -- WE
ARE WHEN IT COMES TO TO DO YOU
EYES -- YOU KNOW WE WE KNOW THAT
IT IS THAT THERE ARE ALREADY
ALMOST HALF THE STATES ALLOW.
STATE WIDER LOCALLY LATER
SERVICE TIME -- WE DON'T THINK
THE EVIDENCE IS THERE THERE IS
THIS REPORT THAT ALCOHOL JUSTICE
JUST RELEASE IT'S AN ALCOHOL
JUSTICE REPORT THIS IS NOT SOME
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY.
PUTTING OUT THE REPORT THE POINT
OF THIS BILL DID ITS OWN REPORT
AND RELEASED IT.
THE BULK OF THE DATA IN THIS
REPORT IS FROM NETHERLANDS AND
ICE LAND AND AUSTRALIA AND
CANADA THIS ONE PIECE FROM NEW
YORK.
BUT THE REST IS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES NO OFFENSE THESE ARE
ALL WONDERFUL COUNTRIES BUT TO
SUGGEST THAT CALIFORNIA IS
COMPARABLE TO NETHERLANDS OR
ICELAND -- I THINK DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE.
LET ME SAY THAT YOU KNOW.
I HAVE SOME CONCERNS -- AND I AM
PERPLEXED UP INTO TERMS OF YOU
KNOW -- WE KNOW THE WORK
STREAMING HARD -- THIS ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL -- EVERY CITY AND
CALIFORNIA'S NOT GIVEN THE CARB
LUNCH TO TO OPERATE BETWEEN AT
EIGHT BY EXTENDED HOURS -- YOU
HAVE IN FACT WORK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS I UNDERSTAND --
AND YOU'VE GOTTEN SOME
AGREEMENTS THAT'S WHY WE IS
REFLECTED IN OF THE ITEMS WE
HAVE BEFORE US TODAY -- I'M
WELCOME TO HEAR FROM MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES ON THIS MATTER AND SO --
MILLER RESERVE AND WE CAN SEE
SEE WAS GOING.
SEWER THINGS ARE.
WHICH COOPER I WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON THE MEMBER FROM CARSON'S
COMMENTS IN TERMS LIKE NEW YORK
IS YOUR PEOPLE USE A SUBWAY.
IT'S A DANCE POP DISLEY POPULOUS
CITY SO IT'S A IT'S WITH APPLE
AND ORANGES COMPARISON.
AND YOU KNOW IT COMES DOWN.
I MEAN TO MONEY.
AND JUST LIKE C. H. P. AND
ASSIST PLEASE INCLUDED.
BUT BILL CITIES DON'T PAY LESS
THESE P. AUTHOR SALLY THE STATE
DOES.
THE CHP IS NOT HAVE INCREASING
MEMBERS AND IN NUMBERS AND GOT
TEN YEARS I KNOW SOMETHING
FRASIER'S RUN MULTIPLE BILLS TO
TRY AND GET.
ADDITIONAL SEIZE P. AUTHORS
ADDED TO C. H. P. THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WITHOUT EVEN GOVERNOR SO
THAT MAY CHANGE SO.
IN MOST FOLKS TAKE THE FREEWAYS
SO THOSE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
PT'S.
SUREST JOBS NOT TRAFFIC BY THE
WAY THEY MAY DO IT SOMETIMES BUT
THIS OTHER PRIMARY JOB SO IN
THOSE LOCAL PLEASE THAT'S FINE
BUT THOSE FOLKS.
ARE GONNA GET THE FREEWAYS AND
DRY THE FREEWAY.
THAT'S REALLY AN ISSUE WITH THAT
NOT HAVE MORE OFFICERS NUMBER.
ONE IT GOES BACK TO THIS IS A
TEN CITY PILOT SO YOU HAVE.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO CITIES IN THE
GERMAN FROM OAKLAND.
THEY BECOME YOUR CITY TO GET
DRINKS BUT THEIR DRIVE IT OUT OF
THE BAY AREA FOR OTHER CITIES.
SO DRIVERS OTHER CITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE ANY.
SAY SO -- IN IN THE MATTER SO
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO I THINK THEY CAN DO IS THE
POPULOUS CITIES WERE.
A LOT OF FOLKS ARE DRIVING THIS
WORKS ABSOLUTELY BUT IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE VEHICLE HEAVY.
HELLO FOLKS CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE
IN THE CITIES SO THAT'S WHAT THE
COMMUTER FROM THE SUBURBS AND
THAT THAT WAS A REAL REALISTIC
ISSUE SO.
IT'S HAVING FUN FIGURE THIS OUT
MAKE THIS WORK.
THIS BLOOD TEST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- STE
SENATOR I FIRST WANT TO SAY THAT --
YOU KNOW I COMMEND YOU ON YOUR
TENACITY WITH THIS BILL THIS IS
THE THIRD DID YOU SAY THIRD
THIRD TRY.
YES I WAS VETO LAST YEAR OKAY SO.
I I MEAN I THINK YOU CLEARLY ARE
VERY SERIOUS ABOUT THIS FISHING
YOU BELIEVE IN THIS POLICY --
BUT I WILL SAY THAT THE COMMENTS
FROM MY THREE COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE SERVED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD -- GIVE EVERYONE PIES --
IT'S NOT ALL ABOUT ECONOMICS OF
COURSE DON'T I UNDERSTAND THAT
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IN ANY
COMMUNITY TO HAVE THESE EXTENDED
HOURS AND LONGER HOURS FOR
PEOPLE TO WORK BY.
I DO THINK THAT THE WITNESSES
BRING UP A GOOD POINT WHICH IS
AT WHAT COST -- WE KNOW THAT IN
SOME OF THE CITIES THE D. Y.
HAVE GONE UP SOME HAVE GONE DOWN
IT SEEMS TO BURY THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE A RHYME OR REASON
WITH THAT.
BUT WHAT WE ALSO NOW IS THAT --
HIT AND RUNS YOU KNOW OUR UP AS
WELL SO IN THE CITIES ARE MORE.
YOU KNOW COMPACT WHERE YOU MAY
NOT HAVE AS MANY PEOPLE DRIVING
BUT MORE PEOPLE WALKING I THINK
YOU ADD. TO THAT EQUATION THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO MAY VERY
WELL FIND THEMSELVES GETTING HIT
BY A CAR BECAUSE ARE STUMBLING
YOU KNOW INTO THE STREET OR
MINUTES A WHOLE HOST OF
SCENARIOS HERE THAT WE CAN GET.
BUT SUFFICE TO SAY THAT -- TWO
MONTHS AGO -- WE BURIED CHP
OFFICER STEVE LIKE ON HE WAS HAD
BY SOMEONE WHO IS DRUNK.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE THOSE AGAIN
I KNOW YOU DON'T EITHER.
AND I SEE THIS POLICY IS
SOMETHING THAT.
IS GOING TO ADD. TO THAT ISSUE
RATHER THAN IMPROVE IT.
I'M ALL FOR HAVING A DRINK.
BACK TO YOU AND I CAN GO HOW AND
WHEN WE'RE DONE HERE.
BUT I DON'T SEE THE HELP AND
EXTENDING THE NUMBER OF HOURS OR
PEOPLE CAN GO OUT AND DRINK TOO
MUCH AND THEN GET ON THE ROAD.
AND TAKE SOMEONE'S LIFE MY
DAUGHTERS OR YOU.
OR ANOTHER CHP OFFICER I THINK
THE NUMBER OF HOURS DURING WHICH
ONE CAN DRINK IN A TWENTY FOUR
APPEARED IN CALIFORNIA -- IS
ENOUGH SO I'M SORRY BUT I CAN'T
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISSION JONES SORT.
AND AND I ALSO WANT TO
COMPLIMENT YOU ON YOUR TO NASA
THE ON ON THIS BILL AND LOOK --
IN THIS COUNTRY AS A WHOLE.
HAS HAD A HARD HARD -- PROBLEM
WITH ALCOHOL -- IF YOU ALL
GOALIE BACK EVEN TO THE
TEMPERANCE PROHIBITION TIME.
WHERE WOMEN?
MAINLY BECAUSE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BECAUSE OF DRINKING.
DURING THAT TIME PEOPLE USED TO
VOTE IN BARS.
IT WOULD HAVE MEETINGS AND AND
DRINKING WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
JUST DONE AT WORK ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
AND AS A COUNTRY.
WE DECIDED THAT MAY BE THE
SOLUTION WOULD BE TO BAN ALL
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION.
WHICH LEAD.
TO PROHIBITION.
WHICH DIDN'T LEAD TO RISE OF
SPEAKEASY'S UNDERGROUND DRINKING
IT DIDN'T STOP.
IN SOME INSTANCES IT PROBABLY
MADE IT WORSE THE MORE YOU
PROHIBIT BECAUSE WE DIDN'T GET
TO THE WHOLE ROUTE.
OF ALCOHOLISM -- IT'S NOT THE
BAR THREE ALCOHOL [inaudible]
AND FOR ME -- IT'S REALLY ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL SOME GLAD YOU.
EXPLAINED THAT -- FOR ME I'VE
BEEN TO LOUISIANA -- I'VE BEEN
IN THE WORLD'S WHEN YOU GET OFF
THE WHEN YOU GET OFF THE PLANE.
EVEN DRIVE TO ADAPT REPLACE IN
YOUR CAR.
AND GET A DRINK.
AND I KNOW THAT IN LOUISIANA
THEY'VE EVEN HAD TO HAVE
PROHIBITION BASED ON FEDERAL
REGULATIONS TO PROHIBIT A LOT OF
THE DRINKING THAT'S GOING ON
HERE -- YOU MAY HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE OUT OF OUR CONTROL BUT
STE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL YOU HAVE CITIES AYE
BATON ROUGE?
THAT DOESN'T.
ALLOW DRINKING.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ANYONE IS
CONFINED TO A CERTAIN PLACE SO I
TRULY BELIEVE IN LOCAL CONTROL
ESPECIALLY SOMEONE FROM SOUTH
LOS ANGELES.
WHERE WE DIDN'T APPLY GOOD?
RULES AND REGULATIONS WHICH
CONTRIBUTE -- TO PROLIFERATION
OF LIQUOR STORES IN MY CAN BE --
AND THAT'S WITH EIGHT TWO AM ONE
THIRTY TWO AM -- PROHIBITION AND
SO WE NEVER REALLY STOPPED --
FROM DRINKING -- A DRINKING
AFTER HOURS AND YOU SEE SOME OF
THAT DATA GOES BEYOND THAT TIME.
AND SO FOR ME -- WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS?
IS THIS WHOLE CONCEPT OF LOCAL
CONTROL -- I DON'T EXPECT.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
ESPECIALLY I KNOW TO COUNSEL
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT.
PROBABLY WILL FORBID ANY. TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN OR FOUR O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING DRINKING THEY'RE NOT.
DO NOT ALLOW THAT IN THE
RESTAURANTS AND AND NEIGHBORHOOD
BARS IN MY COMMUNITY.
NOW IN MISTER SANTIAGO STATISTIC
WHERE HE IS WE INVITE MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
HOTELS WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO BACK
AND FORTH THAT HE CAN GET. TO
THE HOTEL TRAVELING ON DISNEY
BECAUSE A LOT OF TOURISM.
IT PROBABLY WILL MAKE MORE SENSE
I'M ALSO.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE LOS
ANGELES CITY COUNCIL.
WE'LL PUT IN ADDITIONAL
RESTRICTIONS OR ADDITIONAL --
REQUIREMENTS ON THE RESTAURANTS
AND BARS.
THIS CONCEPT THAT BARTENDERS OR
RESTAURANTS OR JUST GONNA.
GET PEOPLE.
LOOKING TO GET DRUNK.
AND THEN GIVEN MORE LIQUOR SO TO
GET DRUNK -- AND THEN HAVE MANY
CARS MY UNDERSTANDING ON JUST
LIABILITY TO THAT WHICH I THINK
LOOK RESTAURANTS HAVE OBSERVED.
AND WILL CONTINUE HIS OR AND IF
THEY DON'T I THINK.
THESE MUNICIPALITIES THAT HAVE
VOLUNTEERED FOR THIS WILL ENSURE
THAT -- SOME REGULATIONS ARE ARE
ARE DONE -- MY MY KIDS FOR ARE
IN YOUR TWENTIES TODAY.
THEY SCARE ME SOMETIME BECAUSE A
YOUNG IN A DAY DRINKING A COUPLE
TIMES I'VE CALLED ME IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
DRAMA AND I'M SHOULD ALL MY GOD
WHAT THE HECK I'LL COME PICK YOU
UP AND DEL SHAMPOO BORDER LIFT.
I SEE WHAT I'LL COME GET YOUR
CAR HE SAID WE UBER LIFT HERE.
WE KNEW WE NEED PROBABLY NEED TO
GET OVER LIFT BACK SO IT IS ALSO
ANOTHER GENERATION.
UP PEOPLE THAT WHEN WE WERE
YOUNGER.
PROBABLY.
TRACK A COUPLE TIMES TOO MUCH IN
DOWN THE ROAD WHEN WE SHOULD OF
THIS GENERATION IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
AND SO -- WITH THIS PILOT
PROGRAM -- I'M HOPING THAT WE
ALSO LOOK AT THE DATA WITH THIS.
LOOK AT THE POLICIES THAT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES COME UP WITH.
WHICH WAS HOPEFULLY HELP REDUCE.
THE AMOUNT OF ACCIDENTS.
AFTER HOURS THAT THEY COME UP
WITH SOME POLICIES THAT
ULTIMATELY WILL ASSUAGE A LOT OF
THE NAY SAYERS AN OPPONENT.
AND SO THAT WE MOVE FORWARD.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM DRINKING.
BUT WE CAN PUT IN PLACE.
POLICY ORDINANCES WHICH
HOPEFULLY WILL REDUCE THAT AND
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY.
SO THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
DOING -- AS ANOTHER COMPONENT
THAT WE'RE NOT THINKING ABOUT
WHICH IS WE COULD ULTIMATELY
SAVE SOME LIVES WE DO THIS
CORRECTLY [inaudible]
THIS LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SHARING
THIS AND WIENER FOR BRING THIS
YET AGAIN -- I JUST IN A BIT
DISAPPOINTED THAT SAN JOSE IS
NOT INCLUDED IN THIS SAYS -- YOU
KNOW AS WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE MANY FROM THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE IT WAS BROUGHT UP WITH
RESPECT TO THE LGBT COMMUNITY IN
THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
STONEWALL RIOTS IN WHICH THIS
ESTABLISHMENT AT THE STONE OFTEN
OCCURRED FOR PLACE OF GATHERING.
IS VERY IMPORTANT AS WE SPOKEN
BEFORE MAC OF THE LABOR THE
POINT BUT INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY
WILL GO ORDER LEVIN THIRTY JUST
POUND ON THOSE DRINKS WHEN LAST
CALLS AT ONE THIRTY SO.
HELLO I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT EFFORT TO HELP ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE TYPE OF
PROTECTIONS AND A FLEXIBLE IT AS
NEEDED.
AND WITH THE SPECIFIC LOCAL
CONTROL ON THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE AT HAND SO WITH THAT -- I
WILL WITH THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MR Là.
GONNA RETURN TO RICHER LACKEY
FOR ADDITIONAL.
YEAH JUST REAL QUICKLY I WOULD
JUST WANTED TO ADD THE POINT
WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
YOU REACHED OUT TO THE HIGHWAY
PATROL WHICH IS COMMENDABLE
BECAUSE I THINK THEY WOULD LIKE
TO MITIGATE.
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE BUT
CURRENTLY IN THE YOU KNOW OR I
CAN STAY SAFE WITH ANY KIND OF
ASSURANCE WHAT THEIR POSITION IS
ON THIS BILL -- BECAUSE I CAN'T
TAKE A POSITION BECAUSE OUR
STATE EMPLOYEES.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE MUCH BUSIER -- IF
THIS BILL DOES PASS AND IT IT
WILL BE IN DEALING WITH -- WITH
TRAGEDY AND AS WE TALK ABOUT.
LOCAL CONTROL AND WHAT THAT
MEANS.
YOUR POLICY.
POLICY THE THE CREATES ACCESS.
THAT WILL LEAD TO TRAGEDY.
SHOULD BE STOPPED WHETHER TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL OR WHETHER IT'S AT
OUR LEVEL AND SO I WILL SPEAK IS
ADAMANTLY AS I CAN AGAINST US
BECAUSE I THINK.
IT WILL LEAD TO NEEDLESS DEATH
AND I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
POINT THAT CH P. DOES NOT
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE -- NOR DOES
IT OPPOSE [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS [inaudible]
QUESTIONS CONCERNS.
WELL SENATOR -- OBVIOUSLY YOU
INSPIRED A ROBUST DEBATE.
HERE TODAY AND QUITE A FEW.
CONCERNS DOTS SOME SUPPORT SOME
OPPOSITION YOUR BILL.
I APPRECIATE AS WELL THE
THOROUGH APPROACH YOU TAKE
ASSOCIATION I KNOW WHEN YOU
FIRST BROADCAST.
BROUGHT THIS BEFORE OUR
COMMITTEE. TO COUPLE YEARS AGO.
YOU HAD GOTTEN OUT OF THE SENATE
WITH NO AMENDMENTS.
AND I THINK WE TOOK NINETEEN
AMENDMENTS THAT FIRST YEAR JUST
MAKE AMENDMENTS THAT I THINK WE
BOTH AGREE -- MAKE THE BILL A
BETTER BILL -- THAT STRENGTH --
COMPONENTS AS IT RELATES TO
PUBLIC SAFETY LOCAL CONTROL
IMPLEMENTATION.
I STRUGGLE WITH THE ISSUE THERE
ARE SOME.
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE
THAT.
ARE LEGITIMATE.
CONCERNS ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY AND
THE FACT THAT ALCOHOL HAS ON OUR
COMMUNITIES [inaudible]
ALTHOUGH.
I WOULD CONCUR WITH MISTER JOHN
SEARCH COMMENTS IN THAT.
AT ONE POINT THIS COUNTRY WE WE
BANNED ALCOHOL AND THE RESULTS
OF THAT PUBLIC POLICY EXPERIMENT.
WE'RE NOT GOOD.
WE HAVE STATES THAT SERVE
ALCOHOL TELL TWO AM WE HAVE
STREET IT'S A SERVE ALCOHOL TELL
FOR HIM -- WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR ALCOHOL.
YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT THE WORLD --
THEIR COUNTRIES WHERE THEY TAKE
TWELVE HOUR WINDOWS OF THE
CHOOSING -- SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT
THE PERFECT PURCHASE.
ALTHOUGH I KNOW THIS IS A BETTER
BILL HAVING COMPANIES COMMITTEE
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'VE WORKED
HARD TO TAKE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
INTO CONSIDERATION.
AND I ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
INSTITUTION LEGISLATURE'S NOT
ALWAYS.
CONSISTENT IN THE APPLICATION OF
OUR IDEOLOGIES.
YEAH WE WE HAD BILLS THIS YEAR
THIS COMMITTEE.
TO BAN FLAVORED -- TOBACCO.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'VE
CONSIDERED BILLS TO EXPAND THE
ACCESS TO FLAVORED MARIJUANA
[inaudible]
WE DEBATE THE MERITS OF AN
EXTENSION OF TWO HOURS AND
ACCESS TO A MIND ALTERING.
SUBSTANCE LIKE ALCOHOL BUT WE
HAVE DOZENS OF OTHER BILLS.
TO AGAIN MAKE MARIJUANA
ACCESSIBLE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO I'M NOT SURE WE HAVE A
CONSISTENT APPROACH I KNOW WE
HAVE A THOROUGH APPROACH IN THIS
BILL HERE AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE MY SUPPORT TODAY
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION LOCAL
CONTROL -- IT HAS SIGNIFICANT --
AMENDMENTS TO INSURE THE
PARTICIPATION AS YOU NOTED OF
PUBLIC SAFETY -- AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS -- TO COMPROMISE AND
ULTIMATELY I THINK IT A BETTER
BILL WE HAVE A MOTION. FOR
MISTER LOW.
WE HAVE A SECOND FROM REGGIE
THAT'S RIGHT. SIX MISTER JONES
SAWYER SO WITH THAT.
THIS IS DUE PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THIRTY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT.
HI GRAY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONDS UP.
BRO.
BRO I'D COOLEY.
COOLEY NO COOPER.
COOPER NOT VOTING DAILY.
DALY I'D GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NOW LACKEY.
NO LOW.
LOW I MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA NO RIVAS
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
YOUR FIVE ICE FOR KNOWS YOU NEED
SIX VOTES SENATOR WILL LEAVE THE
ROLL UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA MOVE.
THE ITEM SEVEN ON YOUR AGENDA SB
FOR SIXTY FIVE A WELCOME CENTER
BATES MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
SENATOR [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN A AND MEMBERS
ARE WITH STATE ON A MOTION AND A
SECOND FOR DO PASS.
I'M GONNA SAY OUR I RESPECT YOUR
VOTE.
I THINK I'LL READ THE
INFORMATION IT CERTAINLY A VERY
IMPORTANT I HAVE WITH ME ARE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
A REPRESENTATIVE AND ALSO
JONATHAN CLAY FROM SAN DIEGO ARE
COUNTY ARE SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF
THE ISSUE IS THE AMMO YOU AND
TRYING TO MOVE THAT ALONG.
OF THIS BILL WILL HELP WITHOUT
WITH THEIR NEGOTIATIONS OF THEIR
C. E..
SO WITHOUT IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THEM.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
ACTUAL PRESENTATION -- DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY --
IN SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL BRING ABOUT THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS SEEING
NONE -- WE HAVE A MOTION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND CENTER BATES IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE AS A AS A TWEENER --
I'M WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE DO NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL.
WHICH ARE LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FREE SHEET THAT.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS A COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MAN OAK MARK ON WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND I WORK
WITH THE SONGS ORGANIZATION AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING.
FIRST OFF LET ME -- THING CENTER
BATES -- FOR HER ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH US TO
FIND A RESOLUTION ON THIS BILL --
WELL AS HE DOES NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON AS BEFORE --
SIXTY FIVE SINCE THE BILL WAS
AMENDED IN APRIL WE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS WITH CENTER BATES
IN THE PROPONENTS OF THE BILL.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND WE BELIEVE CORRECT
FOR ITS HAVE -- BROUGHT US
CLOSER TO A RESOLUTION HERE.
AS HE HAS LONG BEEN COMMITTED TO
PARTNERING WITH THE COMMUNITIES
AROUND SENATE -- FREIGHT TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AGENCIES EVEN TODAY
ONE SONGS RETIRED REQUIRED IT IS
RETIRED.
AND THERE ARE NO FEDERAL OR
STATE REQUIREMENTS FOR US TO
PROVIDE THAT -- FUNDING.
IN FACT AS HE IS THE ONLY
UTILITY IN THE COUNTRY THAT THAT
PROVIDES THIS TYPE FUNDING AT
THIS POINT WITH THE
DECOMMISSIONING PLANT.
THAT SETTING CONSISTENT WITH THE
CURRENT AMMO YOU WE HAVE IN
PLACE WITH LOCAL AGENCIES WE IT
AS HE BELIEVED THAT THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING FOR OFF SITE AGENCY
SHOULD BE INFORMED BY THE LEVEL
OF RISK.
THAT RISK ALREADY IS GREATLY
REDUCED BECAUSE THE NUCLEAR
REACTORS ARE PERMANENTLY DE
FUELED.
AND STATED PLAINLY THERE IS NO
LONGER A CAPABILITY OF A A
MELTDOWN OF THE REACTORS.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMITTEE IS AFFORDED ME TODAY
TO DISCUSS SONGS IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF A RISK BASED
APPROACH. TO THE FUNDING FOR OFF
SITE EMERGENCY SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY.
OKAY SO BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS -- FOR QUESTIONS AGAIN
SEE NONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
MATHIS AND A SECOND.
MR BIGELOW.
SELECT A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY HI GRAY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE WE ARE CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA [inaudible]
ROW [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
UBER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
AS LEVEL VOTES -- AND IS OUT
MORAL WHEN OTHERS AT A LATER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
MEMBERS CHAIRMAN.
OKAY.
MEMBERS ARE WAITING ON SENATOR
WILL FOR OUR FINAL ITEM OF THE
REGULAR AGENDA BEFORE WE MOVE TO
THE SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS IN
THE MEANTIME -- WE WILL RETURN.
TO ITEM ONE AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ABSENT MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY --
ITEM ITEM [inaudible]
ONE AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY.
FIRST ONE AND ONE BY
[inaudible]
ONE HI [inaudible]
YEAH I CANADA LACKEY I RIVAS
[inaudible] TO BE.
MR BIGELOW -- THURSDAY YOU
VOLUNTEERED PRESENT FOR SENATOR
WILK ITEM NUMBER TWO MEMBERS SB
FIFTY THREE MISTER BIG WAS GOING
2% MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND MISTER
BIGELOW.
MISS BIGELOW YOU TAKE THAT I
SHOULD CLOSE PLEASE.
WITH A GREAT OPPORTUNITY SUCH AS
THIS TO REPRESENT OUR GOOD
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO STALL SO HE
CAN WALK UP TO THE PODIUM AND
PRESENT.
SENATE WILL PLEASE -- APPROACH
ATTENDED CARES FOR YOU BUDDY
YOUR CHOICE.
GREAT JOB.
WITH WITH THAT MOTION AND A
SECOND AND THE NODDING HEADS
FROM THE COMMITTEE I WOULD JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
WELCOME SENATOR.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING
TO NIGHT WAS TO BE ROSE
PRESENTATION.
I TELL YA I FOR ONE PREFER MR
BIGELOW.
BECAUSE MY WIFE I SECOND THAT.
LET'S MAKE A DISCLAIMER HERE
RIGHT NOW.
HE'S MINE IS.
WHAT'S THE MOST ISSUE
PRESENTATION TODAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
MEMBERS AGAIN THIS IS ON ITEM.
TWO SB -- FIFTY THREE DO WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC TESTIMONY BEFORE WE
CALL THE ROLL.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YES
[inaudible]
GOOD ACTORS.
AND MEMBERS AND WHEN HE PROP
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
STRONG SUPPORT.
SERVICES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT MY CHEN ASKING FOR
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD I THE BOARD RESPECTFULLY
DID VOTE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL THE
BACK WE CAN ACT IN THE OPEN I
MEAN REQUIREMENTS.
BASICALLY ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS A SEAT AT THE TABLE THIS
BILL WOULD SUPPORT OUR WAY THAT
PROVIDE THAT TO PERSON OF EITHER
YOU COMMITTEES.
ARE SUBJECT TO THE OPEN MEETING
REQUIREMENTS AND OUR TWO PERSON
ADVISORY COMMITTEES DO NOT MAKE
DECISIONS THE FACT FIND THEY
PARTICIPATE WITH THE PUBLIC.
THEY DO I PARTICIPATE WITH
CONSUMER GROUPS IN INDUSTRY IN
OPEN FORUMS AND THEY DO
ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS SUCH AS
PREPARE THE THERE IS SLATED FOR
THE ELECTION ABOARD OFFICERS.
SO -- RESPECTFULLY THE BOARD
DOES BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
WOULD HAMPER ROUTINE OPERATIONS
IF THEY WERE SUBJECT TO THE OPEN
MEETING REQUIREMENTS THANKS SO
MUCH.
ANDREA MCMILLAN REPRESENTING THE
BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL
MAY HAVE UNINTENTIONAL
CONSEQUENCES -- AND IT WOULD
ALSO LIMIT OUR ABILITY TO AT
THIS SIMPLY CONDUCT
ADMINISTRATIVE -- ACTIVITIES SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW
VOTE.
JEFFREY THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
OKAY DIGITAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
THE QUESTION MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL GRAY HI GRAY AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BONTA UP.
BRO.
BRO HI COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
THAT HAS TWELVE VOTES SENATOR
THE BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA RETURN -- TO THE OPEN
ROLES WE'VE GOT.
ITEM THREE WHICH IS ON CALL.
CALL THE ABSENT.
MEMBERS ITEM THREE SB FIFTY
EIGHT BIGELOW I'M SORRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
FUN SO [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
THEY WILL PUT THAT BACK OR CALL.
WILL MOVE TO ITEM. FIVE WHICH IS
ALSO A CO SP ONE SIXTY NINE
JACKSON OUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO LOW [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
I QUIRK SILVA VOTE CHANGE FROM
ALL RIGHT TO KNOW.
AND THE DAILY VOTE CHANGE FROM
AYE TO LAY OFF [inaudible]
OR NOT. FOR NOT VOTING. FOR
DAILY VOTE CHANGE FROM HIGH TO
NON VOTING.
HELLO.
YEAH.
THANK YOU CAN PUT THAT BACK ON
CALL.
WILL MOVE [inaudible]
TO ITEM.
SEVEN SB FOR SIXTY FIVE BATES
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BONDS UP [inaudible]
BRO.
BRO I GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
RIVAS.
RUBIO SALAS.
THE BILL HAS.
TWELVE PUT IT BACK ON CALL
EITHER.
EXCUSE ME WHAT WAS THAT LAST
BILL WITH THE WHICH ONE WAS THAT.
SB FOR SIXTY FIVE CENTER BATES
THANK YOU.
OKAY ITEM TEN MEMBERS SB SIX
SEVENTY MCGUIRE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THE BILL HAS SEVENTEEN IS OUT
ITEM ELEVEN SB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
JONES -- CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ON TOP [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON I LACKEY.
LACKEY I RIVAS.
THE BILL HAS SEVENTEEN IS OUT.
AT THIS.
JUNCTURE MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO THE SPECIAL ORDER
BUSINESS.
AND I'M GOING TO PASSED THE
GAVEL TO THE VICE CHAIRMAN AS
I'M GOING TO BE ONE OF THE
MEMBERS PRESENT.
YOU WANT TO START FIRST OR YOU
WANT [inaudible]
TO YOU.
OKAY.
MISTER CHAIR WE YOU HAVE AB
.
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE IF WE HAVE --
MR GRAY'S WITNESSES IF YOU WANNA
COME ON UP TO THE TABLE AND I
TAKE A SEAT
MR GRAY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
WHEN ASKED AUTHORS EARLIER THIS
YEAR? TO HOLD THEIR BILLS
RELATED TO THE RISE OF E.
CIGARETTE USE AMONGST KIDS AND
TEENS.
I CONVEYED A SERIES.
A WORKING GROUND EXCUSE ME I
CONVENE A SERIES OF WORKING
GROUND GROUP MEETINGS TO HELP US
GET BETTER EDUCATED ON THIS
ISSUE.
DEVELOP SERIOUS AND MEANINGFUL
RESPONSE TO THE EPIDEMIC.
MEMBERS OF OUR HOUSE MET
NUMEROUS TIMES A BROAD NUMBER
PERSPECTIVES AND PRIORITIES TO
THE TABLE.
WE ALSO MET WITH REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL.
NEVER TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE FORSMAN TOBACCO EDUCATION
LOOKS LIKE ON THE GROUND.
THROUGHOUT THESE CONVERSATIONS
IT BECAME CLEAR THAT THERE IN
FACT A NUMBER OF AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE.
BROAD AGREEMENT.
STRICTER RULES TO HOLD TOBACCO
LICENSEES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
UNDERAGE SALES.
MANDATORY STING OPERATIONS AGE
VERIFICATION TECHNOLOGY.
RESTRICTING ENTRY INTO TOBACCO
STORES TO INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE.
TWENTY ONE AND STRICTER
ADVERTISING PROMOTION OF
PACKAGING RULES ARE ALL AREAS OF
AGREEMENT.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO AREAS WERE
AGREEMENT IS MORE DIFFICULT TO
COME BY.
PARTICULARLY HOW TO HANDLE
FLAVORS.
AND HOW TO APPROPRIATELY
DISCOURAGE YOU FROM POSSESSING
THESE PRODUCTS.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE
REPRESENTS THE CULMINATION OF
THESE MEMBER CONVERSATIONS.
THE BILL BEFORE TODAY IS THE
STRONGEST AND MOST COMPREHENSIVE
PROPOSAL ANY STATE HAS PUT
FORWARD. TO ADDRESS THIS
EPIDEMIC.
THE BILL PROPOSES TO RESTRICT
THE SALE OF FLAVORED E.
CIGARETTES THE TWENTY ONE END
ONLINE THROUGH WEBSITE USING AGE
VERIFICATION TECHNOLOGY.
THE PROVISION HAS A TWENTY
TWENTY TO SUNSET DATE. TO GIVE
THIS COMMITTEE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REVISIT THIS PROBLEM MEASURE
THE RESULTS AND SEE IF WE AS A
BODY NEED TO IMPLEMENT EVEN MORE
STRINGENT POLICIES TO FURTHER
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
IN ADDITION THIS PROVISION
EXCLUDES TOBACCO.
MEANT AND MENTHOL FLAVORS
CONSISTENT WITH THE FDA'S
PENDING REGULATIONS.
THE FDA STATES THAT RECENT
EVIDENCE INDICATES THAT MEANT
AND MENTHOL FLAVORS ARE
PREFERRED MORE BY ADULTS AND
MINORS.
WE WON'T IGNORE DATA REGARDING
THE POPULARITY OF MINT MENTAL
FLAVORS AMONG KIDS SHOULD
CONCERNS RISE.
THIS APPROACH REFLECTS A CAREFUL
BALANCING OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSIDERATIONS.
THOSE ARE THE FDA'S OWN WORDS.
THE FDA'S POSITION WAS PARTIALLY
INFORMED BY RESEARCH PUBLISHED
THIS YEAR FROM THE DARKNESS.
GEISEL SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
UNIVERSITY OF VERMONT WHICH
FOUND THAT THE REGULATION OF
SWEET E. CIGARETTE CIGARETTES.
FLAVORS LIKE FRUIT AND CANDY MAY
HELP REDUCE THE USE OF THE
CIGARETTES AMONG YOUNG PERSONS
WITHOUT SUBSTANTIALLY BURDENING
ADULT YOU CIGARETTE USERS.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE IS
CONSISTENT WITH THIS APPROACH
AGAIN THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
SUNSET DATE WILL ALLOW THIS
COMMITTEE TO REVISIT THE ISSUE
OF FLAVORS INFORMED BY FINDINGS
AND ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE FDA.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE ALSO
CREATES ACCOUNTABILITY FOR KIDS
COTTON POSSESSION UNLIKE ALCOHOL
THERE ARE NO PENALTIES AND
CURRENT LAW FOR YOU TO
POSSESSION OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS
INCLUDING IS CIGARETTES.
THE BILL PROPOSES DRUG EDUCATION
COMMITTEE SERVICE HOURS LOSS OF
DRIVING PRIVILEGES FOR
POSSESSION BY INDIVIDUALS LESS
THAN EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE.
IF THE PERSON IS EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY ONE THE BILL IMPOSES A
FINE OF NOT MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THE BILL ALSO PROHIBITS
ADVERTISING PACKAGING THAT IS
ATTRACTIVE TO KIDS INCLUDING
BANNING THE USE OF CARTOON
MASCOTS AND PACKAGING RESEMBLING
CANDY.
AND RAMPS UP PENALTIES ON
RETAILERS AND STRAW PURCHASERS
TO PROVIDE THESE PRODUCTS TO
KIDS.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH CONDUCTS STING
OPERATIONS AT RETAIL SITES.
REPRESENTING NO LESS THAN 20%
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF LICENSED
TOBACCO RETAILERS.
AND FINALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION TO SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
USE OF ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES IN
CALIFORNIA AMONG MINORS.
THE IMPACT OF FLAVOR DO
CIGARETTE PRODUCTS ON THE IN THE
INTEREST OF MINE IS THE
PERCEPTION AND THE REASONS FOR
THE ATTRACTION OF SPECIFIC
FLAVORS.
AND THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF THE
CIGARETTES.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE
REPRESENTS A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH TO CLOSE YOUTH ACCESS.
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THOSE THAT VIOLATE THE LAW
RESTRICTED EXPOSURE TO THESE
PRODUCTS AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT AND EDUCATION ON THE
ISSUE.
THE BILL REMAINS A WORK IN
PROGRESS MEMBERS.
A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS OF
WRITTEN IN TO EXPRESSED CONCERNS
OVER VARIOUS PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF
RESTORING.
PENALTIES FOR YOUTH IN
POSSESSION.
MEMBERS OF ALSO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT THE YOUTH
PENALTIES I BELIEVE IN THE VALUE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND I'D SOUGHT TO RESTORE.
MODEST AND REASONABLE PENALTIES
CONSISTENT -- AND ALSO
CONSISTING OF EDUCATION
COMMITTEE SERVICE FOR YOUTH IN
POSSESSION.
I DO NOT SHARE THE BELIEF THAT
KIDS ARE VICTIMIZED WHEN THEYARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
BREAKING THE LAW.
HOWEVER THIS BILL IS A PRODUCT
OF COMPROMISE.
AND CONSENSUS SO AFTER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AS WELL AS THE ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS TO THIS BILL -- AS WELL
AS COLLEAGUES OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND OF OUR BODY.
I HAVE AGREED TO ACCEPT THE
MEMBERS TODAY.
THAT REMOVE THE PENALTIES FOR
YOUTH IN POSSESSION INCLUDING
THE PROVISIONS RELATED TO
COMMUTERSERVICE COUNSELING IN
THE LOSS OF DRIVING PRIVILEGES.
STRENGTH INTHE ADVERTISEMENT
PROVISIONS TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING ADVERTISING
PROHIBITIONS FOR COMBUSTIBLE
TOBACCO BY PROHIBITING
ADVERTISING AND SPONSORSHIP OF
EVENTS WITH INTENDED AUDIENCE
ABUSE INCLUDING SPORTING EVENTS
AND CONCERTS.
FINALLY PROHIBITING TOBACCO
COMPANIES FROM USING TERMS OF
COMMON.
FOODS THAT APPEAL TO KIDS
INCLUDING TERMS LIKE MILKSHAKE
AND CUPCAKE.
THEIR NUMBER OTHERS WISHING TO
SPEAK SO I WILL CONCLUDE BY
SAYING I THINK IS A MISTAKE FOR
THOSE THAT DID NOT GET
EVERYTHING THEY WANTED.
IN THIS BILL TO WRITE IT OFF
IDEOLOGICAL PURITY SHOULD NOT
STAND IN THE WAY OF COMPROMISE
IN PROGRESS THIS BILL PUTS
CALIFORNIA AT THE CUTTING EDGE
OF THE FIGHT AGAINST YOUTH THEY
WITH ME TODAY MEMBERS -- WE HAVE
A NEW ADDITION -- WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS A COLLEAGUE WHO
ENCOURAGED US TO TAKE THESE
AMENDMENTS -- CITY COM LONGER
DOVE AND MY COLLEAGUE JORDAN
CUNNINGHAM WHO'S BEEN A JOINT
AUTHORS -- SINCE YOUR DOCTOR
THIS BILL I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR SON NUMBER CALMER DOT FOR
HER COMMENTS.
THANK YOU CHAIR GRAY
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
LAST WEEK.
RIGHT AFTER THE FOURTH OF JULY
MANY OF YOU MET MY STEP SON
AUSTIN JUNIOR.
WHEN HE SHADOWED ME IN THE
CAPITAL IN JOINED ME DURING
FLOOR SESSION?
HE WILL BE ENTERING SEVENTH
GRADE NEXT MONTH AND HIGH SCHOOL
IS JUST OVER THE HORIZON.
AND ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IF
TRENDS CONTINUE ONE IN EIGHT OF
HIS FUTURE CLASSMATES WILL USE A
TOBACCO PRODUCT MOST LIKELY AND
ELECTRONIC SMOKING DEVICE.
US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES DATA PUT THAT
NUMBER AT ONE IN FIVE OF HIS
FUTURE HIGH SCHOOL CLASSMATES.
AS A PARENT.
THOSE STATISTICS ARE FRIGHTENING.
BUT TODAY.
TODAY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PASS A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
REVERSING RECENT TOBACCO TRENDS
AND ENSURING THAT THESE
ADDICTIVE PRODUCTS DO NOT END UP
IN THE HANDS OF OUR CALIFORNIA
USE.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREAT TODAY
CALIFORNIA STANDS TO SET ONE OF
THE TOUGHEST ANTI VAPING LAWS IN
THE COUNTRY.
WHILE SANCTIONING THOSE WHO SELL
TO MINORS IS CRITICAL TO ENFORCE
EXISTING LAW OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE IS CURBING DESIRE FOR
THESE PRODUCTS.
YOUNG BRAINS ARE IMPRESSIONABLE.
WE KNOW THAT YOUTH ARE
VULNERABLE TO SOCIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL INFLUENCES TO USE
TOBACCO INCLUDING ADVERTISEMENTS
MESSAGING AND IMAGES WHICH WITH
WHICH MAKE TOBACCO USE APPEALING.
WE KNOW THIS FROM WHEN WE WERE
ALL MUCH YOUNGER JUST A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO FOR SOME.
AND WE'RE TOLD OF THE HARM AND
FALSE ADVERTISING OF TRADITIONAL
TOBACCO.
PROHIBITING E. CIGARETTE
COMPANIES FROM IMITATING CANDY
PACKAGING USING CARTON
CONTAINERS AND PACKAGING
INCLUDING CONFECTIONERY NAMES
LIKE COTTON CANDY AND COOKIES
AND CREAM.
AN ADVERTISING IN AREAS IN WHICH
YOUTH FREQUENT ARE IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS IN PREVENTION EFFORTS.
THESE MARKETING PROHIBITIONS
COUPLED WITH INCREASED
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES SANCTIONS
FOR SALES TO MINORS LIMITED
POINT OF SALE AND MANDATED AGE
VERIFICATION TECHNOLOGY WILL
ADVANCE CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT TO
CURB YOUTH TOBACCO USE.
THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU WILL
BUILD OFF OF EXISTING PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH WHICH CALL FOR MULTI
COMPONENT PROGRAMS WITH OUT
IMPOSING STRICT PENALTIES
PENALTIES FOR POSSESSION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
ADD A FEW THINGS FROM A
PERSPECTIVE THAT OF A PARENT.
AND ON THIS ISSUE IN A
PERSPECTIVE FROM THIS PURPOSE
PERSPECTIVE OF FORMER.
PROSECUTOR WHAT I SAW WITH
RESPECT TO ENFORCEMENT OF LAW --
IN MY TIME DOING DOING NOT I I
FIRST LEARNED WHAT VAPING WAS
FROM MY MIDDLE AGE --DAUGHTERS.
BUT A YEAR AGO I I HONESTLY DE
HAD NO IDEA WHAT THAT TERM MEANT.
AND THEN I FIGURED OUT THAT'S
THE CIGARETTES OKAY -- AGAIN
THESE ARE MIDDLE SCHOOLERS MY
DAUGHTER'S THE TIME OR AN EIGHT
AND SIX GREAT.
I STARTED LOOKING INTO THE TO
THE DE DATA -- THE FDA IS STUDY
THIS FROM 200-011-2000 FIFTEEN
THERE WAS A 9100% 9100% INCREASE
IN -- USE OF VAPING PRODUCTS BY
TEENAGERS.
FROM THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE FDA FOUNDER
AN ADDITIONAL 78% INCREASE AMONG
HIGH SCORES.
AND THE 48% INCREASE AMONG
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS.
THE FDA PROJECTS THAT THERE ARE
FOUR MILLION KIDS TODAY USING E.
CIGARETTES I ASKED MY AT THE
TIME MIDDLE AGED SCHOOL
DAUGHTERS WHETHER THEY KNEW
ANYBODY.
AFTER START LOOKING AT THE STATS
WHICH WERE MIND BOGGLING WITH
THE NEW ANYBODY IN THEIR SCHOOL
AND THIS IS A MIDDLE CLASS
MIDDLE OF AMERICA TYPE SCHOOL.
WHETHER THEY KNEW ANYBODY AT THE
MIDDLE SCHOOL THAT USE VAPE
APING PRODUCTS OR E. CIGARETTES
AND THEY ACTUALLY LAUGHED.
THINGS LIKE THAT THIS IS THE
RESPONSE THAT EVERYBODY DOES
THAT. TO WHICH I SAID.
THE CUNNINGHAMS BETTER NOT BE
DOING.
I HOPE YOU DON'T MEAN EVERYBODY
WE GOT SOME THINGS TO TALK ABOUT
MOM.
BUT IT IS A TRULY AN EPIDEMIC
AND IT IS GROWING FASTER THAN
ALMOST ANY THINGS GROWING.
IN TERMS OF NUMBERS IN OUR
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A CHANCE TODAY TO PASS
WHAT IS OBJECTIVELY.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT ITS
COMPONENTS SAY WHAT YOU WILL
ABOUT.
THE WORK PRODUCT AS IT STANDS
NOW BUT THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL WILL CALIFORNIA IF ENACTED
INTO LAW WILL BE.
THE TOUGHEST ON TEENAGE VAPING
IN THE COUNTRY.
THIS BILL IS A WORK PRODUCT OF
THE CHAIR MR GRAY -- THE
SENATORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WE
TOOK A LOT OF THE PROVISIONS
FROM THE FDA'S REGULATIONS THAT
THEY HAVE NOT ENACTED YET BUT
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS.
AND ON THE ENFORCEMENT PIECE.
I CAN TELL YEAH AS AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR.
ALL OF THESE AGENCIES ARE UNDER
RESOURCE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS JURISDICTION
OVER THIS THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
THAT MANY SWORN PEACE OFFICERS.
THEY STUDIED AND SURVEYED HIGH
SCHOOLS WHERE ASK THEM WHERE
YOU'RE GETTING YOUR VAPING
PRODUCTS. 74% OF HIGH SCHOOL --
SURVEYED SAID THEY GET HIM AT
CONVENIENCE STORES.
THAT TELLS ME ONE THING.
WE ARE NOT ENFORCING THE LAW.
SOMEBODY'S WALKING IN AND
THEY'RE NOT BEING CARTED OR
THEIR PASSING OFTEN FAKE ID
JUST LIKE THE OLD DAYS.
AND THEY'RE WALKING OUT WITH THE
PRODUCT IT'S NOT LEGAL FOR THEM
TO PROCESS WHICH IS ADDICTING.
SO WE'VE GOT IT WE'VE GOT A
NARROW THE ENFORCEMENT SO WE CAN
DEPLOY RESOURCES BETTER IN THIS
BILL DOES THAT.
THIS BILL ALSO CONTAINS
PROHIBITIONS ON MARKETING TO
KIDS WHICH THE CHAIR.
ADDRESSED AND THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
OF THE DRESSING THIS PROBLEM.
IN A WHOLESALE FASHION.
HOW THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ROAD IN YOUTH
PURCHASE POSSESSION USED USE
LAWS DO NOT PROTECT CHILDREN
FROM THE MISLEADING MESSAGING
ADVERTISING BY THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY?
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE THAT'S WHY
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
IN THIS BILL.
THIS BILL IS THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE THING THAT THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODIES TRY TO DO ON
THIS ISSUE AND I WOULD SUBMIT TO
YOU.
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE THING
THAT ANY LEGISLATIVE BODY HAS
TRIED TO DO.
MORE THAN CONGRESS IS DONE MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE
LEGISLATURES DONE.
WE HAVE WORK TO DO. TO REFINE
THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL.
BUT LET'S NOT MAKE THE PERFECT
THE ENEMY THE A GOOD OF THE GOOD
WE'VE GOT A CHANCE. TO MAKE A
REAL DENT IN THIS EPIDEMIC AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR.
GO AHEAD MR GRAY.
THIS CHAIR THANK YOU WERE.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
MAKE A SPECIAL INTRODUCTION. FOR
ONE OF OUR SUPPORTERS HERE TODAY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BRIGHTEST
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT I'VE MET IN
RECENT MEMORY.
RON AT THE KNOCK IS GOING INTO
HER SOPHOMORE YEAR MODESTO HIGH
SCHOOL MY DISTRICT.
SHE WROTE AN OP ED LAST MONTH
WHICH WAS PUBLISHED IN MODESTO
BEE THAT CAUGHT MY ATTENTION
DESCRIBING HER EXPERIENCE AS A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT.
SEEING THE UPSURGE IN VAPING
AMONG HER CLASSMATES.
HER OP ED WAS WELL RESEARCHED.
INCREDIBLY ELOQUENT AND
PRAGMATIC.
I ADVISED HER TODAY -- HERE.
TODAY TO GIVE HER FIRST HAND
ACCOUNT OF THIS ISSUE AND INFORM
THE COMMITTEE OF THE REAL WORLD
PROBLEM WE'RE FACING FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF YOUNG PERSON --
DEALING WITH THIS EVERY DAY SO
WITH THAT.
RUN A PLEASE -- PRESENT YOUR
TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS RON ABANDONED BECAUSE I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADAM GRAY.
AND A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
MODESTO HIGH SCHOOL I SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE I BELIEVE THE
OUR LAWS AND REGULATIONS ON
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES DEMAND
REFORM.
AS A TEENAGER IN HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT MYSELF I HAVE THE UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE OF WITNESSING
FIRSTHAND ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE
EPIDEMIC IN TODAY'S YOUTH.
I PERSONALLY KNOW TEENAGERS WHO
HAVE GONE TO STORES AND ASKED TO
BUY YOU CIGARETTES.
AND YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
CASHIER SAID TO THEM.
THEY SAID HOW WILL YOU BE PAYING
TODAY.
SCENARIOS LIKE THESE WHICH
HAPPENED FAR TOO OFTEN VIVIDLY
HIGHLIGHT THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE WITH EASE CIGARETTE
REGULATION. TO BE ON WITH NO ID
WAS ASKED WHY WOULD DAY THE
CLERK KNOWS OF THE E. CIGARETTE
MARKET IS SATURATED WITH MINORS.
NO ONE IS THERE TO CATCH THEM IN
THE FINE FOR DOING SO IS
MINUSCULE COMPARED TO THE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS THAT THEY
COULD BE MAKING.
SO THEY SELF IN FACT A RECENT
SURVEY SHOWED THAT 74% OF TEENS
USERS.
SIMPLY PURCHASED THIRD TOOL AT A
RETAIL LOCATION.
NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THIS
BILL TACKLES HEAD ON BECAUSE IT
MANDATES MORE DECOYS STING
OPERATIONS IN INCREASES THE
PENALTY FOR STORES THAT DO SELL
TO MINORS.
SO THEY WILL GET CAUGHT AND
LEARN THEIR LESSON THE FIRST
TIME.
WE ABSOLUTELY NEED TO SEND A
STRONG SIGNAL TO THE STORES SO
THAT CHILDREN DON'T GET THEIR
HANDS ON THESE PRODUCTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
I ALSO SUPPORT THE LIMITATION OF
THE SALE OF FLAVOR PRODUCTS AND
ALL STORES ACCEPT TOBACCO SHOPS.
THIS WILL TAKE AWAY SOME OF THE
INCENTIVE FOR TEENAGERS TO SMOKE
AS IT'S NO SECRET THAT THESE
FLAVORS DIRECTLY FEEL TO
CHILDREN.
ALTHOUGH SOME MAY ACTIVELY PUSH
FOR A COMPLETE BAN OF ALL FLEA
RUDY CIGARETTE PRODUCTS I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THIS APPROACH WOULD
BE EFFECTIVE IN SOLVING THE
PROBLEM. TO PUT IT SIMPLY THE
FLAVORS ARE A BIG PART OF THE
REASON WHY EASE CIGARETTE
CONSUMPTION RATES AMONG TEENS
ARE HIGH.
HOWEVER THAT IS NOT WHAT KEEPS
SCENES COMING.
I'LL BE THE FIRST TO SAY THAT
THE MAIN REASON WHY TEENS VAPOR
JEWEL IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE THIS
IDEA IN THEIR HEAD.
BUT IT'S COOL.
THEY SEE IT ALL OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA ALL OF THEIR FRIENDS HAVE.
ONE AND THE PEER PRESSURE JUST
BECOMES UNBEARABLE.
SO THEY BY ONE THEMSELVES AND
POST ABOUT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
TO SOMEONE ELSE USE THEIR STORY
BECOMES INFLUENCED BY SOMEONE IN
THE CYCLE JUST CONTINUES AND
CONTINUES.
I'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN FIRSTHAND TO
PEOPLE I KNOW.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME JUST
LOOK ONLINE.
AND ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY
81% OF U. S. ONLINE CONSUMER
PURCHASING DECISIONS ARE
INFLUENCED BY THEIR FRIENDS
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS -- ALSO FOUR
TIMES AS LIKELY TO BUY A PRODUCT
BECAUSE THEY WERE REFERRED TO IT
BY A FRIEND.
PUT THOSE TWO TOGETHER AND YOU
HAVE AN EPIDEMIC ON YOUR HANDS.
SO HOW DO WE STOP TEENS FROM
USING E. CIGARETTES.
WE MAKE THEM DIFFICULT TO
PURCHASE THE SAME LOGIC APPLIES
TO ALCOHOL YOU ALL BETTER THAN I
KNOW HOW MANY FUNDS RINGS IN
FLAVORS OF ALCOHOL THERE ARE.
IN THE PAST MANY TEENS LEGALLY
DRINK ALCOHOL AND WE EVEN TRIED
TO BAN ALL ALCOHOL IN AN ATTEMPT
TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S HEALTH.
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW THAT DIDN'T
WORK OUT VERY WELL.
BUT NOW RATES ARE FINALLY
DECLINING.
SO WHAT DID WE DO.
WE MADE IT DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
PURCHASE.
AND IT LOST ITS POPULARITY.
THOSE TWO THINGS ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE BUT RATHER
DIRECTLY CORRELATED.
SAME WITH CIGARETTES THEY USED
TO BE WILDLY POPULAR AMONG TEENS
BUT NOW RATES ARE DECLINING.
SO WHAT DID WE DO WE MADE THEM
DIFFICULT TO ACCESS IN EDUCATED
TEENS ABOUT.
THE DETRIMENTS THAT TOBACCO FACE
THAT TOBACCO.
HAS TO THEIR HOUSE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT GIVES A REASON FOR BOTH
RETAILERS TO STOP SELLING TO
MINORS AND FOR MINORS TO STOP
SMOKING E. CIGARETTES.
SEE EVEN IF WE BANNED ALL
FLAVORS WHAT ABOUT THE MILLIONS
OF TEAMS THAT ARE ALREADY
ADDICTED.
BILL JUST SWITCH THE FLAVORLESS
PRODUCTS CONSIDERING HOW MUCH
ADDICTIVE NICOTINE IS IN THESE
EASE CIGARETTES THEY WILL DO
ANYTHING FOR THEIR FIX.
AND THEIR FRIENDS WILL STILL
FEEL THE SAME PEER PRESSURE AS
THEY DID BEFORE.
BUT IF WE ATTACK THIS PROBLEM
FROM ITS SOURCE AND MAKE IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR TEENS TO
ACCESS.
THIS TOO WILL LOSE ITS
POPULARITY.
AND I KNOW THAT THESE BILLS MAY
NOT BE PERFECT FOR EVERYONE.
BUT IT MAKES PROGRESS IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO PROTECT MILLIONS OF
TEENS.
AND THAT'S INVALUABLE
CONSIDERING THAT AS EVERYDAY
PASSES.
MORE MORE TEENS ARE BECOMING
ADDICTED TO THESE PRODUCTS MORE
AND MORE MY GENERATION BECOMES
CONSUMED BY ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES.
PERSONALLY I FIND IT DIFFICULT
TO JUST SIT BY AND WATCH AS MY
PEERS AND FRIENDS BECOME
ADDICTED.
TO WE'VE SEEN HE SAME THING
HAPPENED WITH TEENS AND
CIGARETTES IN THE PAST AND
MILLIONS LOS OUR LIVES BECAUSE
OF IT.
WE CAN'T JUST SIT AROUND AND
ARGUE UNTIL WE CREATE THE
PERFECT BILL BECAUSE FRANKLY
IT'LL NEVER HAPPEN.
BUT WE CAN START BY MAKING
PROGRESS RIGHT NOW.
SO IN CONCLUSION I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT THESE BILLS WOULD
EFFECTIVELY COMBAT THE ON GOING
AT THAT I MAKE UP UNDER AGE
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE CONSUMPTION.
THANK YOU.
SPOKEN WORK QUITE WELL THANK.
NEXT -- PRESENTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MORNING CAR ALL
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SUCH AS A
ASSOCIATION AS LONG SUPPORTED
REDUCING YOUTH ACCESS AND
EXPOSURE TO TOBACCO PRODUCTS AS
NICOTINE IS NOT ONLY HIGHLY
ADDICTIVE A HARM FOR THE
ADOLESCENT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
IMPACTING INTENTION LEARNING AND
MEMORY.
WELL CONSIDERABLE CONSIDERABLE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN
REDUCING SMOKING OF COMBUSTIBLE
SO CIGARETTES AMONG YOUTH THE
TOBACCO PRODUCT LANDSCAPE HAS
CHANGED.
AND THE INCREASING YOUR
CONCEPTION CONSUMPTION OF MUSIC
RATS AS DISTURBING.
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
YOUTH CONSUMPTION OF ELECTRIC
CIGARETTES INCREASED 278% AMONG
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND 48%
AMONG MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENTS.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN
THREE POINT SIX MILLION U. S.
YOUTH CURRENTLY DOOZY CIGARETTES.
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE AN
INCREASED RISK OF DEVELOPING A
TOBACCO RELATED DISEASE
INCLUDING CANCER LUNG DISEASE
HEART DISEASE AND STROKE.
AS THE MARKET FREE CIGARETTES
AND THE EVIDENCE FOR THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE CIGARETTE
YEARS HAS GROWN SO HAS THE
POSITIONS DESIRE TO ENSURE
REGULATION OF THEM.
CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE ACTION TO
ADDRESS THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EPIDEMIC AND REDUCE USE OF THESE
PRODUCTS IF YOUTH USE OF THESE
PRODUCTS.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE ALLOWS US
TO HAVE THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION ON HOW TO REDUCE
CONSUMPTION OF THESE TOBACCO
PRODUCTS.
SEVERAL OF THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL HELP MOVE THE NEEDLE
ON REDUCING CONSUMPTION BY
INCREASING ENFORCEMENT ON
RETAILERS INCREASING PENALTIES
TO SALES OF SALES TO MINORS.
AND SETTING LIMITATIONS ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF FLAVORED GREAT
PRODUCTS.
CMA REQUESTED THAT THE AUTHOR
CONSIDER AMENDMENTS TO
STRENGTHEN PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL THAT RESTRICT MARKETING AND
PROMOTIONS AVE PRODUCTS IN A WAY
THAT ATTRACTS KIDS WE APPRECIATE
THAT HE'S DONE THAT TODAY.
WE'VE ALSO REQUESTED THAT
AMENDMENT BE TAKEN TO REMOVE
PENALTIES AGAINST YOUTH
POSSESSION -- FOR VAPING
PRODUCTS.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THOSE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY.
AS WE CONTINUE THE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT REDUCING YOUTH CONCEPTION
OF THESE HARMFUL PRODUCTS YOU
MAY WOULD ASK THAT MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MOVE THE BILL FORD.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT DISCUSSION
THAT COULD NOT STOP HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
TESTIMONY IF I COULD GO.
TO THE AUDIENCE FOR A PERSON --
PEOPLE WISHING TO ADDRESS THE
BODY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
KIND OF A TWEENER CAN I MAKE
SOME COMMENTS IN BETWEEN WELL IF
THERE'S NOBODY WISHING TO COME
TO THE FRONT FOR SUPPORT.
THEN I'LL GO TO TWEET -- WINTERS
IN OPPOSITION.
IF I COULD GET.
IF I COULD GET EVERYBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE. FOR FOR FOR THE
OPPOSITION.
IN BREAKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- SO I'M A STUDENT AT
RIO AMERICANO HIGH SCHOOL AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS OPPOSITION NEXT.
CAN I CAN ACTUALLY GET BETWEEN
WELL I WAS DOING.
I STARTED BACK HERE LET'S GET
WITH YOU MY NAME IS LARGELY
TRAVIS I'M FROM LIVING IN MERCED
RIGHT NOW AND I PROVIDE A LOT OF
PROGRAM DESIGN ANY VALUATION. TO
ABOUT TWENTY COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA IS SPECIALLY IN
TOBACCO CONTROL PROGRAMMING --
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS THAT I HAVE
I AM IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE I AGREE WITH --
A LOT OF THE DOCTOR A LOT OF THE
POINTS THAT DOCTOR GARDNER WILL
BE MAKING -- AND GIVEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO LOG.
SERGEANTS IF YOU DON'T MIND IF
YOU COULD JUST SIR.
IF YOU STAND IT A WHOLE LOT SIR
SIR HOLD ON IF YOU COULD STAND
IN LINE.
AND TAKE YOUR TIME.
I UNDERSTAND THAT AND YOU
DECIDED TO STEP OUT OF LINE AND
HAD AN ARGUMENT.
IF OR WHEN THEY SET OFF.
IF IF YOU DON'T MIND OKAY WELL I
CAN'T IF YOU CAN'T STAND TAKE
YOUR PLACE IN LINE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU DECIDED TO
MAKE ITS DECISION TO STEP OUT OF
LINE THE CHOICE.
SIR WHO WERE SORRY SIR THE
CHOICES ARE RIGHT NOW.
BACK IN LINE.
AN TAKE YOUR TURN.
OR THE REST OF THE SERGEANTS
LISTS WERE YOU OUT -- PLEASE
THAT WOMAN HAS NOT FINISHED
ALLOW HER TO FINISH THIRD.
OKAY -- SO I'M GONNA CONTINUE
FROM WHERE I LEFT OFF.
SO I WANTED TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS
ON THE EXCLUSION A MENTALLY IT
AND MEN'S PRODUCTS. SIX LEARNING
MENTAL MEANT MENTAL AND MEN'S
RELATED FLAVORS WEAKENS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS POLICY.
ANY FLAVOR RESTRICTION POLISH
SEE SHOULD INCLUDE ALL FLAVORS
FOR ALL TOBACCO PRODUCTS --
MENTAL PRO TOBACCO PRODUCTS ARE
CONSIDERED THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
STARTER PACKED -- DUE TO THE
NUMBING AFFECTS.
IT IS EASIER TO MASK A LOT OF
THE HARSHNESS UP TOBACCO WITH OF
THIS.
MENTAL'S ALSO HAS GREATER
ADDICTION PROPERTIES.
SO PEOPLE WHOSE CHOOSE TO SMOKE
MENTAL PRODUCTS INCLUDING E.
CIGARETTES ARE LESS LIKELY TO
QUIT SMOKING COMPARE -- TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO SMOKE OTHER
FLAVORS.
ALTHOUGH CIGARETTE USE IS
DECLINING IN THE U. S. THE USE
OF MENTAL CIGARETTES HAS
INCREASED IN RECENT YEARS
ESPECIALLY AMONG OUR YOUNGER
USERS AND USE.
WELL ONLY 25% OF CIGARETTES SOLD
IN THE US ARE LABELED AS A
MENTAL 90% OF FLAVORED PRODUCTS
HAVE SOME KIND OF MENTAL IN THEM.
MAKING IT MORE ADDICTING AND
LESS HARSH TO SMOKE.
MENTAL MAKES UP ABOUT 35% OF US
CIGARETTES SALES IN THE UNITED
STATES AS WELL.
OTHER FLAVOR EXCLUDE EXCLUDED
UNDER THEM BILL IS MEANT THIS IS
THE NUMBER ONE E. CIGARETTE
FLAVOR USE BY YOUTH AND MOST
DEFINITELY SHOULD NOT BE
INCLUDED. FOR SHOULD NOT BE
EXCLUDED I'M SORRY.
AS STATED IT IS IMPERATIVE TO
INCLUDE ALL FLAVORS TO BE PART
OF THE FLAVOR RESTRICTION POLICY
I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO AND THE AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
SORRY FOR THE INTERRUPTION -- MY
NAME IS DOCTOR PHILIP GARDNER I
AM THE CO CHAIR OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN TOBACCO CONTROL
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL.
I AM ALSO WORKED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TOBACCO
RELATED DISEASE RESEARCH PROGRAM
FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
THANK CONTRARY TO WHAT --
ASSEMBLYMAN ADAMS -- HAS PUT
FORWARD OF THE THE FDA MADE A
MISTAKE IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
WHEN IT EXCLUDED MEN FALL FROM
THE PRODUCTS THAT WERE
RESTRICTED.
IT LEFT IT IN AND FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS THERE'S BEEN AN
EPIDEMIC OF MENTHOL USE AMONG
AFRICAN AMERICANS THAT IS LED TO
THE DISPROPORTIONATE DYING OF
THESE PRODUCTS.
THERE IS NO REASON TO LEAVE
MENTHOL AND MET OUT OF IT.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF A PERFECT
BILL IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF ITS
BAN IT'S A QUESTION OF NOT
MAKING FLAVORS AVAILABLE AT ALL.
WHY DID THEY PUT FLAVORS IN
THESE PRODUCTS IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
THAT ALLOWS THE POISON TO GO
DOWN EASIER.
THE FDA HAS NO DATA ON HOW
MENTAL HAS HELPED ANYBODY
SWITCHED -- TO TO TO GET OFF IN
FACT.
THE DATA SHOWS THAT CIGARETTE
SMOKING HAS GONE DOWN OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS BUT WHAT IS GONNA.
IS BEEN THE YOUTH THE MALES USE
MENTHOL CIGARETTES.
AND THIS IS NOT ONLY TRUE OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
WOMEN DISPROPORTIONATELY USE
MENTHOL CIGARETTES FOLKS FROM
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IS MALE
MENTAL CIGARETTES.
NATIVE HAWAIIANS
DISPROPORTIONATELY USE THIS
PRODUCT PORTER RETAIN USE
PRODUCT.
FOLKS WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES POOR PEOPLE AND WHAT
WE'RE TALKING MOST ABOUT TODAY
OUR KIDS DISPROPORTIONATELY USE
THIS PRODUCT THERE IS NO DATA TO
SUPPORT THIS.
WHILE I APPLAUD SOME OF THE
MEASURES IN THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S SHORT SIGHTED THE THINK
THAT KEEPING MENTAL ONE MINUTE
WE'LL DO ANYTHING THAT MAKES THE
SAME MISTAKE THAT WAS MADE. TEN
TIE -- TEN YEARS AGO.
LET ME JUST CONCLUDE BY
APOLOGIZING FOR MY ACTIONS
INITIALLY WHEN THERE'S BEEN
OTHER PEOPLE CALL FOR OPPOSITION
THEY'VE USUALLY KEPT WE ARE ABLE
TO COME UP AND SIT DOWN I'M NOT
CLEAR WHY THEY WERE CALLED UP
SIT DOWN.
TODAY I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT TO BE
CLEAR MEN FALL IN FLAVORS ALLOW
THE POISON GO DOWN EASIER DON'T
MAKE A BILL THAT YOU THINK IS
REALLY GOING TO BE GREAT WHEN
YOU'RE STILL DOING THE SAME
THING.
AND REMEMBER THAT HOW IT'S JUST
PREPARED PROPORTIONALLY IMPACTED
FOR COMMUNITIES THANK SIR SIR
BEFORE YOU LEAVE JUST LET ME SAY
I I APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I WASN'T
CLEAR.
IN RESPECT TO WHO WAS CALLED UP
TO SIT AT THE THE TABLE AND GIVE
TESTIMONY SO I WAS NOT AS CLEAR
WITH THAT IS I COULD HAVE BEEN
AND I APOLOGIZE WE VALUE YOUR
COMMENTS AND ALWAYS WHEN
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO COME.
AND SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS WHETHER
IT BE PRO OR CON ON A BILL SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING AND
BEING VERY ARTICULATE ON THE ON
YOUR POSITION.
COULD I HAVE THE NEXT --
PRESENTER -- COME UP.
AND ARE TO THE MICROPHONE ENSURE
YOUR YOUR POSITION.
HELLO MY NAME IS FAITH THIRTY
AND I'M.
I JUST GRADUATED FROM VALLEY
HIGH SCHOOL AND I WILL BE
ATTENDING SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE -- AS A FRESHMAN THIS
FALL.
I'M HERE TODAY TO OPPOSE BILL AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE ON BEHALF OF
PAY PARENTS AGAINST.
VAPING E. CIGARETTES THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LEXI OUT.
I'M SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD I'M A
FORMER BE FOR AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
I'M SORRY IT WOULD BE CLEAR DID
YOU MEAN YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
DID YOU MEET OKAY.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MEGAN FORD I'M
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD AND I JUST
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL I BELIEVE
THAT PROGRESS HAS TO START
SOMEWHERE SO I'D LIKE TO VOICE
MY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
TIM GIVES AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK --
WE APPRECIATE SOME OF THE WORK
THAT'S GONE ON THE BILL WE
MAINTAIN OUR OPPOSITION --
MAINLY BECAUSE THIS BILL DOES
NOT HOLD THE INDUSTRY
ACCOUNTABLE JUL HAVE WHO HAS.
LARGELY FUEL THIS FLAVOR AND E.
CIGARETTE EPIDEMIC GETS OFF SCOT
FREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LYNN DEFREITAS AT
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
I'M ALSO GRATEFUL FOR US SOME OF
THE AMENDMENTS BUT AT MAINTAIN
OUR OPPOSITION POSITION THANK
YOU.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
STROKE ASSOCIATION WE STILL
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ARE HAPPY TO HEAR THAT SOME
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE BUT
MUST REMAIN IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME.
HI OF FIGURE RAMPS EATING FOR A
SMARTER DISABLED COMBAT VETERAN
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER ONE OF OVER
A HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE VAPOR
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION.
AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOR SMOKE
FREE ALTERNATIVES ASSOCIATION.
IS MEMBERSHIP IS OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IS WRITTEN.
HELLO BRAIN HE **** I AM A LOCAL
BUSINESS OWNER IT RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I'M A MEMBER OF THE
VAPING COMMUNITY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
COSTS -- AS FIGURED MENTIONED --
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
MEMBER CONSUMER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO SMOKE
FREE ALTERNATIVES TO TRADITIONAL
CIGARETTES.
AT THIS TIME.
I'M HERE OFFERING PROXY FOR MY
WIFE IS HOME WITH AN INJURY AND
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED REGULAR
CUSTOMERS IN MY SMALL SHOP.
WHO ALL HAVE VOICED?
AN OPINION THAT THEY ALSO THAT
THEY SHARE WITH ME THAT WE NEED
TO RESTRICT YOUTH ACCESS WHILE
PROTECTING.
ADULT ACCESS TO FLAVOR PRODUCTS.
AT THE TIME I OPPOSE THIS BILL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM AND WE'VE
MADE STRIDES TO MAKE THE BILL
ACCOMMODATING TO BOTH SIDES BUT
THEY'RE STILL NEEDS TO BE MORE
WORK DONE.
THERE'S A LOT OF VIGOROUS STILL
IN THE IN IN THE BILL AS TO
NAMING CONVENTIONS AS TO
ADVERTISING.
THAT NEED TO BE CLEARED UP
BEFORE IT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE TO
EITHER PARTY.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL ROLE PRIVATE
CITIZEN AND I OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN -- CAN
CHECK CAR I'M A SMALL LOCAL
BUSINESSMAN ALSO PRESIDENT ROOM
AFTER ASSOCIATION.
AND SOMEONE JUST SAID THAT.
YOU'D HAVE ACCESS 274%
CONVENIENCE STORES.
WELL MR GRAY'S PAPER ON PAGE
FIVE SAYS FIVE POINT 7% FROM
CONVENIENCE STORES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTY SO PLEASE GET
YOUR FACTS TOGETHER.
AND AS FAR AS GETTING.
ACCESS ONLINE I AGREE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR DOING THAT BUT IT ADDS
THIS BILL I OPPOSE THANK.
MY NAME IS MILTON WHEN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK
WE HAVE SOMEONE AT THE TABLE.
DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK.
YOU WERE ONE OF THOSE IT DIDN'T
GET RECOGNIZE I WANNA MAKE SURE.
YOUR POSITION.
YEAH I'M IN A POSITION. TO
ADVISE YOUR CIRCLE YOU WITH SURE --
WITH THAT THEY'VE TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- CONNECT
WIENER YES.
IT DID WHEN YOU HAVE A STATEMENT
YOU WANT.
YEAH OKAY SO LET'S LET'S TAKE
CARE OF YOUR STATEMENT.
THANK YOU.
SHOULD RUN IT THANK THANK YOU --
VICE CHAIRMAN -- GOOD AFTERNOON --
CHAIRMAN GRAY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S JAKE BUTCHER ON THE
STATE AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR THE
PAPER TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION --
OUR MEMBERS EMPLOYED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
COUNTRY IN HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- LAST FISCAL YEAR
AND THEY PLAN TO ST GENERATED
OVER.
A FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
AND STATE LOCAL TAXES FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- WE APPEAR
TODAY AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN THIRTY
NINE AS AMENDED -- AS DRAFTED
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN THIRTY
NINE CONTAINS MANY PROVISIONS
THAT ARE IN LINE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE POLICY AND GOALS AT
THE BEACH IS A STRICTLY
SUPPORTED.
AND ADOPTED IN THEIR OWN --
MARKETING STANDARDS SUCH AS THE
PROHIBITION MARKETING AND
PACKAGING CURES TOWARDS CHILDREN.
STIFFER PENALTIES AGAINST THOSE
WHO SELL TO MINORS.
INCLUDING STRAW PURCHASES.
WHICH IS DATA SHOWS THE PRIMARY
OFFENDERS OF UNDERAGE SALE SO
NOT THE RETAIL LEVEL.
BUT BUT FROM.
OTHERS.
ENHANCED ENFORCEMENT OF EXISTING
LAWS SO WE APPLAUD -- THE WELL
INTENTIONED EFFORTS TO CURB
YOUTH ACCESS TO PAPER PRODUCTS.
HOWEVER THE RESTRICTION OF
FLAVOR -- PAPER PRODUCTS AGE
RESTRICTED STORES WILL SEVERELY
LIMIT THE AVAILABILITY OF FLAVOR
VAPOR PRODUCTS TO ADULTS WHO
DESPERATELY TRYING TO QUIT.
AND I THINK YOU HEARD FROM SOME
OF THEM TODAY WHILE LEAVING
ACCESS TO DEADLY COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES AND FLAVORED
COMBUSTIBLE PRODUCTS ON CHANGE
SO THEY ACCESS TO THOSE.
WHO REMAIN UNCHANGED WHY WE
LIMIT THE ACCESS? TO LESS
HARMFUL TURNED OF IN PAPER
PRODUCTS WITH REGARD TO LABELING
AND MARKETING STANDARDS IN THE
BILL.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED.
MARKETING AND LABELING STANDARDS
OF COMBUSTIBLE PRODUCTS RELATED
TO CANNABIS TO POP PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR I WHICH SIMILAR TO
THE BILL AS PROPOSED BY CHAIRMAN
GRAY.
I PROHIBITS THE USE OF CARTOONS
IMITATIONS OF CANDY PACKAGING
AND LABELING.
AND THE USE OF THE TERM CANDY
AMONG OTHER ITEMS.
THE VAPOR TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
BELIEVES THAT CLEAR CONCISE AND
ENFORCEABLE MARKING LABELING
STANDARDS FOR APPROPRIATE.
HOWEVER THIS BILL GOES FAR
BEYOND.
THE LABELING AND MARKETING
RESTRICTIONS IN PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR AND CREATES A VAGUE
AND AMBIGUOUS MARKETING AND
LABELING SCHEME.
BY USING THE TERM.
OF ART REASONABLE BELIEF.
THAT THE PRODUCT COULD BE
APPEALING TO PERSONS UNDER
TWENTY ONE OF EIGHT YEARS OF AGE
AGAIN THE STANDARD.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT TO FIND ANYWHERE
I IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
AND LEAVES A LOT OF AN AMBIGUITY.
WOULD LIKE TO WORK -- WITH THE
SPONSOR TO ADDRESS THAT.
IN ADDITION THE BILL PROHIBITS.
ADVERTISING BRAND ELEMENTS TO
LIFESTYLE ADVERTISING -- WHICH
IS DEFINED UNDER THE BILL AS A
BOOKING A POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
EMOTION ABOUT IT IN THAT WAY OF
LIFE.
INCLUDING ONE THAT INCLUDES
CLAMOR RECREATION EXCITEMENT
VITALITY RISK OF DARING -- PUT
SIMPLY -- THIS IS TANTAMOUNT TO
AN ADVERTISING BAN.
GIVEN THE FACT ALL ADVERTISEMENT
ELICITS AN EMOTION.
IN ADDITION -- THE BILL
PROHIBITS THE USE OF
TESTIMONIALS WHICH IMPACTS YOU
BOIL THE BILL ANY OF REAL PEOPLE
REAL CONSUMERS. TO TELL THEIR
STORY SO THAT'S ANOTHER.
CHALLENGE WITH THE BILL AS
DRAFTED -- LASTLY THE BILL
PROPOSES PENALTIES ON BUSINESSES
WITHOUT JUSTIFICATION.
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THOSE
OF SOMEWHERE INDUSTRIES SUCH AS
ALCOHOL THIS IS FOR SALES -- TO
MINORS -- SPECIFICALLY A SIXTY
DAY LICENSE SUSPENSION ON THE
FIRST OFFENSE.
IS UNPRECEDENTED AND WHICH SHOT
SMALL VAPOUR BUSINESSES.
LIKE THOSE WHO HEARD FROM TODAY.
SO FOR THESE AND OTHER REASONS
WE OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE STRAPPED AND HOW WE
APPRECIATE -- CHAIRMAN GRACE
COMMENTS TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR AND CO
AUTHORS. TO FIND COMMON GROUND
AND MORE TARGETED APPROACHES TO
LIMITING YOUTH ACCESS TO PAPER
PRODUCTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A TWEENER IN
THE AUDIENCE.
YES THANK YOU -- JOHN WINGER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FUELS
INCONVENIENCE ALLIANCE WE
REPRESENT OVER HALF OF THE
TWELVE THOUSAND GAS STATIONS AND
CONVENIENCE STORES.
IN THE STATE -- WE'RE KIND OF IN
A TWEENER POSITION WE THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD THINGS IN
THIS BILL ESPECIALLY AROUND
ENFORCEMENT AND PENALTIES WHICH
WE KNOW IS A GOOD.
WAY AT CURBING -- TEEN ACCESS AS
WE KNOW 7580% OF MINERS THAT
OBTAIN VAPES GET IT FROM
SOMEBODY THAT'S TWENTY ONE OR
OVER THREE STOP PURCHASING SO WE
THINK THIS IS A REASONABLE
APPROACH.
TO CURBING THAT WE WOULD PUSH
BACK A LITTLE BIT ON THE
COMMENTS THAT 70% OF OF TEENS
ARE PURCHASING THESE PRODUCTS
ILLEGALLY FROM OUR STORES
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WE HAVE OVER 95%
SUCCESS RATE.
AT RESTRICTING MINORS TO AGE
VERIFIED -- GREAT RESTRICTED
PRODUCTS -- AND SO WE THINK THAT
WE HAVE -- A LONGSTANDING
HISTORY OF BEING AT THE FRONT
LINES TO PREVENT MINORS FROM
THESE -- PRODUCTS AND WE THINK
THAT THE INCREASE IN TECHNOLOGY --
VERIFICATION AS WELL AS THE
STREET THREE STRIKES LIMIT ON
OUR FOLKS IS GOING A LONG WAY
AND AND NOT PREVENTING -- MORE
YOUTH ACCESS AND SO WE DO HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH THE TWENTY ONE AND
OVER -- FLAVOR CIGARETTES
CONSIDERING THAT ARE FLAVORED.
VAPOR TECHNOLOGY MY PRODUCTS
CONSIDERING THAT WE WE DO ARE
EFFECTIVE AT AGE RESTRICTED --
AT VERIFICATION SO WE WOULD --
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THAT BUT WE
DO THINK THE MAJORITY OF THE
BILLS IN GOOD SHAPE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW THAT WAS
A TWEENER -- IS THERE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION THAT HASN'T ALREADY
SPOKEN IF YOU FORTY SPOKEN WITH
YOU'VE HAD YOUR TIME HAVE YOU
SPOKEN SIR I DID.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SO.
WITH THAT -- IF THERE'S NO OTHER
OPPOSITION AND I KNOW A COUPLE
OF SUPPORTERS GOT IN THERE ANY
OPPOSITION LINE.
IS THERE ANY OTHER SUPPORT I
DON'T WANNA MAKE SURE I WANNA
MAKE SURE ONCE HAD THEIR CHANCE.
I'LL BRING IT BACK -- TO MEMBERS
ARE THERE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
MISTER BRO.
THANK YOU -- I JUST WONDERED --
MISTER CHAIR DURING YOUR
DELIBERATIONS IF THERE IS ANY
CONSIDERATION OF THE MILITARY A
LOT OF MEN AND WOMEN COME TO
CALIFORNIA EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD
WEAR THE UNIFORM IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION ON ON THAT -- THERE
WAS SOME DISCUSSION ON THAT AND
AS I RECALL.
WE WORK WE STAYED CONSISTENT.
WITH THE LAW CURRENTLY WHEN THE
TWENTY ONE AND OVER PROVISION
WAS PASSED BACK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AS PART OF THAT PACKAGE --
MILITARY PERSONNEL WITH A
MILITARY ID CAN PURCHASE -- AND
EIGHTEEN THAT WAS THE COMPROMISE
REACHED IN THAT PACKAGE AND THIS --
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT -- WITH
THAT THANK YOU MISTER FOR CAR
FROM THAT.
MR BERMAN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SO FIRST ALL THANK YOU. TO TO
ALL THE AUTHORS OF THE BILL IN
THAT AND IT REALIZE THAT.
GROUP IS GROWING RAPIDLY --
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WELCOME ME ON
AS A JOINT AUTHORS MR I I I I
REALLY HOPE I CAN GET THERE ONE
DAY -- BUT AND I APPRECIATE THE
THE MEMBERS YOU TOOK THOSE TO
NECESSARILY ACTUALLY JUST SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT I HAD --
WHICH WERE LARGELY AROUND THE
EXCLUSION OF MEN AND MENTHOL.
FLAVORS AND AND ALSO THAT THE
AGE VERIFICATION FOR ONLINE
PURCHASES WHICH I UNDERSTAND IS
IS AN UP FRONT -- ALGORITM A
SOLUTION AS OPPOSED TO A BACK
AND HAVING THE SEAVER OF THE THE
PACKAGE SIGN.
UP FOR THE NO I I SOMETIMES BY.
ALCOHOL AND WINE -- ON THE
INTERNET AND IT'S A PAIN IN THE
**** BECAUSE I'M NEVER HOME WHEN
THEY DELIVER IT AND SO THEN THEY
KEEP IT AT THE FED EX FACILITY
AND HAVE.
TO GO TO THE FEDEX FACILITY AND
SIGN FOR IT AND THAT IS A PAIN
BUT IT'S A GOOD PAIN -- AND I
THINK IT'S IT'S I THINK IT'S A
STEP THAT.
WE SHOULD HAVE A IT'S A STEP
THAT FURTHER RESTRICTS UNDER AGE
PEOPLE FROM GETTING ACCESS IN
THIS CASE ALCOHOL AGAIN AND MY
GUESS ALCOHOL OR IN THIS CASE.
TO TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND MAKING
PRODUCTS -- AND SO -- WOULD BE
CURIOUS TO KNOW WHY THE BILL HAS
THE THE ALGORITHMIC SOLUTION AS
SENT THE RECEIVER OF THE PACKAGE
SIGNED FOR IT.
AS A THANK YOU -- FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST THING -- RESPOND TO IS
THE MENTAL MET AND AS YOU CAN
TELL FROM THE TESTIMONY PROVIDE
TODAY BOTH IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION THERE -- IS
DISCREPANCIES -- IN THAT SPACE
RIGHT YOU HAVE ACADEMIC STUDIES
ARE QUOTED BY THE FDA THAT
SUGGESTS THAT MEANT PAUL MEANT --
ARE NOT A USE.
ISSUES THAT ARE NOT DRIVING IS
CONSUMPTION YOU HAVE TO TEST
PUBLIC TESTIMONY HERE TODAY --
FOR GENTLEMEN.
WAS ASSOCIATE WITH BERKELEY IS
WHEN I HEARD -- SAYING THAT THAT
THAT IS IN FACT A DRIVER -- SO
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE COULDN'T
FIND CONSENSUS -- EVEN ALL THE
DATA OR RESEARCH ON THE SUBJECT
WE DIDN'T INCLUDE BECAUSE THE
PURPOSE OF THIS.
BILL IS TO VERY SPECIFICALLY
TARGET YOU FAX AND JIM.
THIS ISN'T A BIT BILL ABOUT
LARGER TOBACCO ISSUE THIS ISN'T
A BILL ABOUT TRADITIONAL DAHLE
PRODUCTS LIKE MENTAL THAT HAVE
BEEN IN CIRCULATION FOR DECADES.
RIGHT THIS IS A BILL -- TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASE IN USE --
UTILIZATION OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
AND SO THAT EXT YOU KNOW IT IS
WHY WOULD NOT INCLUDED THOSE --
QUOTE UNQUOTE FLAVORS AND AT
THIS JUNCTURE AND THAT IS A
DEFINITION CONSISTENT WITH THE
FDA WHERE THEY HAVE TRADITIONAL
TOBACCO MEANT BY.
MID AND MENTHOL IN ONE CATEGORY
OTHER FLAVORS LIKE FRUIT CHILL
AND CRAM AND OTHERS IN A
DIFFERENT CATEGORY -- THE SECOND
QUESTION IS -- RELATES -- TO
SIGNATURE VERIFICATION AS YOU
KNOW THAT'S A BILL THAT HAS MADE
ITS WAY THROUGH THIS --
INSTITUTION.
BEFORE.
AND IT'S A BILL AND A CONCEPT
CURRENTLY CONTAINED IN A SENATE
BILL -- ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUE
SURGERY HILL WHO HAS A BILL ON
THAT INTERFACE WITH THE THE
ONLINE DELIVERY -- WE CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW SIR HILL HAD THE OPTION
TO PARTICIPATE AND WAS ABLE TO
PRESCRIBE SUMMER STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS -- WHICH YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S GOOD ISSUE -- WE
THOUGHT ABOUT INCLUDING IT IN
THIS BILL BUT WE DECIDED -- TO
INSTEAD LET IT MOVE FORWARD IN
THE SENATOR HILL BILL WHICH IS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA -- IT WILL BE
PRESENTED FOR THE NOW TO TAKE
THAT AND COUPLE IT WITH THE AGE
VERIFICATION TECHNOLOGY MANDATE
THAT'S AND THIS LEGISLATION I
THINK YOU'VE GOT A PRETTY ROBUST
APPROACH TO ONLINE SELF.
SO DISAPPOINTED THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT SO TO MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY IF BOTH
BILLS WERE TO PASS YOUR BILL AND
CENTER HILLS BILL THEN THE
SIGNING AT TWENTY ONE IF FOR
PURCHASES ONLINE.
WHAT APPLY TO VAPING PRODUCTS?
AS WELL DO I UNDERSTAND THAT
CORRECTLY.
YOU DO GOTCHA THANKS.
THANK YOU WE HAVE MISTER MATHIS
THAN MISTER GALLAGHER IS ZERO
ANYONE ELSE WANTING TO ASK
QUESTIONS TO PONDER.
ALL RIGHT SALUTE ME.
RICHARD.
THIS QUESTION RIGHT AWAY.
SOLANA YOU SAW MY MY SON THAT
WAS WITH ME -- LAST FRIDAY.
AND HE'S ALREADY AND AT THE AGE
OF NINE ASKED ME ABOUT VAPING.
AND TALK TO ME ABOUT FLAVORS.
BUT WHAT MY CONCERN IS IN AND
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN ANSWER THIS
SIR SOMEBODY UP THERE.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE WITH THE
VAPING TECHNOLOGY FOR MARIJUANA
VERSUS CIGARETTES AND WITH THE
FLAVORS BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE FLAVOR.
OILS THAT YOU CAN BUY A FOR SAY
E. CIGARETTES IS CROSSED WITH
THE SAME STUFF THAT YOU CAN DO.
FOR VAPING MARIJUANA.
SO WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
AND HOW DO I EXPLAIN THIS TO MY
CHILDREN.
WHY I'M CERTAINLY NOT THE EXPERT
ON THIS AND -- AND NOT A PAPER --
MY UNDERSTANDING.
AND I INTO A FAMILIAR WITH EACH
OF THE DIFFERENT PRODUCT LINES
OF PERHAPS THE VAPING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION HERE -- MIGHT HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL.
INFORMATION BUT THERE ARE I
THINK OPENING CLOSE PRODUCTS
MAKE THE OIL RELATES TO THE OPEN
PRODUCTS VERSUS THE CLOTHES
PRODUCTS -- SO IF YOU'VE SEEN A
TRADITIONAL JUL.
DEVICE FOR EXAMPLE I BELIEVE
THAT'S A CLOSE PRODUCT THAT YOU
CAN'T IN CERTAIN OIL INTO -- A
WONDERFUL EVER SINCE HE'S OPEN
PRODUCTS FOR YOU CAN USE
DIFFERENT OILS AND I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE REFERENCING.
IS -- THE USE OF MARIJUANA WITH
THOSE OILS IN THOSE PRODUCTS OR
IS THAT IS THAT FOR THE THAT
THAT'S THE QUESTION I MEAN
BECAUSE THERE'S THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT THINGS OUT
THERE.
IN THE EVEN CANNOT WHERE WERE
YOU I MEAN HI I JUST ONE ON
AMAZON JUST JUST TO CHECK IN AND
GO BOLD THE THE SAME QUESTION
WHAT.
POPS UP IS YOU CAN BUY THESE
LITTLE TO THE OIL.
THE YOU CAN USE FOR VAPING
MARIJUANA -- VAPING.
NICOTINE FOR THE E. THE IT GOES
EITHER WAY.
CHAU IF THE GOAL IS TO GET
FLAVORED.
TOBACCO AWAY FROM OUR KIDS
WHAT'S TO STOP.
THEM JUST BUYING THE OIL THAT'S
GONNA BE ON SELF FOR MARIJUANA --
GETTING HOLE THAT.
IN IF THE DEVICES.
CROSS BACK AND FORTH WITH THE
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
THEN WHAT THE HELL ARE WE REALLY
DON'T.
AND WHY ISN'T THE BILL BROAD
ENOUGH TO COVER BOTH.
BECAUSE OF OUR GOAL IS TO KEEP
OUR YOUTH FROM SMOKING AND
VAPING.
THEN THIS BILL CLEARLY ISN'T
PRODUCT AND THAT'S THAT'S MY
LARGEST CONCERN.
IS WE WE'VE GOT KIDS ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
LEVEL THAT ARE TALKING ABOUT VPN.
AND THESE PRODUCTS.
WHETHER IT'S FOR E. CIGARETTES
OR EMAIL HONOR WHAT WHATEVER YOU
WANNA CALL VAPING IS VAPING.
EVERYTHING CROSSES OVER IN THE
PRODUCTS IN THE TECHNOLOGY OR
JUST GONNA COME OUT WITH IS
GONNA CROSSOVER ANYWAY.
SO.
THERE'S NOT REALLY I I DON'T SEE
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO STOP THIS
UNLESS YOU ADDRESS VAPING AS A
WHOLE.
VERSUS GOING AFTER BIG TOBACCO
VERSES BIG MARIJUANA THAT WE'RE
GIVING GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES.
TO SHOW A EXPLAIN IT TO ME.
IF IF I MIGHT RESPOND THIS MASS
APPRECIATE QUESTION -- I THINK
PERHAPS YOUR MISUNDERSTAND MIS
CHARACTERIZING PORTION BILL IN
THE SENSE THAT THIS DOES APPLY.
TO THOSE FLAVORS -- OPENED OR
CLOSED SYSTEM -- CURRENTLY THERE --
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND LICENSED
TOBACCO RETAILERS IN THE STATE.
UNDER OUR PROPOSAL THE SALE OF
THOSE FLAVORED PRODUCTS BE IT --
OILS -- IN AN OPEN ENDED PRODUCT
FOR BE IT IN A CLOSED SYSTEM
WOULD ONLY BE AVAILABLE FOR
PURCHASE.
AT VAPE.
SMOKE SHOP LOCATIONS WHERE -- IN
LET ME READ YOU SPECIFICALLY THE
DEFINITION SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT -- ANY TOBACCO ONLY STORE
WHICH GENERATES MORE THAN 60% OF
ITS GROSS ANNUAL REVENUE FROM
THE SALE OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS
IMPAIR.
FOR NINE DOES NOT SELL ALCOHOL
OR FOOD FOR CONSUMPTION ON THE
PREMISES -- AND PROHIBITS MINOR
XIN ENTERING UNLESS THAT PERSON
IS ACCOMPANIED BY HIS OR HER
PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN SO THAT
IS WHAT A TOBACCO ONLY STORE IS
NOW WE KNOW -- AND ACTUALLY I
WAS DISAPPOINTED WHEN I
CONTACTED THE BILL WE THE PART
OF PUBLIC HEALTH -- I HAD ONE OF
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES I'M SURE
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THIS MATHIS
WE TALKED A COUPLE GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND THEY POINT BE
OPPOSITE DIRECTIONS AND SAY WELL
THE OTHER PERSON KNOWS -- WHEN I
ASKED SPECIFICALLY HAS Y.
WEARING GEO CORRECT THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT -- BUT WHAT WE DO
KNOW IS THERE'S ROUGHLY -- FIVE
HUNDRED VAPE SHOPS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S CURRENTLY --
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND RETAILERS SO
WHAT WE'RE DOING EFFECTIVELY
THIS BILL AS IT RELATES -- TO
FLAVORED PRODUCTS -- THAT WOULD
BE APPLICABLE TO MARIJUANA WORE
TRADITIONAL TOBACCO USE -- OR
YOU CIGARETTE USE -- WOULD BE
RESTRICTING FROM THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND POINTS OF SALE DOWN TO
LESS THAN A THOUSAND ARGUABLY I
AM AND AS WE MOVE THE BILL FORD
WILL DIAL THAT NUMBER AND TO THE
EXACT NUMBER -- THAT IN IN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE 20% MANDATE.
ON STING OPERATIONS GIVES US A
FAR MORE EFFECTIVE TOOL AND I
WOULD PUSH BACK A LITTLE BIT
I'VE HEARD TESTIMONY -- PROVIDED
TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY THAT
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THIS BILL IS
DOING NOTHING TO THE INDUSTRY TO
THE MANUFACTURE.
OF THESE PRODUCTS WELL IF YOU
WERE MANUFACTURED MANY PRODUCT
AND I TOLD YOU WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND PLACES YOU
CAN SELL YOUR PRODUCTS TO REDUCE
IT TO LESS THAN A THOUSAND I
WOULD SUPPORT FOR THAT'S A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
ON YOUR BOTTOM LINE AT YOUR
BUSINESS -- BUT WHAT THAT
EFFECTIVELY DOES ALLOW US TO
REGULATE IT BETTER AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE PRODUCTS ARE NOT
GETTING INTO THE HANDS OF OUR
KIDS.
IMAGE JORDAN WILL JUMP IN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IN FURTHERANCE OF THAT POINT.
I THINK IT'S SUPPORT UNDERSTAND
UNDER THE STAKE ACT WHICH IS THE
CURRENT SOARED INTO TOBACCO OF
LONG CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S ONLY THREE GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES THAT HAVE THE
JURISDICTION TO REGULATE THIS
ONE'S THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S DOING
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING. TO CURB TEEN
DATING.
THE OTHER IS -- THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AS WE'VE DISCUSSED IS
UNDER RESOURCE WE TALKED THAN
THAT WITH THEM AND THEY TOLD US
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
POLICE THIS ISSUE WITH OVER
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND POINTS OF
SALE IN CALIFORNIA.
OKAY.
AND THE THIRD IS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES I ASK.
ALL SORTS LAW ENFORCEMENT
FRIENDS OF MINE AND POLICE
CHIEFS AND SHERIFFS AND NONE OF
THEM ARE DOING ANTI TEEN DATING
STINKS NOT A ONE THAT WE'VE HAD.
EVER TALKED TO HER.
SO WHAT AND UNDERSTAND TOO THAT
THE PENALTIES IN TERMS OF THE
RETAILERS THAT ARE SELLING --
ILLEGALLY SELLING TO MINORS.
OR UNDER CURRENT LAUNDERED STEAK
ACT OR ARE.
ARE VIRTUALLY NOTHING IT TAKES
GETTING CAUGHT THREE TIMES TO
HAVE ANY SUSPENSION OF YOUR
RETAIL LICENSE TO SELL TOBACCO.
YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH IT TWICE
GET CAUGHT RED HANDED I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU GET CAUGHT BECAUSE
THERE'S NO BE DOING STINKS.
OKAY BUT SAY YOU GOT CAUGHT SOME.
SAY RANDY MISTER CUNNINGHAM
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT HELPING WITH
THE BILL BECAUSE NOW YOU'RE
SEEING IS NOT BEING ENFORCED AT
ALL DOES THAT'S THAT'S UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
CHANGE SO HERE'S HERE'S THE
GOODNESS UNDER THIS BILL.
YOU GET CAUGHT THE FIRST TIME
THERE'S LICENSE SUSPENSION THE
FINES TRIPLED AND AND WE'RE AS
THE CHAIR SAID WE'RE RESTRICTING
POINTS ACCESS FROM THIRTY
SOMETHING THOUSAND CONVENIENCE
STORES. TO ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR SO WHICH MAY GROW
OVER TIME BUT NOW WE CAN TAKE
OUR RESOURCES AND DEVOTED TO
DOING STINGS WHERE WE KNOW THE
KIDS ARE TRYING. TO BUY THE
PRODUCTS AND THEN WE'VE GOT
PUNISHMENT.
ON THE RETAILERS THAT ARE
SELLING ILLEGALLY WE DON'T HAVE
EITHER OF THOSE THINGS UNDER
CURRENT LAW THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT.
QUESTION COMES FROM MISTER
GALLAGHER BUT I WANT TO BE REAL
CLEAR ON ON THAT POINT.
IT ISN'T NOBODY.
DOING ANYTHING BECAUSE THE A TF
IS DOING -- STING OPERATIONS ON
A REGULAR BASIS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COMES UNDER
THE A TF ON THE FEDERAL SIDE
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT DEALS WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
PUTTING REGULATION SO THE STATE.
CAN ACTUALLY HELP -- MITIGATE
THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING
HERE EXACTLY -- MISTER GRAY IF I
IF I CAN CLARIFY THAT FURTHER --
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW -- IN
CERTAIN THE A TF AND AND EFFORTS.
MORE TOWARDS BLACK MARKET
ACTIVITIES -- DO OCCUR -- WHAT
WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS SHORT
COMING UP AND ANY OF THE MEMBERS
WHO PARTICIPATED -- IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS SLASH INVESTIGATIVE
MEETINGS INCLUDING ME WOULD
PROBABLY HELP IS IT IS JUST NOT
THERE'S NOT RESOURCES AND
THERE'S NOT AFFECTED PLANNED
THERE AND WE'RE NOT CONDUCTING
STING OPERATIONS -- ON TOBACCO --
THE SALES TO MINORS AND AND
FRANKLY THE PENALTIES WERE A BIT
OF A JOKE AND CURRENT LAW I MEAN
AS MISTER CUNNINGHAM TO SHARE
WITH YOU YOU COULD SELL TWO
TIMES. TO A MINOR WITH WITH WITH
NO PENALTY ON THAT THIRD
OCCASION -- THERE WERE SOME
SUSPENSION OF YOUR SALES OF
CENTER UNDER OUR BILL THE FIRST
TIME YOU DO IT -- THERE ARE
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES THE SECOND
TIME YOU DO IT THERE ARE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES AND THE THIRD TIME
YOU DO IT YOU'RE NOT SELLING
ANYMORE SO THESE ARE THESE ARE
WERE SENDING A MESSAGE TO
RETAILERS GET IT RIGHT -- AND
ALSO IT DOES SO THE KIDS OKAY SO
WE HAVE MISTER GALLAGHER THEN MR
BONTA THAN MR COOLEY.
SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- A
PRE SHEET TO THE AUTHORS HERE
FOR TRYING TO THREAD THE NEEDLE
HERE ON A AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I WANT TO FOCUS IN ON ONE OF MY
CONCERNS HERE IS THE BAND.
AND THE LIMIT ON FLAVORS.
AND THEN ALSO -- YOU KNOW THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT RESTRICTING IT
TO I GUESS OR TO DO A TERM IN
TOBACCO -- STORES -- I AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ABOUT PROTECTING
MINORS.
AND ENSURING THAT WE CRACKED
DOWN ON THOSE WHO ARE SELLING TO
MINORS THAT WE HAVE BETTER
PROTECTIONS AS MISTER CUNNINGHAM
WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT -- TO GET
AT THE BAD ACTORS -- ALSO ON THE
ADVERTISING I MEAN I YOU KNOW
THE THINGS THAT ARE VERY CLEARLY
EASING CARTOONS AND AND THINGS
LIKE THAT ARE CLEARLY TRYING TO
TARGET.
USE.
I THINK THOSE ARE GOOD
PROVISIONS BUT I DO BELIEVE
FUNDAMENTALLY THAT ADULTS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO MAKE ADULT DECISIONS.
AND I KNOW THAT.
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT AN ADULT IS ANYMORE
ESPECIALLY IN THIS BUILDING --
BECAUSE LET ME.
I THINK WE'RE GETTING CLOSE TO
HAVING THE NEXT QUESTION LET ME.
LET ME CLARIFY BECAUSE IN THIS
CONTEXT THAT'S YOU'RE AN ADULT
IF YOU'RE.
TWENTY ONE RIGHT.
ANOTHER BILL THIS YEAR.
IS PROPOSING A THE VOTING AGE TO
BE SEVENTEEN YOU KNOW SO
APPARENTLY YOU'RE NOT ADULT
ENOUGH TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
SMOKING AND TOBACCO -- BUT YOU
WELL FORMED ENOUGH TO MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT GOOGLE. TO OFFICE.
YOU KNOW WE ALSO HAVE V<c.cyan>ALSO</c>
PASSED LEGISLATION HERE THAT IF
YOU COMMIT VERY SERIOUS CRIMES
AGAINST PEOPLE IN YOUR TWENTY
FOUR YEARS OLD -- YOU SHOULD BE
TREATED AS AN ADULT BECAUSE YOU
HAVE HOT BRAIN.
SO YOU KNOW IT'S EASY TO BE
CONFUSED AROUND HERE ABOUT WHAT
AN ADULT IS BUT I DIGRESS -- BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHEN YOU ARE
AN ADULT WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
DETERMINE THAT IS I THINK IT'S
EIGHTEEN WHENEVER YOU'RE AN
ADULT I THINK YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO MAKE ADULT DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TO USE TOBACCO
AND MAYBE YOU MAYBE YOU DECIDE
YOU LIKE CERTAIN.
FLAVORS.
OR NOT AND I THINK BY US
ARBITRARILY LIMITING WHAT
FLAVORS SHOULD BE OUT THERE AND
SAY THERE SHOULD ONLY BE THREE
IN THE WORLD. TO ME IS.
YOU KNOW NOT RESPECTFUL OF THAT
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE --
CERTAINLY WE CAN MAKE SURE THOSE
ARE TARGETED TOWARDS USE -- YOU
KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
ADVERTISING THE BILL DOES THAT
BUT LET ME.
TO THREE YOU KNOW THREE FLAVORS
TO ME I I DON'T SEE WHY WE WOULD
DO THAT FOR PEOPLE WHO CAN MAKE
ADULT DECISIONS.
AND ALSO YOU'RE LIMITING THE
ABILITY THAT PEOPLE CAN AS AN
ADULT AND HAVING THE RIGHT TO DO
THIS.
WHERE THEY CAN GET ACCESS TO A
PRODUCT THAT THEY USE -- MANY
PEOPLE GO TO GAS STATIONS AT THE
OTHER MS STOP TO GET GAS AND
THEY HAPPEN.
TO YEAH PARTAKE IN THAT HABIT
THAT MANY OF US THINK IS NOT
GOOD FOR YOU.
WE WOULD ALL SAY THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION OUT THERE
THAT TELLS YOU THAT -- BUT
THAT'S THEIR RIGHT AND WE'RE
GONNA BE LIMITING THAT UNIVERSE
SO I HAVE A I HAVE A PROBLEM
FROM JUSTICE FUNDAMENTAL SENSE
OF ADULTS.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKEADULT
DECISIONS.
AND THEN SECONDLY I THINK
THERE'S SOME LEGITIMATE
DISCUSSION HERE IT WAS REYES
SAYS.
THESE RESTRICTIONS ALSO SEEM TO
MAYBE FAVOR CERTAIN BUSINESSES
OVER OTHERS.
AND I THINK THAT COULD BE
PROBLEMATIC TO BECAUSE LOOK
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE IN THIS MARKET -- THEY MAY
HAVE DIFFERENT PRODUCTS THAT
THAT IS A MARKET I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE SHOULD GET IN THE
BUSINESS OF REGULATING.
WHAT KIND OF PRODUCTS YOU CAN
HAVE?
EXCEPT FOR WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
LAID OUT IF YOU'RE IF YOU ARE
TARGETING IN ADVERTISING TO KIDS
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
AND I THINK WE CAN DO THAT.
I THINK WE CAN DO THAT AND
PROTECT USE LEGITIMATELY.
WITHOUT DOING THE THE THREE
FLAVORS AND THEN MAYBE MY FINAL
POINT.
DOES AGAIN THE YOUNG LADY FROM
MODESTO HIGH GREAT JOB.
BY THE WAY AND I'M GLAD YOU WERE
ABLE TO GET HER HERE -- YEAH BUT
THINGS AVE NOT CHANGED IT SEEMS
TO ME.
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL RIGHT
IT WAS ABOUT FLAVORED CHEWING
TOBACCO RED AND?
YOU KNOW THAT WAS THE THING THAT
WAS GOING OUT THERE ALTHOUGH THE
MARKET DID.
ADDRESS THE SOMEWHAT IS IT
PEOPLE VERY QUICKLY FOUND.
THAT CHERRY SCHOOL.
NOT A GOOD CHOICE -- ANYWAY IT'S
WITH THAT I WILL I WILL IN MY
POINTS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THOSE -- THOSE TWO THINGS.
I THINK IF WE CAN CONSIDER THOSE
IN THE FUTURE MAYBE YOU CAN
RESPOND TO SIR THANK YOU --
MICHIGAN ALL RIGHT I WILL.
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND EXCEL
YOUR THIRD QUESTION WE'RE GOING
TO FOCUS ON YOUR FIRST.
TWO AND THAT THE FIRST ISSUE
RAISED -- WAS THIS ISSUE OF THIS
INSTITUTION STRUGGLING TO FIND
THE AGE OF MAJORITY AND I THINK
YOU KNOW -- INPRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN YOU AND I
THAT I AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT
SUBJECT IN FACT I THINK I'M ONE
OF THE FEW PEOPLE IN MY PARTY IN
THIS INSTITUTION.
WHO VOTED AGAINST CHANGING --
THE AGE RESTRICTION.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE I DID
THAT BECAUSE I ARRIVE AT THE AGE
OF MAJORITY AT THE AGE THAT YOU
CAN ENTER THE MILITARY.
FORGET ASKED YOUNG PEOPLE TO DIE
FOR THIS COUNTRY THEN THEY CAN
MAKE IT DON'T CHOICES THAT'S MY
POSITION IT'S BEEN MY POSITION
IN MY VOTING RECORD CONSISTENT.
HAVING SAID THAT OTHER PEOPLE
FEEL DIFFERENTLY.
THIS IS A IN PERFECT BILL THAT'S
A PRODUCT OF COMPROMISE RIGHT
AND ALL OF US CAN TAKE OUR
RESPECTIVE IDEOLOGICAL POSITION
TO BE PEER.
RIGHT I CAN REFUSE TO SUPPORT
ANYTHING THAT ADDRESSES --
SUBJECTS THAT IN OR INCONSISTENT
PERHAPS MY PERSPECTIVE BUT WHAT
WE ALL AGREE ON A WHICH ARE
BROAD CONSENSUS AMONG COLLEAGUES
AND MEMBERS IN MEETINGS ON IS
THAT.
EVERYBODY AGREES WE'VE GOT A
PROBLEM WITH TOO MANY KIDS USE
THESE PRODUCTS.
AND SOME HAS TO BE DONE ABOUT IT
SO WHETHER NOT WE CAN AGREE TO
BAN ALL FLAVORS OR WHETHER NOT
WE CAN AGREE ON THE NUMBER OF
FLAVORS THAT ARE AVAILABLE WHERE.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO GET A
HANDLE ON THAT.
AND I WOULD REMIND YOU THAT
LICENSE BEING LICENSE TO SELL
CERTAIN PRODUCTS IS A PRIVILEGE.
RIGHT -- YOU MADE THE POINT
WHILE YOU KNOW WHY SHOULD WE
RESTRICT WHAT A BUSINESS CAN AND
CAN'T SELL WELL.
IF I WANT A BAR I CAN SELL UNCLE.
IF YOUR LEMONADE STAND YOU CAN'T.
WELL I'M NOT THEY THEY THEY
THOSE IMPORTANT RESTRICTIONS AND
THEN THERE'S PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS -- IT INVOLVED THE WHY
WE MAKE THOSE TO TRY AND THAT'S
NOT ANY DIFFERENT HERE RIGHT WE
HAVE LICENSE READERS NOW WORK IN
THIS CASE UNDER OUR BILL GOING
TO HAVE.
TOBACCO ONLY VAPE SHOP LOCATIONS
IT'S A SPECIAL -- PART OF THE
MARKET WE'RE GONNA ALLOW ALL
FLAVORS TO BE SALT.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TRADITIONAL
TOBACCO WHICH IS THE THREE I
THINK YOU'RE REFERRING TO WHICH
IS MEANT MENTHOL AND TRADITIONAL
TOBACCO FLAVORED PRODUCTS --
SOLD -- AS THEY ARE TODAY IN THE
STORES WIDELY AVAILABLE CAN MEAN
STORAGE GROCERY STORES IT'S
CENTER.
SO I THINK IT'S ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE THAT WE LIMIT THE
SALE THE PRODUCTS INTO A SMALLER
NUMBER OF RETAIL LOCATIONS AS IT
RELATES TO PRODUCTS THAT ARE TOO
OFTEN FINDING THEMSELVES IN THE
HANDS OF CHILDREN.
WE OBVIOUSLY TO GET A BETTER
HANDLE ON IT WELL LET'S TAKE IT
FROM THIRTY ONE THOUSAND LESS
THAN A THOUSAND AND THEN LET'S
GO TO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THE TOOLS. TO
PROPERLY ENGAGE IN STING
OPERATIONS SO THAT WE KNOW THOSE
LOCATIONS ARE NOT SO MUCH AND ON
TOP OF THAT JUST LIKE A BAR
LET'S REMOVE THE ABILITY OF
SOMEBODY UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE WHO CAN'T LEGALLY BUY A
PRODUCT AND REPLACE.
RIGHT YOU DON'T SEE SIXTEEN YEAR
OLDS WALKING INTO BARS BECAUSE
THERE'S NOTHING IN A BAR THE
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD CAN LEGALLY BUY
RIGHT.
AND SO IT'S NOT ONLY THAT THEY
CAN'T BUY SOMETHING THERE BUT
THEY CAN'T EVEN GO IN AND THAT'S
THE THE CONSTRUCT WERE SETTING
UP -- IN THIS BILL -- HI AGAIN.
IS IT THE PERFECT ANSWER ALL
FLAVORS -- MAYBE MAYBE NOT FOR
SOME FOLKS -- YOU MISTER BERMAN
ARTICULATED THAT MENTAL MEANT
SOMETHING THAT IS ON HIS MIND --
MISTER BONTA MAY HAVE OTHER
IDEAS ON HIS MIND.
BUT THE EXCUSE OF WE CAN'T AGREE
ON FLAVORS -- TO NOT MOVE
FORWARD TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
TAKE THESE PRODUCTS IN THE
ACCESS IS PRODUCTS AWAY FROM
CHILDREN IS JUST RIDICULOUS AND
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE AND WE ALL
OUGHT TO MAKE THE NECESSARY
COMPROMISES. TO GET TO A PLACE
WE CAN SUPPORT A BILL THAT'S
GOING TO INCREASE ENFOCEMENT IS
GOING TO GET A HANDLE ON THIS
RIGHT AND WE'VE GOT A SUNSET IN
HERE. FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
CONSISTENT WITH THE FDA WE CAN
COME BACK TO THIS BODY AND IF IF
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH IT'S NOT
STRINGENT AFTER THIS OTHER
THINGS WERE MISSING.
WE WILL REVIEW WILL PUT THOSE IN
PLACE.
JOINT AUTHORS ON ANYTHING WELL I
SHOULD.
AND YOU WERE QUITE ELOQUENT
MISTER GRAY BUT I DID WANT TO
JUST ADD -- TO MISTER
CUNNINGHAM'S POINT THAT WE
SHOULD LET THE PERFECT -- BE THE
ENEMY OF THE GOOD I THINK IT'S
ALSO ABOUT CREATING.
STEPPING STONES OF STRATEGIC
PROHIBITIONS AND LIMITATIONS.
AND ALLOWING THOSE TO KIND OF BE
FORMULATED AN INSTITUTIONALIZED
SO THAT WE CAN THEN COME BACK
AND SAY HOW CAN WE EXPAND ON
THIS I DON'T THINK ANY ONE OF US --
IN THIS HOUSE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE CAN REALLY SAY THAT
WE'VE CREATED ST SILVER BULLET
LEGISLATION THAT HAS FIXED ALL
ISSUES IN ONE BILL.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
SEE THIS AS THE FOUNDATION FOR
BEGINNING TO GROW AND EXPAND
THOSE LARGER CONVERSATION AROUND
STOPPING OR PROHIBITING.
THE SALE OF THE CIGARETTES TO
MINORS.
YOU KNOW WHO ARE STILL HAVING
THEIR BRAIN DEVELOPED BY THE AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE WHEN THESE
PRODUCTS CAN BE DISASTROUS LEE
ADDICTIVE RIGHT SO -- I THINK
WHAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT IS THAT
WERE RECOGNIZING WE'RE GOING
AFTER THE RETAILERS RATHER THAN
PUNISHING THE USE.
AND TO DO QUITE OFTEN IN THIS
BUILDING.
MR BONTA WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
YOUR QUESTION I WOULD AND I WANT
TO START BY EXPRESSING MY DEEP
RESPECT AND APPRECIATION TO THAT
THE JOINT AUTHORS FOR TAKING ON
A VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE.
AND FOR DOING VERY HARD WORK I I
UNDERSTAND YOU'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
MEETING AFTER MULTIPLE HOURS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS WITH WITH
MEMBERS WITH OTHER AUTHORS TO
TRY TO PULL TOGETHER A A
SOLUTION AND I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND -- THE ART OF THE
DEAL THE INSIGNIFICANCE OF
COMPROMISED -- A NEED TO NOT
HAVE THE PERFECT BE THE ENEMY
THE OF THE GOOD AND I I DO WANNA --
EXPRESS.
MY SUPPORT FOR A CERTAIN
COMPONENTS OF THIS BILL AND
INCLUDING -- THE PENALTIES
AGAINST RETAILERS WHO DON'T
COMPLY WITH THE LAW YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO REMOVE THE
PENALTIES AGAINST OUT THOSE WERE
UNDER AGE I THINK THOSE ARE
EXCELLENT.
AND AND I APPRECIATE THEM VERY
MUCH THAT THE PART THAT.
HANGS ME UP -- RIGHT NOW IN THE
CURRENT FORM OF THE BILL IS IS
THE FLAVOR ISSUE -- I'M NOT
ENTIRELY A PURIST ON IT BUT I
THINK.
THE MINT FLAVOR IS VERY
ATTRACTIVE TO KIDS -- I KNOW
YOU'VE ALREADY MENTIONED THIS
COMPETING STUDIES WE HAVEN'T
AGREED IN THIS ROOM.
THAT HAPPENS SOMETIMES IN OUR
DEBATE -- BUT FROM ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE FROM OTHER EVIDENCE
THAT I'VE HEARD -- I THINK IT'S
VERY ATTRACTIVE TO KIDS -- MAYBE
MENTHOL LESS SO -- AND IN MY OWN
DISTRICT I'VE HAD CITIES --
OAKLAND SAN LEANDRO ALAMEDA THAT
HAVE -- BAND ALL FLAVORS EXCEPT
FOR TRADITIONAL TOBACCO SO AT
LEAST AT TIMES WITH SOMEBODY'S
THERE THERE CAN BE THE POLITICAL
WILL. TO GO THAT EXTRA MILE --
IN WAYS THAT I I THINK WE'LL
PROTECT KIDS.
SO.
HAVING SAID THAT.
I HOPE THE BUILDING DOES MOVE
FORWARD TODAY I THINK IT WILL --
I DON'T BELIEVE I'M ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL UNLESS IT'S
NECESSARY -- TO GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION -- BUT I AM HOPEFUL
GIVEN THE PROCESS YOU'VE BEEN
COMMITTED -- TO MISTER GRAY AND
ALL OF THE JOINT AUTHORS TO
LISTEN TO OTHERS -- TO TO BRING
THE BEST IDEAS TO THE TABLE AND
TO MAKE CHANGE WHEN NECESSARY TO
GET A BETTER MORE.
BILL -- THAT MAYBE THERE'S
SOMETHING IN THE FUTURE I WILL
BE ABLE SUPPORT SO I I THINK YOU.
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
RESPONSE AND AND I JUST I TAKE
THAT AS AN OPPORTUNIST SAY.
THAT'S ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
BODY THAT -- THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS WE'VE GOT THE
FOUNDATION AND MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE SAID IT WELL -- OF
WILL BE FOR DOING SOME REAL ON
ACCESS TO PRODUCTS -- THE
COMPONENTS IN PEACE THIS BILL
THERE'S ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT
RIGHT THERE'S ROOM FOR FRESH
IDEAS NEW IDEAS -- MISS CALMER
DOG JUST CAME TO US I THINK
SHE'S MADE IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
BILL -- IN HER COMMENTS IN HER
ADDITIONS -- AND I WOULD WELCOME
YOU KNOW FURTHER COMMENTS YOU GO
FORWARD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO
LAY OFF -- YEAH WE WILL WE WILL
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH AND
WELCOME NEW IDEAS AND IF WE CAN --
STRAIGHT FROM THE PROVISIONS
HAPPY TO DO SO -- BUT WE ALL
FEEL STRONGLY THAT SOMETHING HAS
TO BE DONE -- THIS YEAR.
MR COOLEY NEXT AND THEN MISTER
COOPER THAN MISTER GIBSON.
I JUST WANT TO SAID THEY YOU
KNOW ADAM I'M LOOKING THIS BILL
I THINK IT'S A GOOD STRONG BILL
SO MANY FRONTS.
I DON'T ACTUALLY QUITE
UNDERSTAND.
THE PURPOSE OF THE SUNSET CLAUSE
UNDER SECTION.
SEVEN THAT'S THE PROVISION OF
THE BILL THAT SAYS -- WE'RE
ADDING SOME TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE TOBACCO RETAILERS LICENSE
SHALL NOT SELL FLAVORED
CIGARETTES EXCEPT AS PROVIDED.
WE DO ALLOW THE TOBACCO THE
MEANT THE MENTAL FLAVORS -- IT
INCLUDES A PROHIBITION ON SALE
UNDER TWENTY ONE AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR AGE
VERIFICATION.
I'M JUST UNDERSTANDING WHY.
WHAT THE ROLE OF A SUNSET IS ON
THAT TYPE OF PROVISIONS ACTUALLY?
THOSE ARE RESTRICTIONS ON THE
MARKET PLACE.
AND WE CAN STILL BE BACK IN THAT
DEBATE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF
WORKERS SERVER WAS GOING ON IT
SEES WE HAVE RESTATED THE
RESTRICTIONS.
AND THEN DO BY OPERATIONAL ALL
TWELVE OR ONE MIDNIGHT ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THOSE RULES THOSE
RESTRICTIONS GO AWAY.
IS IT'S LIKE WELL WHY DO WE DO
THAT TO YOURSELF.
IS FOR WERE GIVEN UP THE REGULAR
REGULATION THE MARKET PLACE WE
HAVE TO RE ENACTED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
MR COOLEY AND OVERALL SHOCK TO
HAVE YOU ASK A QUESTION ABOUT
PROCESS.
BUT BUT YOU MADE A GREAT POINT
WHY ARE WE YOU KNOW QUICKLY
MOVING BACKWARDS AT THAT
JUNCTURE BY -- THE INCLUSION
SUNSET AND WHAT I WOULD SAY YOU
IS WE'VE MADE GREAT EFFORT.
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS TO TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY -- THE BODY OF
WORK THAT HAVE BEEN DONE AT THE
FDA -- WHERE THIS IS BEEN A HOT
TOPIC IN MUCH WORK HAS BEEN DONE --
THEY HAVE A PROCESS.
THAT THAT IS CONSISTENT --
TIMING WISE WITH AND WE LOOKED
AT IT FROM THE VIEWPOINT OF THIS
FORCE US BACK TO THE TABLE TO
REVIEW -- THE ACTIVITIES AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROVISIONS
WOULD PUT THIS BILL INTO PERHAPS
STRENGTHEN THEM AT THAT TIME --
BUT CERTAINLY I CAN SAY FOR
MYSELF AND WILL SPEAK FOR ALL
THE ALTERS THAT JUST OFF THE
CUFF -- IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
I FEEL.
COULDN'T TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
THE FOR SOME REASON YOU THOUGHT
THE REMOVAL OF THE SUNSET.
ADDED SOME -- GRAVITY TO THE
BILL -- THAT CERTAINLY I'D BE
OPEN MINDED ABOUT IT -- BUT
HOPEFULLY THAT EXPLAINS AT LEAST
THE THOUGHT PROCESS OF HOW WE
ARRIVED AT THAT POSITION.
YEAH HI I I WILL SAY YOU HAVE
TWO SECTIONS WITH THE SUNSET.
THE SECOND ONE I THINK MAKES
PERFECTLY GOOD SENSE.
THIS ONE IS MORE OF AN ISSUE --
I'M INCLINED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BUT AS IT MOVES TO THE
FLOOR.
THAT'S THE THING THAT I MOSTLY
FOCUSED ON I SORT OF THINK.
FROM A PUBLIC POLICY STANDPOINT
TO JUST LEAVE THE RULES IN PLACE --
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO WE DON'T
SLIDE BACKWARDS SO WHAT THE
RESTRICTIONS ARE WE STILL ENGAGE
DEBATE IS EMPTY IS DOING THINGS.
BUT I THINK IT.
IT MAKES CLEAR THAT WE WE
MAINTAINING CALIFORNIA STRONG
RESTRICTIONS.
UNTIL A FUTURE LET'S SEE BY
DECIDE YOU WANT TO CHANGE THEM.
AND NOT THAT.
THE CLOCK PAST MIDNIGHT AND NOW
WE DON'T HAVE THOSE CONTROLS IN
PLACE THAT.
SEEMS A LITTLE.
DOESN'T MAKE GOOD SENSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE COM WILL
CERTAINLY -- TAKE NOTE OF IT AND
AND FOLLOW UP TO SEE IF WE CAN'T --
ARRIVE SOMEWHERE BETTER.
THANK YOU.
ON OUR NEXT QUESTION COMES FROM
MISTER RUBIO.
I MEAN RISK MR REGIS.
YEAH SO I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BE
HERE SOON AS RUN AROUND
EVERYWHERE -- BUT I I YOU KNOW I
DO APPRECIATE -- CO AUTHORS IS
I'VE -- I'VE BEEN A PART OF THIS
PROCESS AND YOU KNOW MY LIFE.
PRIOR TO BE HERE THE
LEGISLATURE'S I WORKED AT A HIGH
SCHOOL VERY LARGE ICE OVER TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
OTHERS TO SUPPORT MANAGER.
SEMI TO HIGH SCHOOL.
AND IN MY ROLE AS TO SUPPORT
EVERY DAY I SAW THIS VAPING
EPIDEMIC RIGHT BEFORE MY EYES IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
AND THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
QUESTION THAT YOU KNOW THE NEED
TO ACT IS IS IS IS CLEAR -- AND
AND AND AS A FATHER OF A YOUNG
CHILD YEAH I REFUSE TO SIT ON
THE SIDELINES AND DO NOTHING
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO WAIT AND SO THAT'S WHY
I APPRECIATE.
THIS APPROACH I APPRECIATE --
ARE CHAIR.
MY COLLEAGUES THAT I WORK WITH
OVER THE LAST -- TWO OR THREE
MONTHS -- YOU KNOW OF THE FOR
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK AND THEIR LEADERSHIP.
THIS OBVIOUSLY ISN'T A PERFECT
BILL -- BUT I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT --
YOU KNOW WE CAN REACH A A A GOOD
COMPROMISE AND DO SOMETHING
BECAUSE DOING NOTHING IN MY
OPINION IS IS IS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE -- IN AS A NEW MEMBER
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SACRAMENTO.
I REALLY HAVE APPRECIATED THE
STOP FULL -- AND THIS A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH THAT HAS
BEEN TAKEN.
YOU KNOW TO TO BE PART OF THIS
WORKING GROUP OF OF LEGISLATORS
THAT RECOGNIZE THIS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM AND WE HAVE THIS
COMMITMENT AMONGST OURSELVES OR
MONKS THIS LEGISLATION TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
IT'S A CERTAINLY YOU KNOW I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE HEALTH
ADVOCATES FOR THEIR DEDICATION
AND TIRELESS FIGHT TO PROTECT
PEOPLE FROM THE DANGERS OF ALL
TYPES OF THE TOBACCO PRODUCTS --
AND FINALLY I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IT PROVIDES IMPORTANT
VEHICLE TO CONTINUE THIS FIGHT
AND WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT WE
STRAIGHTEN THIS BILL BUT WE WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE STRAIGHTEN
IT TOGETHER AND I BELIEVE THAT
WE'LL GET THERE.
THE THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS OF I
APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER COOPER YOU WHAT NEXT
THANK CHAIRMAN ONLY THINK I
TRIMMING GREEN IS CLOCK JOINT
AUTHORS BRING THIS BILL FOR THIS
IMPORTANT. TO BRING IT IN LINE
WITHTHE WAY THE ENFORCEMENT
ALCOHOLS DONE IN BASICALLY WE'VE
DONE NOTHING FOR VAPING
WHATSOEVER.
SO DIED GOODNESS TO REVISIT THIS
THIS IS A START IT IS BETTER
THAN WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE NOT BEING A FORCES AN
ISSUE -- THE FDA SAYS THAT.
THEY BECAUSE BEEN SMOKING.
OBVIOUSLY YOU IN AMERICAN
SOCIETY SAYS ON THERE --
STATEMENT BASED ON CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE EVIDENCE USING.
CURRENT GENERATION CIGARETTES IS
LESS HARMFUL THAN SMOKING
CIGARETTES.
THE HEALTH EFFECTS A LONG TERM
USER NOT NO WE DON'T KNOW WE'LL
FIND OUT AT SOME POINT.
FORGOTTEN SOMETHING.
LIKE I SAID THEY HAVE THE
ALCOHOL STINGS AND THAT'S BEEN
DONE ALREADY TO ADDRESS THE
ALCOHOL ISSUE IN TEAMS BUT
NOTHING'S BEING DONE TO ADDRESS
A BABY ISSUE.
SO I THINK WITH THIS LEGISLATION
EXIST WHERE WE NEED TO BE.
I'VE GOT TIME TO MODIFY IT BUT
TO SIT HERE AND DO NOTHING.
IS UNACCEPTABLE.
WE'RE GONNA BE SOMETHING IS THE
VEHICLE I'M I'M SUPPORTIVE OF IT.
AND IT'S A START I GUESS IT IS
WORKING MOTION.
MISS WHEN THIS YOU HAVE A
QUESTION -- A COMMENT I WELL
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THE CHANGESTHAT YOU DID
TO THIS BILL WITH RESPECT TO THE
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS. FOR THE
FOR THE MINERS I THINK THAT WAS.
A WISE MOVE CERTAINLY THINK THAT
WILL PROBABLY GET YOU SOME MORE
VOTES IN THIS COMMITTEE -- I
JUST FOR ME THE STICKING POINT
IS.
BANNING THE FLAVORS BECAUSE I
GET SO MANY EMAILS FROM
CONSTITUENTS SAYING THIS HELPED
ME TO QUIT SMOKING DON'T TAKE
THIS CHOICE AWAY FROM ME DO WHAT
YOU CAN TO KEEP THE KIDS AWAY
FROM IT.
THAT'S THE STICKING POINT FOR ME --
AN ICE I MEAN I CAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING WHICH IS
THAT'S TERRIBLE THAT THE KIDS
ARE USING THEM AND OTHER PEOPLE
ARE HELPING THE MUSEUM BUT THAT
BUT I AM AN ADULT AND I GET TO
MAKE THIS DECISION THIS IS WHAT
IS HELP ME AND WE CERTAINLY WANT.
PEOPLE TO GET AWAY FROM SMOKING
CIGARETTES AND ON ON TO
SOMETHING THAT -- THE FDA SO FAR
HAS SAID WE BELIEVE IS CERTAINLY
LESS HARMFUL THAN REGULAR
TOBACCO PRODUCTS -- HAVE YOU I
KNOW YOU CHECK MADE ATTENDED
CHANGES TO THIS BILL I HATE TO
ASK THIS HAVE YOU CONTEMPLATED
AT ALL.
CHANGING THIS BAN ON THE FLAVORS
BECAUSE FOR MORE FOR MORE I SAY
YOU HAVE THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM RIGHT TO YOU CAN HAVE
20% AT LEAST OF THESE PLACES
CHECK TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
NOT SELLING IT -- YOU HAVE THE
INITIAL FIND -- THE ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL BURDEN WHICH WHICH I
THINK IS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO
FRANKLY I MEAN THE HEAD ON THE
FIRST TIME NOT THE THIRD TIME --
I THINK THAT'S IN IN AN
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN I THINK IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
CAN PUT ALL THE ENFORCEMENT OF
PLACE THAT WE WANT BUT IF.
IF IF THE SCHOOLS AREN'T TALKING
TO THE KIDS ABOUT THIS AND
THEY'RE NOT SEEING IT EVERYWHERE
JUST LIKE THEY SEE OTHER SIGNS
OF IN BUS STOPS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF SMOKING OR THE
DANGERS OF DROWNING OR YOU KNOW.
CAN SEE THIS STUFF IT'S IT ALL
WORKS IN CONCERT TOGETHER THAT
IS IMPORTANT.
BY.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE ALL
THOSE THINGS IN THE BILL I JUST.
CAN'T HELP BUT THINK THAT YOU
WOULD REALLY -- KIND OF
DISSOLVED A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT EXISTS RELATING
TO THE FLAVORS BECAUSE ADULTS
ARE FEELING LIKE.
THAT'S THE CHOICE THAT WE'RE
TAKING AWAY FROM THEM SO IF YOU
WANT TO COMMENT IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO GIVE WHERE SURETY THAT
TOTALLY FINE.
WITH ME -- IF YOU IF YOU DON'T
MIND SHERMAN AVENUE -- RESPOND
THAT WAS A QUESTION -- IT ALL
JUST BOTH KINDA WHICH GROUP
COMMENTS AS WELL AS THIS ONE
DOES -- YEAH WHEN WE MET WITH
THE MEMBER -- GROUP.
WITH THE A. B. C. AND APART
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WHAT WE WERE CONFRONTED WITH
WITH -- ABC WAS THAT THEY CAN
DOCTOR I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER
OFF THE TOP MAY HAVE A THIRTY TO
FORTY THOUSAND STING OPERATIONS --
PER YEAR.
AND WE'RE WITH THE PART PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SO HOW MANY STING
OPERATIONS YOU GUYS CONDUCTING.
THE ANSWER WAS I DON'T KNOW.
HERE MISTER COOPER LAUGHING BUT
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S CERTAINLY --
WAS KIND OF OUR RESPONSE TO IS
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE -- I DON'T
WANT TO I DON'T WANT TO PUT THAT
FULLY ON THE DOORSTEP OF THE
PART PUBLIC I THINK THE RESOURCE
ISSUES I THINK THERE'S SYSTEMIC
ISSUES THAT WE CAN BE OF
ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDE THEM THE
TOOLS. TO DO BETTER ENFORCEMENT
BUT IT CERTAINLY CALLS THE
QUESTION THAT WE NEED BETTER
ENFORCEMENT.
AND YEAH THAT THAT THAT'S THE
PROMISE OF THIS IS HOW DO WE
BALANCE THAT AND I THINK YOU
KNOW MISS ONE IS THAT I TEND TO
ERR ON THE SIDE OF ADULT CHOICE --
OUR PRODUCTS AND I STRUGGLED
WITH THAT MYSELF -- BUT WE ARE
WE HAVE -- AREAS OF LAW CHOCK
FULL OF EXAMPLES WHERE YOU HAVE
CONTROLLED PRODUCTS RIGHT THAT
WE DON'T NEED GETTING IN THE
HANDS OF KIDS THAT WE HAVE SOME
LIMITED.
AVAILABILITY OF COURSE SPECIAL
LOCATIONS TO PURCHASE AND
CERTAINLY BARS COME TO MIND
PHARMACIES -- AND OTHER EXAMPLES.
AND SO I I BELIEVE THIS BILL
DOES STRIKE TO BOUNCE BECAUSE
YOUR ABSOLUTE RIGHT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CESSATION
ESPECIALLY -- CESSATION PRODUCTS
THAT HELP PEOPLE TO GET OFF OF
TRADITIONAL TACKLE AND AND THERE
ARE EXAMPLES OF TESTIMONY --
THAT THIS IN FACT -- HAS HELPED
A LOT OF PEOPLE THESE PRODUCTS --
IT'S STILL AVAILABLE TO A LEGAL
ADULT ONLINE DIRECTLY FROM
MANUFACTURER TO YOUR HOME -- THE
COMBINATION OF OUR AGE
VERIFICATION TECHNOLOGY IN THE
BILL ALONG WITH SENATOR HILLS --
PROVISIONS IN HIS BILL WHICH
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR LATER TODAY
I THINK DO A GREAT DEAL TO
STRENGTHEN -- THE ACCESS TO KIDS
NAPA STILL PROVIDE A LEGAL
PRODUCT TO AN ADULT AND THEN ON
TOP OF THAT YOU HAVE --
LOCATIONS TOBACCO SLABS SLASH A
BAIT SHOPS -- WHERE THIS IS
AVAILABLE -- I THINK THOSE
LOCATIONS EXIST I CERTAINLY KNOW
THEY EXIST IN MY DISTRICT I
ASSUME THEY EXIST IN THE
DISTRICTS.
OF YOU ALL AS WELL AND SO I
THINK THOSE PRODUCTS WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO THOSE EVIL WE ARE
STRIKING A BALANCE HERE BETWEEN
YOUTH ACCESS.
AND POINT OF SALE -- FOR IN
FORSMAN AND ADULT AVAILABILITY
OF LEGAL PRODUCTS OKAY I JUST
WANTED I WANNA MAKE SURE I'M
CLEAR SO -- THE THE FLAVORS YOUR
LIVE YOUR BILL IS LIMITING THE
FLAVORS TO ONLY. THREE IS THAT
RIGHT.
OR ARE THEY ALL OKAY SO I KNOW
MISTER GALLAGHER SOMEBODY SAID
THAT EARLIER MAYBE WE SHOULD
CLARIFY THAT SO THE REFERENCE TO
THREE FLAVORS SEEMS TO BE.
A TRADITIONAL TOBACCO MET MET
BALL.
NOW THE FTA SEES THOSE IS
TRADITIONAL -- TOBACCO PRODUCTS
AND MOST OF US ARE AWARE THAT --
MENTAL SLASH BAD CIGARETTES BEEN
AROUND FOR DECADES -- AS WAS
JUST BACK ON THE FLAVORS THAT WE
ARE -- LIMITING -- TO THESE
SPECIFIC RETAIL LOCATIONS ONLINE
ALL THE OTHER FLAVORS RIGHT SO
FRUIT AND CUCUMBER AND CREME
BRULEE AND COOKIES AND CREAM --
COTTON CANDY YEAH THE THAT THESE
TYPES OF SPECIALTY FLAVORS --
THAT WOULD BE LIMITED TO WEAR
JUST ON THE LIMITED TO ONLINE
DIRECTLY FROM MANUFACTURER WITH
THE AGE VERIFICATION TECHNOLOGY
IN THE SIGNATURE -- END OR AT A
TOBACCO BAIT SHOP LOCATION WHICH
EXISTS IN I THINK ALMOST
EVERYONE OF OUR DISTRICT HAS
DIED WHEN THE COMMUNITIES THERE
ARE THOSE STORES SO YOU CAN GO
TO THE STORES YOU CAN LEGALLY BY
PARTY GOT TO BE TWENTY ONE TO
GET IN THE DOOR.
I DO HAVE A TWENTY ONE PERSON
RIGHT.
WHAT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
MILITARY IDEA WHICH I COVERED
EARLIER?
OKAY SO THEN JUST COULD YOU
CLARIFY THEN THIS DISCUSSION
WE'RE HAVING ABOUT MEN TO MENTAL
ON THOSE TRADITIONAL TOBACCO
FLAVORS WILL BE AVAILABLE.
IN ALL THE LICENSE RETAIL
LOCATIONS AS THEY ARE TODAY.
SO WALMART AND STUFF LIKE THAT
WHEREVER YOU CAN FIND THOSE
PRODUCTS TODAY YOU WOULD BE ABLE
TO FIND THEM -- AFTER THE
SIGNING OF THIS BILL AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL --
IF THEY ARE MEANT MENTAL OR
TRADITIONAL TOBACCO AND IF THEY
ARE BUBBLE GUM CAPTAIN CRUNCH
COTTON CANDY COOKIES AND CREAM
RATHER YOU MAY HAVE TO GO TO A
SPECIAL TO LOCATION.
OKAY GOT IT THAT IS HELPFUL
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT --
I WILL JUST ADD AS A FINAL
COMING BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S
GETTING LATE BUT THESE.
COMPANIES ARE TARGETING KIDS FOR
SURE NOT A SHAMEFUL.
SORRY THAT SHAMEFUL I HAVE.
OUR TWO YOUNGEST BOYS ARE MIDDLE
SCHOOLERS AND THAT STOPS
EVERYWHERE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
IT'S EIGHTY ARE I AM CERTAIN
THAT.
MANY OF THE PARENTS HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WITH THE FIND
IT IN THEIR KIDS BACKPACK AND I
TALKED OUR BOYS ABOUT IT AND
THEY GET IT THE WAY YOU KNOW WE
GOT.
STUFF LIKE THAT I GUESS WHEN WE
WERE KIDS WHICH IS YOU HAD
SOMEONE ELSE BY FORTY EXCEPT NOW
THEY'RE A LITTLE MORE
ENTREPRENEURIAL AND SPIRIT.
AND OTHER SELLING WITH THE
MARKUPS OUT THERE IS THAT BUT
THE I THINK THIS IS JUSTIFIED IN
GOING AFTER THE MANY FACTORS AS
MUCH AS WE CAN TO NOT TARGET.
KIDS AND NOT TRY TO GET THEM
HOOKED ON TO SOMETHING THAT --
ISN'T IT IS AN ADULT.
BEHAVIOR.
AND IF IF I MIGHT ADD ONE
ADDITIONAL COMMENT AND THIS ONE
IS THAT THAT YOU BRING TO MIND
WHICH IS MANY OF YOUR FROM OVER
THE MSA THE MATTER SETTLED
AGREEMENTS THAT WERE RESULT OF
TOBACCO LITIGATION.
MANY YEARS AGO AND SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE NATIONAL
AGREEMENTS AS IT RELATES TO
ADVERTISING TO USE ANOTHER.
DO NOT THE DHARMA PLUGGABLE --
TO THEY PEARY CIGARETTES RIGHT
SO THAT'S ONE OF THINGS WE ALSO
ACCOMPLISH THIS BILL AS WE APPLY
SOME OF THOSE ADVERTISING
RESTRICTIONS -- FURTHER
STRENGTHENED TODAY BY THE
MEMBERS WERE TAKING SPECIFIC --
TO SPORTING FACILITIESOTHER
VENUES THAT -- OBVIOUSLY HAVE A
DISPROPORTION NUMBER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN ATTENDANCE.
I JUST WANTED TO ALSO AND THAT --
YOU KNOW I TO HAVE YOUNG KIDS I
HAVE A TWELVE YEAR OLD AND A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD AND ACTUALLY
LATE LAST YEAR I ASKED MY
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD.
YOU KNOW OUR KIDS VAPING BECAUSE
I YOU KNOW I DON'T SMOKE AT ALL
I NEVER HAPPENED SO I REALLY
DIDN'T KNOW THAT MUCH ABOUT IT.
AND THE SIMILAR TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM SHE'S LIKE OH
MY GOD ARE YOU KIDDING ME THEY
DO IT ALL THE TIME IN BETWEEN
YOU KNOW GOING TO CLASS IN THE
HALLS LIKE CENTER.
YOU KNOW BUT FOR ME I DON'T SEE
IT BECAUSE I DON'T SMELL IT.
YOU KNOW AND SO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK ABOUT
BUT I ALSO ASKED HER OKAY SO
WELL WHAT KIND OF FLAVORS ARE
YOU USING BECAUSE I'M JUST NOW
LEARNING ABOUT THIS.
AND SHE TALKED ABOUT ALL OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE FLAVORS A
CUCUMBER THAN MEN.
YOU KNOW THE COTTON CANDY THOSE
ARE NOT TYPICAL FLAVORS ARE
YOU'RE GONNA BUY WHEN YOU'RE AN
ADULT GOING TO A STORE TO EITHER
GET VAPING.
JUICE OR TO BUY REGULAR TOBACCO
AND SO THIS IS REALLY YOUTH
CENTRIC I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO JUST SAY.
THAT IT'S A LUXURY TO BE A
PURIST WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LEGISLATION.
WE'VE HAD BILL REFORM BEFORE US
WE'VE HAD WILD FIRES BEFORE AS
WE'VE HAD RENT CONTROL BEFORE US
NONE OF THOSE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION WERE A 100% AMAZING
GRACE WHEN THEY CAME BEFORE US
BUT WE VOTED ON THOSE BILLS TO
KEEP THEM ALIVE TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ASKING THIS BODY TO CONSIDER AS
WE CONTINUE TO TACKLE A VERY.
DIFFICULT AND INVASIVE -- ISSUE
AN EPIDEMIC THAT'S HITTING ALL
OF US ACROSS ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SO -- SCENE NO ONE HAVING
RALLIED TO THE FOR MORE
QUESTIONS -- MR GRAY I BELIEVE
WE'VE HEARD THE TESTIMONY
PRESENTED -- THIS BILL IS DOES
ENJOYED TO PASS AS AMENDED --
PUSHING THIS -- ACTION ITEM OVER
TO THE HEALTH.
COMMITTEE I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT WILL BE ANOTHER SHIP SHOT
AT THIS BILL IN FACT I THINK YOU
HEARD SEVERAL COMMENTS MADE BY
MEMBERS ABOUT MAYBE MAKING A
TWEAK HERE AND THERE.
THAT YOU WOULD TAKE UNDER
CONSIDERATION AND AND TRY TO
MAKE THOSE HAPPEN -- IN
PARTICULAR THE SUNSET ISSUE --
SO WITH THAT SAID THE CHAIR
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION. TO TO
APPROVE THIS AND AS AMENDED AND
MOVED TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE MR
BONTA MAKES THAT MOTION.
DO I SEE A SECOND I SEE MR
COOLEY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
ADD TO A CLOSE.
ALL TAKE MISS COLOR DOES
COMMENTS AS MICHAEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL GRAY.
HI GRAY EYES A BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN NOT VOTING BONTA.
BONTA NOT VOTING BRO
[inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW I MATHIS.
MATHIS NONVOTING MELINDA.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE IT RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
THAT BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES SO
THAT BILL IS OUT -- THERE'S WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT
PARTICULAR BILL OFFER ABSENT
MEMBERS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MISTER HILL.
THANK YOU FOR BEING EVER SO
PATIENTS.
ON A YOUR PRESENTATION FOR YOUR
BILL YOU HAVE SB.
THIRTY NINE HERE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION YOU HAVE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE SUPPORT
SUPPORT ON IT SO MY DAD WOULD
SAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
AND FIRST OF ALL I DON'T KNOW
WHERE [inaudible]
OUR THIS IN MY CLOTHES -- I
WANTED TO WIN THE CHAIR -- OF
WINDS ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY GETS
BACK I DO WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT
OR TWO MAYBE I COULD DO THAT
WEBER WITNESS AND THEN MAY I
JUST WANTED. TO TO MENTION.
THAT HIS WORK ON THIS AND IF I
COULD ABSOLUTELY THE ENJOY SOME
PRAISE MAY NOT HAVE A WITNESS
FOR A AND THEN I COULD DO THAT
IF THAT'S IT'S REFLECTIVE THANK
YOU.
PLEASE YOU HAVE A AN INDIVIDUAL
DO YOU WANNA OPEN OR YOU WILL
GET NO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
IT'S SB THIRTY NINE WILL IMPOSE
STRICTER AGE VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. FOR TOBACCO
PRODUCTS SOLD ONLINE OR BY MAIL
AND TO I DO HAVE WITNESSES AND I
APPRECIATE THE MOTIONS ALREADY
THANK YOU THE SECOND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
PLEASE BEGIN.
I HIT THE LITTLE RED BUTTON
RIGHT.
THERE YOU GO -- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MELTING WHEN AND I'M A LOCAL
YOUTH ADVOCATE THE VOLUNTEERS
WITH BRIEF CALIFORNIANS
SACRAMENTO -- THIS AFTERNOON I'M
HERE TO SPEAK IN REGARDS -- TO
MY SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THIRTY
NINE ONE OF THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITIES I HAVE EVER BEEN
GIVEN IN MY LIFE WAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF THE HEALTH OF MIKE
SOCIETY.
AND ESPECIALLY THE HEALTH OF MY
GENERATION I JOIN BREED
CALIFORNIA AS A VOLUNTEER
BECAUSE I CAME TO THE
REALIZATION THAT THERE WAS A
PROBLEM IN MY COMMUNITY.
MY PEERS CLASSMATES AND CLOSEST
FRIENDS HAD FALLEN DOWN THE PATH
OF ADDICTION BECAUSE BY THESE
HORRIFIC TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
EACH DAY THAT I VOLUNTEER MY
TIME AND MY EFFORT. TO THIS
CAUSE IS DUE TO THE FACT THAT
ALL OF THESE FRIENDS THESE
CLASSMATESIN THESE YOUNG LOS
LIVES THAT I KNOW THAT I'VE
ENTERED A LIFETIME OF ADDICTION
DUE TO BIG TOBACCO AND THEIR
DEVIOUS MARKETING AND TACTICS.
BIG TOBACCO HAS LONG TARGETED
THE YOUTH AUDIENCE UP FROM
SMOKING CARTOON CHARACTERS IN
THE PAST IN NEWSWEEK ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES WITH THE MERRY OUT OF
FLAVORS THAT TARGET YOUTH IT IS
APPARENT THAT MY GENERATION AND
THE YOUTH OF CALIFORNIA -- BEING
TARGETED FOR PROFIT OFF OF OUR
SUFFERING IF I'M BEING BLATANTLY
HONEST NOW THESE TACTICS HAVE
COMPLETELY WORKED.
MY PEERS HAVE BEEN HYPNOTIZING
LOWERED BY THESE DEVICES THAT
RESEMBLE THEIR PHONES OR EVEN
THEIR WATCHES.
THEY'VE BEEN LEARNED BY THESE
ENTICING FLAVORS THAT REMIND
THEM OF THEIR CHILDHOOD SUCH AS
BLUE RASPBERRY OR FRUITY BLAST
NOW I AM UNABLE TO GO A DAY
WITHOUT HEARING TALKS ABOUT
THESE ALLURING FLAVORS.
ARE GETTING A PLUME OF VAPOR
BLOWN IN MY FACE IN THE BATHROOM
AT SCHOOL.
I HEAR TALK FROM MY PEERS ABOUT
HOW SIMPLE IT IS FOR THEM TO BUY
THESE -- ADDICTIVE PRODUCTS BY
BUYING THEM ONLINE THEY SIMPLY
ENTER THEIR CREDIT CARD AND PUT
IN THEIR ADDRESS AND SOON ENOUGH
THERE IS IT THEIR ADDICTION IS
REFILLED WHAT WE NEED NOW IS
CHANGE AND THIS BILL WILL MAKE
IT HARDER FOR E. CIGARETTES
FLAVOR CARTRIDGES.
AND TOBACCO PRODUCTS AS A WHOLE
TO FALL INTO MY PEERS LAPS AND
FOR THAT WILL MAKE THEIR HEALTH
BETTER IN THEIR OVERALL LIVES
BETTER SO I BEG OF YOU TODAY TO
VOTE I ON SENATE BILL THIRTY
NINE FOR ME.
MY CLASSMATES MY PEERS AND TRULY
FOR THE GREATER FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR THAT TESTIMONY.
AT THIS TIME DO WE HAVE FURTHER
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
MR MEMBERS TO MATT AND REVERSING
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THEN THE PREVIOUS
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AT PROUD CO SPONSOR
HERE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN GARY COOPER
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ORAL AND
MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS IN
SUPPORT.
EXACTLY CORPS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE OTHER
CALIFORNIA FEELS INCONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE POLITICIAN I GET OUR
LETTER AND ON TIME BUT WE DO
SUPPORT.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
STROKE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
PROUD BECAUSE SPONSORED.
TIM GIVES AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
PROUD BECAUSE SPONSORS WELL.
RONALD KOEMAN HERE WE HAVE A TO
HELP TEXAS CALIFORNIA ALSO HERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT SPENCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND SPORT.
CHAU GIVENS OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MORNING KERR HALL AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
YOU CAN VALLEY'S STUDENT OF RIO
AMERICANO HIGH SCHOOL IN SUPPORT.
OKAY WE HAVE -- ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION.
WELL CENTER LOOKS LIKE A GOOD
JOB.
OKAY SEE NO OPPOSITION LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
[inaudible]
WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DID IF
I MAY CLOSE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION AND FOR THE
MEETINGS THAT WE'VE HAD IN YOUR
OFFICE AND DISCUSSION AT THE
STAKEHOLDERS YOU BROUGHT
TOGETHER -- THIS IS SOMETHING I
THINK WE BOTH AGREE ON THAT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE THIS
YEAR.
THIS EPIDEMIC NEEDS TO STOP AND
I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT AND HARD
WORK -- AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
THIS CONVERSATION WILL CONTINUE
AS IS IT HAS AND AS WE IT'S
INVOLVED.
IN THAT -- WE CONTINUE HAVING
THAT SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
OPEN THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU CENTER.
SO MEMBERS WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER BONTA IN A SECOND FROM
MISTER REED.
AND THIS IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GRAY HI GRAY I'D
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BROUGH.
GROW HI COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
UBER IDEALLY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER ALL I JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
WELL I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIVAS.
RIVAS I'D RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
THANKS.
TO CENTER THAT HAS TWENTY ONE
VOTES IN THE BILL'S OUT WE'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED --
DISCUSSIONS OF PARTNERSHIP IN
TRYING TO MOVE THESE ISSUES FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR FUTURE
THANK YOU COLLEGE.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE GONNA
WELCOME. TO THE DIETS.
ARE OTHER SENATE -- PARTNER IN
THIS ISSUE -- WHO HAS SB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT CENTER RUBIO
APPRECIATE -- HER PARTICIPATION
LEADERSHIP WITHIN OUR NUMBER TO
MEMBER DIALOGUE AND THIS BILL
THAT SHE'S BRING WERE FORCED.
TO SECOND.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
SET.
THANK YOU FOR THE VOTE OF
CONFIDENCE ALREADY BAD TINO --
WITHOUT THESE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING SINCE ONE O'CLOCK SO ON
A GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY. TO TO
PRESENT HERE WITH ME TODAY SO
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE I
WILL BE ACCEPTING JUST AMENDMENT
ON CLARIFICATION LANGUAGE -- SO
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WILL
REQUIRE ELECTRONIC CIRCUIT
MANUFACTURERS TO SUBMIT A
PHYSICAL DESCRIPTION AND
PHOTOGRAPH OF EACH TYPE OF
DEVICE THEY SELL TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
AND IMPOSE A REASONABLE FEE ON
MANUFACTURERS TO COVER THEIR
DEPARTMENTS COSTS OF
ADMINISTERING.
THE PROGRAM.
OUR DESPITE LAWS PROHIBITING THE
SALE OF ELECTRONICS CIGARETTES
TO PEOPLE UNDER TWENTY ONE YEARS
OF AGE THAT THEY USE HOUSE
RAPIDLY BEEN INCREASING.
WE ARE SEEING DEVICES ON THE
MARKET THAT LOOK LIKE USB PORTS
FLASH DRIVES AND EVEN PENS
COMMON OBJECTS THAT EASILY GO
UNDETECTED.
I KNOW WE'VE HAD A BIG
DISCUSSION RIGHT NOW ABOUT TO
BACK COOL AND HOW THEY'RE
TARGETING CHILDREN JUST HAVE BY
WAY OF EXAMPLE AND MY TEACHER
COLLEAGUES UP HERE ON THE DíAS.
YOU KNOW NOW THEY HAVE LIKE
HIGHLIGHTERS THIS IS ONE OF THE
OBJECTS THIS IS WHAT OUR
HIGHLIGHTERS LOOK IN THE
CLASSROOM.
THIS LOOKS LIKE A PHONE BATTERY.
IF WE GO BY.
KEEP OUR VOICES DOWN JUST A
LITTLE BIT AND SHOW RESPECT TO
OUR SENATE DOT COM THANK YELL AT
AND THIS I'VE SEEN IN THE
CLASSROOM OUR KIDS USE
MECHANICAL PENCILS.
THIS IS A LITTLE CASE THAT LOOKS
LIKE WE PUT THE PENCILS AND SITE
SO CLEARLY THEY ARE TARGETING
OUR CHILDREN THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
THEY'RE ON BRING THAT TO THE
CLASSROOM AND NOT IN FOR
TEACHERS IS REALLY DIFFICULT TO
DETECT THE SIDE I'M CELL SO ONCE
AGAIN MY EXPERIENCE INFORMS MY
DECISION IN THIS BILL IN TERMS
OF NOT KNOWING WHAT TO LOOK --
FOR I'VE HAD PEOPLE ASK WELL
CAN'T THEY GOOGLE THE ITEM BUT
I'M NOT A SMOKER EITHER AND I
DON'T HAVE CHILDREN SO.
I WOULD HAVE NO REASON TO BE
GOOGLE THE ITEMS THAT THE
PERTAIN TO TO EIGHTEEN AND SO
AGAIN THESE ITEMS CAN EASILY BE
HIDDEN IN THE CLASSROOM IN THE
BACK OF THE LIBRARY.
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE INSURE THAT TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS AND ADMINISTRATORS.
ARE -- AWARE OF WHAT KIND OF
PRODUCTS TO LOOK FOR SO ANY HELP
TODAY I WANT -- TO GIVE MEGAN
FOR A LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS TO ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AN AUNT --
CORE A PARENT ADVOCATE FROM THE
ANTI VAPING ALLIANCE HAVE WE CAN.
HEAR THEM FOR A LITTLE BIT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS MEGAN FOR IT I'M A
NEWLY GRADUATED SENIOR FIRMWARE
AMERICANO HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
PROUD TO BE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR RUBIO.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE WITH ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES AS WELL AS WHAT I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT THEM.
A FEW YEARS AGO I DON'T KNOW
ANYONE MY AGE TO USE ELECTRONIC
TOBACCO PRODUCTS NO WHAT I HAVE
EVER CONSIDERED USING ONE MYSELF.
I BECAME FAMILIAR WITH THE NEWER
SLEEKER VAPES ABOUT A YEAR AGO
WHEN A FRIEND TAUGHT ME HOW TO
ONE HELL TO GET A HEAD RUSH --
BONDS FROM HIS PREVIOUS PRIOR.
THIS WAS A TINY METALLIC BOX
THAT FIT IN OUR HANDS AND WAS
DISCREET ENOUGH TO HIT IN
CROWDED RESTAURANTS WITH THEIR
PARENTS THE NEXT ROOM AND
EVENTUALLY EVEN DURING CLASS.
IT HONESTLY DID SEEM HARMLESS
REST OF THE TIME AND IT TASTED
LIKE GREEN APPLE.
WHAT I DIDN'T REALIZE BACK THEN
WAS THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
CHEMICALS IN TORRANCE CIGARETTES
MAY NOT INJURED MAY NOT EXISTING
PAGES MOST BRANDS OF JEWS STILL
CONTAIN CARCINOGENIC SUBSTANCES
AS WELL AS INCREDIBLY
CONCENTRATED AMOUNTS OF NICOTINE
THAT I GOT ADDICTED TO VERY
QUICKLY?
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THE RUSH I
FELT WAS DUE TO NICOTINE
INCREASING MY DOPAMINE
ADRENALINE LEVELS MY BLOOD
PRESSURE AND MY HEART RATE.
AND I CERTAINLY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT I WOULD
EVENTUALLY NEED AFFECTS IN ORDER
FOR MY BODY AND BRAIN TO
FUNCTION NORMALLY.
THERE'S SO MUCH WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE AFFECTS OF THE
CIGARETTES AND WITH THE
CONCENTRATE ACTION OF NEWER AND
MORE DISCRETE DEVICES SOME DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
HELP EDUCATE THE GENERAL PUBLIC
MORE SPECIFICALLY TEACHERS AND
PARENTS ON WHAT TO LOOK FOR IN
THEIR CLASSROOMS AND HOMES.
PUTTING DESCRIPTIONS AND PHOTOS
OF EVERYDAY DEVICE ON THE MARKET
AND SENDING THIS INFORMATION OUT
TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HELP EDUCATORS AND
PARENTS REALIZE.
WHAT EXACTLY THEIR KIDS ARE
USING AND TAKES STEPS TO HELP
THE KIDS REALIZE WHAT USING WILL
DO TO THEM?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE THE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRAY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS A IN DELCO OR A
SCHOOL VOLUNTEER AND PARENT OF
THREE TEENAGERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M PROUD TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
RUBIO IS.
SB.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT SEXY SLEEK.
AND SECRETLY HIDDEN IN THE
POCKETS BACKPACKS AND SLEEVES OF
OUR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
HOW COULD WE HAVE KNOWN THAT THE
SMALL VAPING DEVICES COULD
DELIVER SUCH A DEVASTATING BLOW
TO THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
OUR CHILDREN?
SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHTHS NEW
DESCRIPTION AND PHOTO
REQUIREMENTS OF ELECTRONIC
SMOKING DEVICES WILL ALLOW THE
FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE FOR
PARENTS TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
SO THAT WE MAY HAVE A MEANS OF
EARLY INTERVENTION IN THE MIDST
OF THIS TEENAGE BEEPING EPIDEMIC.
I VOLUNTEER AT RIO AMERICANO
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE SAN JUAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IN RESPONSE TO HIGH SUSPENSION
RATES STUDENTS WITH NICOTINE
POISONING OR AN ADDICTION
COUNSELING AND FRUSTRATED SCHOOL
PERSONNEL I CREATED THE ANTI
VAPING ALLIANCE.
AND HAVE BEGUN A MULTI PRONGED
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THIS HEALTH
CRISIS.
WE HAVE ON ENDING WORK TO DO.
SOME STUDENTS AND PARENTS IN OUR
GROUPS IN OUR GROUP CAME TO THE
CAPITOL LAST WEEK.
WE PUSH.
EXCUSE ME WE PUSHED AROUND A
CART FILLED WITH THESE
CONFISCATED VAPING DEVICES FROM
TO AREA HIGH SCHOOLS.
WE MET WITH SEVERAL STAFFERS AND
LAWMAKERS IN NEARLY EVERY PERSON
WE MET IN THE OFFICES IN THE
LUNCH ROOM AND IN THE ELEVATOR
SOFT THREE OR MORE DEVICES THAT
THEY HAD NEVER SEEN BEFORE ON
THAT CART. FOR OUR STUDENTS.
STUDENTS USE OF THESE DEVICES
WILL DO IT WILL DAMAGE THE
SYNAPTIC DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR
BRAINS AND CAN DELIVER A
LIFETIME OF ADDICTION.
RIGHT NOW THESE DEVICES ARE
WREAKING HAVOC IN OUR SCHOOLS.
TURNING OUR BATHROOMS LOCKER
ROOMS AND CLASSROOMS INTO VAPE
ROOMS.
WHETHER DEVICE MANUFACTURERS
DESIGN THESE TO BE DISCREET.
OR DESIGN THEM TO BE DECEPTIVE
WE MUST REQUIRE THEM TO PROVIDE
PHOTOS AND DESCRIPTIONS WE HAVE
TO KNOW WHAT WE'RE LOOKING.
FOR WE WEREN'T PREPARED FOR THIS
EPIDEMIC AND MAKE NO MISTAKE
YOUTH VAPING PREVENTION.
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENT IN
THE LARGER STRATEGY BUT WITH
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
YOU WILL BE ARMING US WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED THAT
WILL HELP US PROTECT THE HEALTH
OF OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY SUPPORT
TODAY.
MORNING CARVALLO AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
EXACTLY COR ABOUT CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
GARY COOPER REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ORAL AND
MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS IN
SUPPORT.
BLAKESHELTON ONLY A MEMBER OF
THE INTERFAITH ALLIANCE IN THE
STUDENT AT RIO AMERICANO ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY ADICIONAL TESTIMONY SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE ANYONE HERE
TODAY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST
WANT TO KNOW -- SO IT REQUIRES A
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO CONDUCT
A PUBLIC OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO
NOTIFY THE SCHOOLS DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE SCHOOLS TO THEN
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
PARENTS.
BUT IS IS THERE FUNDING ATTACHED
TO THIS BIRD.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
DO THIS OUT REACH.
WELL THEY'RE ALREADY OVERSEE A
LOT OF DEPARTMENTS THAT ALREADY
ARE IN PLACE AT THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR THE WAY WE WANTED TO
APPROACH IT IS COST NEUTRAL WE
WANT THE MANUFACTURERS.
TO REGISTER EACH NEW PRODUCT
THAT COMES WITH THE FEE AND THAT
FEW WILL GO TOWARDS -- THE OF
THE COST OF EDUCATING THE PUBLIC.
SO YOU THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE
ENOUGH NEW PRODUCTS INTRODUCED
THAT WOULD COVER THAT FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH.
NOTIFYING EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE STATE.
SO IT'S NOT NECESSARILY ABOUT
NOTIFYING THE THE ENTIRE --
STATE IT'S WE WANT TO HAVE A
CENTRALIZED -- WEBSITE WHERE WE
CAN POST ALL THE ITEMS AND THEN
SCHOOLS WILL BE NOTIFIED THAT
THEY KIND.
OF LOOK WHAT TO LOOK FOR WE'RE
ALSO WORKING ON HAVING -- THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS REQUIRE THAT
THE PAGE WITH ALL THE PRODUCTS
BE POSTED ON THE AND THE STAFF
LOUNGE I WAS A TEACHER BEFORE
YOU KNOW WE SIT THERE WE EAT AND
WE HAVE CAL OSHA AND ALL THESE
REQUIREMENTS.
IT WOULD BE REALLY SIMPLE TO PUT
UP A POSTER OF ALL THE PRODUCTS
OR THEY CAN SEE IS JUST A WAY OF
POINTING PARENTS TO A WEBSITE
WHERE THEY CAN FIND PRODUCTS.
AND THAT'S GOING TO TAKE A
LITTLE TIME TO INFORM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND HAVE THEM POSTED
BUT IT REALLY IS GOING TO BE
MINIMAL COST TO THIS.
OKAY I THINK YEAH.
WELL NORMALLY WE DON'T ALLOW
THIS FORM OF NEPOTISM BUT WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW -- MYSTERY WOULD
ASK MISS RUBIO QUESTION.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M A VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY AS A FORMER
SCHOOL TEACHER.
JUST THE PRODUCTS THAT YOU
PASSED AROUNDWHAT THEY WERE
INCREDIBLE I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT
EVEN THE THE FLASH DRIVES OR
EVEN THAT THE US BE -- DEVICES
WERE PART OF THAT SO I WOULD BE
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS -- COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
OKAY SAYING NOW AND WE HAVE A
MOTION.
WE HAVE MOTION FOR MISTER COOLEY
A SECOND MR SALAS THE THIRD FROM
THIS RUBIO.
AND SECTOR PLEASE CARLOS'S DO
PAST SIX TO COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
GRAY HI GRAY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
UBER I DAILY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
THE BILL HAS NINETEEN VOTES
THANK YOU CENTER I DON'T WANT.
ANY I'M ALL SET I AFTER THEY
SAID RUBIO AFTER LIKE.
I HAVE TO TAKE IT BACK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND JUST A
SIDE NOTE I JUST SAW STABLER
THAN US PRODUCT SO WE NEED TO
REALLY LOOK OUT FOR KIDS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
SENATOR.
OKAY MEMBERS WE HAVE -- GOTTEN
THROUGH ALL OF OUR BUSINESS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA BUT WE DO HAVE A
FEW OPEN ITEMS.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START WITH
THE ITEM NUMBER ONE ON YOUR
AGENDA AND WE WILL ROLL THROUGH
ALL.
FOURTEEN SUCH A PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ACR ONE OR TWO
ITEM. ONE FIVE POINTS OUT.
BONTA I AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE RIVAS.
RIVAS ALRIGHT.
OKAY ITEM TO ON THE AGENDA.
SB FIFTY THREE WELL -- SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BONTA BONTA AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON HI JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I RIVAS.
RIVAS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
THE BILL HAS TWENTY VOTES.
ITEM. THREE THREE ON THE AGENDA
SB FIFTY EIGHT WIENER THIS BILL
IS ON CALL SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BONTA.
BONTA I COOLEY.
PRODUCE COOLEY VOTED PREVIOUSLY
VOTED NO [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO NOT VOTING SALAS.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL PUT
THAT BACK ON CALL [inaudible]
FIVE ITEM. FIVE SP ONE SIXTY
NINE THIS IS SENATOR JACKSON'S
BILL IT'S ON CALL -- SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BONTA.
BONTA I COOPER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D LOW
[inaudible]
RIVAS.
RIVAS I SALAS.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES WILL
PUT IT BACK ON CALL -- MEMBERS
REMOVING THE ITEM SEVEN ON YOUR
AGENDA SP FOUR SIXTY FIVE BATES --
SEARCHER PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
A BUT ALL OF THEM.
YEAH SHE'S DONE.
PREVIOUS SPELL SB ONE SIXTY NINE
ITEM FIVE AGUIAR-CURRY IS NOT
VOTING.
MEASURES SEVEN FOUR SIXTY FIVE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BONTA.
BONTA I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
THE BILL HAS TWENTY VOTES IS OUT.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS REMOVED
ITEM TEN ON YOUR GENDER THIS IS
SB SIX SEVENTY MCGUIRE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA I'D [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
RIVAS.
RIVAS ALL RIGHT.
THE BILL HAS TWENTY VOTES -- IT
IS OUT WE'RE NOW ON ITEM ELEVEN
MEMBERS THIS IS SB SEVEN ONE
SEVEN JONES.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I ONCE SAW.
BONTA AYE GARCIA [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
RIVAS AYE.
THE BILL HAS EIGHTEEN VOTES IN
HIS OUT WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM --
TWELVE ON THE AGENDA THIS IS.
AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE GRAY
CUNNINGHAM AND RIVAS -- SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BRO.
BRO I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THE BILL HAS.
FIFTEEN ITEM THIRTEEN ON YOUR
GENDER MEMBERS SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON ALL RIGHT.
THAT.
HAS.
TWENTY ONE S. ITEM FORTY MEMBERS
SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GARCIA [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible] NINETY THAT HAS
NINETEEN IN THIS OUT -- WILL
MOVE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
[inaudible]
LOW.
LOW AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I RIVAS.
RIVAS ALL RIGHT -- THE BILL HAS
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN EXCUSE ME EVER
HAS -- EIGHTEEN OKAY MEMBERS
THAT CONCLUDES ALL OF OUR
BUSINESS WE HAVE -- TO TO ITEM
STILL ON CALL -- ITEM THREE SB
FIFTY EIGHT WIENER -- SECRETARY
PLEASE -- CALL THE RECALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON ITEM THREE SB
FIFTY EIGHT WIENER.
ITEM THREE SB [inaudible]
FIFTY EIGHT GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible] EIGHT BLOCK.
LET'S MOVE TO ITEM FIVE ON YOUR
AGENDA SB ONE SIXTY NINE JACKSON --
THIS.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SB ONE SIXTY NINE ITEM FIVE
COOPER.
GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE GIPSON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
SALAS
.
SO LET'S --
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH -- ONE MORE TIME ON THE
AGENDA STARTING WITH ITEM. ONE
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL ADD ON
SERVICE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THIS IS ACR ONE
OR TWO BIGELOW.
GARCIA ALL RIGHT.
GARCIA I THE BILL HAS SIXTEEN
ITEM TO SB FIFTY THREE WILK THIS
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GARCIA I ITEM THREE SB -- FIFTY
EIGHT LET'S ON CALL IT'S GO ITEM --
ITEM SEVEN SP FOUR SIXTY FIVE
BATES CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SERICEA.
HI GARCIA HI [inaudible]
ITEM.
ITEM TEN SB SIX SEVENTY MCGUIRE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GARCIA.
AYE GARCIA AYE.
ITEM ELEVEN SB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
JONES PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GARCIA. FIVE GARCIA HI ITEM
TWELVE AB TEN THIRTY NINE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT'S GREAT -- ITEM TWELVE A.
B. [inaudible]
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE GALLAGHER.
GARCIA HI GARCIA I ITEM THIRTEEN
SB THIRTY NINE HILL PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS GARCIA.
HI GARCIA ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
ITEM.
FOURTEEN SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
RUBIO.
GARCIA I ALSO ASKED IF I COULD --
AT IS IS CAUGHT UP TO THE BILL.
TWO FIVE THIRTY EIGHT CORRECT.
OKAY AND BRINGS OF NOTRE DAME
THANK YOU HELLO.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA RETURN NO
MEMBERS THE ITEMS ON CALL ITEM
THREE SB FIFTY EIGHT WIENER --
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GARCIA AYE.
GARCIA AYE [inaudible]
SALAS.
OUT THE BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES IT
IS OUT.
ITEM FIVE ON THE AGENDA SB ONE
SIX NINE JACKSON.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
MR.
CALL IT.
SB ONE SIXTY NINE ITEM FIVE
SALAS ALRIGHT.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES.
SENATOR SEEING THE ABSENCE OR IS
A THE ABSENCE OF THE VOTES DO
YOU WANT TO NOTICE
RECONSIDERATION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEMBERS.
SAY NO JACKSON RECONSIDERATION
NOTED.
WITH THAT MEMBERS WE ONE OF THE
OKAY MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS AYE CHEN DAY WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
TWO MINUTES FOR MEMBERS TO MAKE
VOTE CHANGES RATS.
THANK YOU.
EXCEPT FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
GARCIA.
HI GARCIA I
WE'LL TALK MORE THAN.
WITH THAT GEO IS A JERK